Seeing that the board members are now present, Karen, will you please call the roll to establish
a quorum?
Yes.
Good morning.
Patricia Rucker.
Here.
Brenna Pangelinan.
Jim McQuillan.
Here.
Ting Sun.
Eileen Strauss.
Here.
Linda Darling-Hammond.
Cynthia Glover-Woods.
Here.
Matt Navo.
Ade Rodriguez.
Here.
Kim Patil-Bronson.
Okay.
We're all present.
Well, I hereby call the roll to establish a quorum.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay.
Well, I hereby call the July 2020 meeting of the State Board of Education to order at
839 a.m.
I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Vice President Strauss, you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Would you all please rise?
Right hand over your heart.
Ready.
Begin.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for
which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
You may be seated.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And I'd like to begin this morning by swearing in our three wonderful new state board members.
And then after that, I will actually more properly introduce them.
And we are going to go in alphabetical order.
I'm going to start with Cynthia Glover Woods.
And as I say, I'll introduce everyone more properly after we've gotten them officially
sworn in.
And so, Cynthia, will you please raise your right hand and repeat after me?
I, Cynthia Glover Woods, do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States against all enemies,
foreign and domestic.
That I will support and defend the Constitution against all enemies.
Foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United States.
And the Constitution of the State of California.
That I take this obligation freely without any mental reservation.
Or purpose of evasion.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which I am about to enter.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties.
Upon which I am about to enter.
Thank you very much, Dr. Glover Woods.
Welcome to the State Board.
Thank you very much.
And I, as I say, I will introduce you in just a moment.
But first I want to swear in Jim McQuillen.
Jim, can you please raise your right hand and repeat after me.
I, Jim McQuillen.
Do solemnly swear that I will support and defend.
The Constitution of the United States against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
The Constitution of the United States against all enemies, foreign or domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United States.
And the Constitution of the State of California.
That I take this obligation freely.
that I take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion,
and that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties,
and I will well and faithfully discharge the duties
upon which I am about to enter,
upon which I'm about to enter.
Thank you very much and welcome to the State Board.
Thank you.
And then, last but not least, Aide Rodriguez.
There you are, Aide,
to find you in my Hollywood squares here.
Please raise your right hand and repeat after me.
I, Aide Rodriguez, do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend
the Constitution of the United States.
Against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance
to the Constitution of the United States.
to the Constitution of the United States
and the Constitution of the State of California
and the Constitution of the State of California.
That I take this obligation freely.
That I take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion.
Without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties.
Upon which I am about to enter.
Congratulations and welcome to the state board.
Thank you.
And now let me give a little bit of an introduction
and opportunity for each of these new board members
to say a few words to us.
Each of these folks was appointed
by Governor Newsom earlier this week.
Cynthia Glover Woods is the chief academic officer
at the Riverside County Office of Education.
She has been a teacher, an elementary principal,
the coordinator of professional development,
a curriculum specialist,
and an assistant superintendent in Compton and Alford
before adjoining the Riverside County Office of Education.
She currently chairs
the Curriculum and Instruction Committee of SESSA
and as a member of CASA and ACSA
and a very active participant in education in our state.
Cynthia, welcome.
And I'd love to invite you
to offer a couple of comments to yourself.
Thank you so much, Governor Brown-Hammond.
And again, good morning to everyone.
I will be very brief, but I just want for all to know,
I am humbled and honored to have an opportunity
to serve the students, families, and educators
in the state of California.
It is an awesome opportunity to be able to work
with all of the State Board of Education board members
as we shape education and support our students
to be the best that they can be.
So thank you so much for this opportunity.
We're delighted to have you with us.
And Jim McQuillen is the education director
for the Yurok Tribe.
He has degrees in a master's degree in psychology.
He's a people personnel credential.
He's been very involved in supporting programs
from pre-K all the way through high school
and even support for college students
across the whole education continuum.
He's also been American Indian education administrator
and consultant for the Del Norte Unified School District
and has had a variety of roles in our education system.
So Jim, would you like to say a few words and welcome?
I would say Skuyanukoi and Ayakwe
in the Yurok language that's greetings and good morning.
So I'm very pleased to be in this position
for the state of California in supporting
and being here for all of our students.
We're in very unusual times right now.
And I really think that we need to be very creative
in keeping our students connected
and helping them social emotionally, stay connected.
I'm just so pleased to be here and honored
to work with all of you and be here
for the state of California and our students.
So thank you.
Welcome, welcome.
And Iday Rodriguez, Iday is currently a teacher
at Central Union High School.
She is a national board certified teacher,
which is a very high accomplishment
in the teaching profession
and has served on the board of the national board itself.
She comes to us from the California
Teacher Credentialing Commission.
She is additionally the director
for the AVID program in her school.
And Iday, we're just thrilled to have you.
Would you like to say a few words?
Thank you so much.
And also, you know, I'd like to echo
what Jim and Cynthia just said.
I'm humbled and this is a great honor.
As I was reading the agenda and preparing for the meeting,
I found it a harbinger of, you know, good fortune
that we're looking at the framework for theater
and world language because I've taught both theater
and world language.
And so, you know, I was looking at that through that frame.
I'm excited to be a classroom teacher
and to be able to serve as a bridge,
you know, with my colleagues
and what's happening on the ground
and the decisions that we make here.
So I'm very honored and humbled to be here.
Thank you.
Great to have you.
I'd also like to announce in a bittersweet announcement
that this is our student board member,
Brenna Pangolinan's last meeting with us.
But the good news is she's been accepted
to Brown University to pursue a degree
in behavioral decision science.
I'm not sure what that is,
but I think we probably need it in the state board.
So after you figure out how to help us make decisions,
you can come back and teach us that.
So please join me in thanking Brenna for her service.
And Brenna, please feel free to say a few words.
Thank you so much.
I first just wanted to say thank you
to the board for this opportunity.
You have all been so supportive
and welcoming to me throughout this year.
You have all motivated me to do better.
You are also accomplished in your respective fields
and everyone here has truly chosen to make a difference.
And your passion and your leadership has inspired me.
And I am so grateful to have witnessed that passion
because I can enter this next chapter in my life,
knowing what's possible with the right values.
So I thank you all for that.
I also wanna say thank you to the staff
who was always willing to help me.
It is definitely intimidating as a student
to enter this position.
And if you don't learn fast enough, you fall behind.
So what has made that easier is everyone here willing
to be patient and tell me what I wouldn't have known before
so I could really learn and grow.
And I could not have gotten throughout this year
without your guidance and support.
So thank you so much.
I wanted to share one thing.
It was kind of one of my favorite memories
that I believe summarizes the mindset of this board
that I really appreciated.
And it was really small, but something that board member
or Feasley Cohen said during a discussion.
And she apologized for being impatient.
It was very simple
that she apologized for being impatient.
And of course, everything that happens here takes time.
And it's a process because it affects so many people.
However, I think being impatient is a beautiful thing
when it comes to improving people's lives and education.
And I think that's a common mindset
amongst all the board members here.
In so many discussions, this board pushes forward
to not settle for the status quo.
So I really appreciate that.
And impatience is necessary to make change.
And I've learned that from this board.
So I thank you so much.
Like President Linda Dollingham said,
I'll be attending Brown University.
And I'm grateful to take all the lessons
that I've learned into this next chapter.
So I'm very motivated after this year.
And I thank you all for helping me and supporting me.
And I'm just so grateful for the opportunity.
So thank you so much.
It's been great to have you.
Does anyone want to add any comments to Brenna
as she takes this next step in her journey?
Wait, go ahead.
No, I just wanted, this is Board Member Navo.
Brenna, I just want to tell you, I greatly appreciate you.
You have taught me a lot about how far behind I was
as a high school student.
And you've taught me a lot about student perspective,
which I really appreciate.
And I think sometimes it's easy to forget.
We spend a lot of time planning and thinking
We spend a lot of time planning and having conversations
about what's best for students.
We oftentimes forget their voice matters.
And you have brought that to bear here.
And I appreciate it very much.
You'll be missed.
I think we all share in those sentiments
and we wish you all the very, very best.
And please come back and teach us behavioral decision science
when you've learned it.
Linda, Patricia Rucker has her hand up too to make comment.
Oh, great, thank you.
Good morning, Brenna.
We spent a lot of time as neighbors
during the board meetings when we were physically meeting.
And it was always a pleasure to sit and talk with you.
But also it was always for me with great admiration
and all that I listened to your comments, your questions
and the concerns that you raised.
It's amazing to me to think about the fact
that you're going to be leaving and going off
and representing all of us here
when you go to Brown and go back East
and you'll bring that West Coast perspective
to the East Coast.
But more importantly, this is an exciting time
not only to be from California, but to be in California
and be involved in the decisions and the policies
that you had a hand in making.
So even though it was only for a very short time,
I really wanna make sure that everyone who knows you
and everyone we send you forth out into the world to me
recognizes and understands not only the power of your voice
but the influence that you were able to wield
and the role model that you served for the students
from the various student councils
and student leadership positions across the state
that you had a chance to work with.
Because believe it or not, as people came in contact
with you, particularly those students,
they were aware of just how important
the work you were doing.
And they also wanted to follow in your footsteps.
With great awe and respect and admiration
that I congratulate you and take care
and have a wonderful life.
That's great.
And I wanna commend member Rucker
for using the raise your hand function
which shows up in our little participant box.
You can do that or you can raise your hand physically.
I'm seeing you and trying to watch that box
to recognize folks and Karen will be at my backup
as we saw.
Linda, Tony and Ting would like to say something.
Okay, great.
Madam President, I'll wait until after the board members
have spoken, but thank you.
Okay, Ting.
Hi.
Yes, so Brenna, I just wanted to add my congratulations
to you and wish you a great journey in your college career.
I so admire you.
I really have, you have a fan for life.
And this was kind of brought to home for me
when I heard you on an Ed source interview.
And I was so blown away.
I've been blown away by your maturity,
how smart you are and your articulation.
And in that interview, I was literally listening to it
and dancing up and down and so proud of you
and the work that you've done on this board.
So I wish you the best of luck.
I'm so glad to have known you
and have worked with you this last year.
And I hope to follow you as you go to college in your career.
Okay, Tony.
No, we have Eileen and then Tony, Linda.
Okay, thank you.
I'm trying to figure out how to manage the chat,
the participants and the Hollywood squares.
And I haven't mastered it yet.
I think it's great when you have Karen backing you up.
It's really helpful. Yes.
So Bren, I just wanted to say,
I just so appreciate you came onto the board
as such an experienced board member
with your experience in your local school district,
which really right from the beginning,
you contributed, you had comments,
you had thoughts and perspectives.
And I so appreciate you working to try to make sure
we have student board members in our local districts.
I know that's a mission of yours and that they be trained
and have an important voice in their local work
as well as at the state level.
And so I just think from your work across the state
and in your local district,
you've set an expectation that we really appreciate.
We've also loved spending time with you personally.
It's been really fun.
She just joins us all just as one of the team
and we will follow you.
You should know student board members go on
to do great things and circle back.
So this is not, we all have each other's emails
and we do hope that we'll stay in touch with you,
but you've made a really big difference in the year
that you served while you've been a senior.
And now you get to go to your next chapter
and we'll be following you.
So thank you, Brenna, for just your energy
and your thoughtfulness and always being present
in our work.
And Tony, I think you're up.
Thank you, Madam President and members of the board.
Board member Pangolini, I wanted to add my thanks to you
in addition to the board members.
And congratulations as you pursue
what sounds like a very exciting major,
like our board president, not sure quite what it is,
but it does sound like something that can be helpful
to all of us in California and maybe nationwide,
depending on where you decide to land and settle.
It's hard to believe that it's already time
to say, see you later.
I believe in see you later because as you've heard,
we know that you're gonna do great things
and we hope that you'll stay connected.
And we hope that you will allow us to help you
if we can along the way.
It seems like you just jumped right in
that you didn't really need any time,
that you felt really comfortable
really holding your place as a board member, as you should.
But these are often difficult conversations
to enter for anyone.
And you showed that you were courageous
and a great educator and ready for whatever comes forward.
I also would like to offer a personal word
of thanks and gratitude and to share something
that board members may not know,
that board member Pangolini has helped us to launch
what is a very new and fledgling youth advisory council
at the California Department of Education.
They give us a chance to bring youth voice
into all matters related to education.
This has really grown out of our interest
in providing support to students during the pandemic.
And board member Pangolini was more than generous
in her time in helping to be a part of it and shape it,
but she really has been a leader
and has given us a way to really think differently
about how we partner with young people
in supporting their education.
Hope that you'll continue when your schedule allows,
but know that we are grateful.
And as I said, that I and staff and the board are all here
if we can support you on your journey.
Good luck at Brown and thank you.
Perfect.
And finally, in the area of announcements,
I'd like to announce the departure of Malia Gonzalez,
who started at the state board office in August, 2016.
She's accepted a new opportunity to work at CDE
as a school fiscal services division,
associate governmental program analyst in June, 2020.
And we want to thank Malia
for all of her invaluable assistance during her core years
at the state board.
And she is right down the hall when we get back
to being together at the department's offices.
Our agenda is very full today for this meeting
and I'll try hard to help us finish today's work
by dinnertime, but we will have to be very focused
to do that.
We'll reopen item one, SBE priorities,
to take action on the draft minutes
and receive the state board liaison reports
tomorrow morning.
Item seven was withdrawn from our agenda
by the state board yesterday,
which would have considered the approval
of local educational agency plans
as required through the Every Student Succeeds Act
through the completion of the LCAP federal addendum.
Item 12, Cabrillo Point Academy charter number 1748
was withdrawn by CDE on June 28th,
as noted in attachment one.
There will be no closed session on Thursday.
Item 23 has been added to the agenda
at the end of the day on Thursday,
which is a waiver request
by Fallbrook Union Elementary School District.
There are seven public hearings on our agenda,
including items three, four, 16, and 17,
which will be heard today,
and items 18, 19, 20, and 21,
which will be heard tomorrow.
The proposed waiver consent items are W01 through 15.
The proposed regular consent items are items eight through 15.
We will take up both the waiver consent items
and regular consent items later this afternoon.
In terms of public input,
members of the public wishing to call in
through a public comment
should view the live stream of the meeting
to know at what time public comment will occur for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number,
entering a participant access code,
and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers
when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We will also ask callers to please turn down
the speaker volume of their computers
if they are following the live webcast
in order to avoid an echoing effect.
Public comment will be limited to one minute
for each speaker.
Item 18 is the general public comment item
during which members of the public may provide comment
on matters that are not specifically listed
on the board's agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones
when you're not speaking
and keep your cameras on at all times,
except during the schedule breaks
to ensure that we maintain a quorum
throughout today's virtual meeting.
For each item on the agenda,
there will be an opportunity for you board members
to raise your hand using the Zoom participant window
if you'd like to ask a question or make a comment,
and we'll also watch for you in the Hollywood squares.
Agenda item one is our state board priorities item,
and we are opening item one
to hear the superintendent's report
and the state board president's report at this time only,
and then we will reopen the item tomorrow morning
for any of the remaining items.
So I now turn it over to state superintendent Tony Thurman
to provide his report.
I thank you, Madam President and board members.
I'd like to first start by acknowledging
and congratulating and welcoming
board members McQuillin, Dr. Glover-Woods,
and board member Rodriguez.
You are all very distinguished,
and you're joining a very distinguished board.
It is an honor for me and the 2,500 employees
at the California Department of Education to work with you.
There are a number of new staff
who I would like to announce and share with you,
but first I'd like to just give just a few highlights
of some of the things that have happened since we last met.
It feels like it was very long ago.
It was only in the month of May,
as we are living in some of the most challenging times.
Every day feels like the longest day,
but I'm grateful to see each and every one of you
and that we are able to convene again
as you continue to take up the business
of the people of the state of California.
As you probably know, our office in conjunction
with the State Board of Education
and many other partners and with the support
of our president who joined us
when we released it, we did release guidance
or how schools can reopen safely.
That guidance was released in June.
It probably mirrors many of the things
that you have heard stated by organizations
like the Center for Disease Control
and the Department of Public Health in California,
that in order for schools to open safely,
students will need to wear face coverings, as will staff,
and that there will need to be personal protective equipment
provided to all of our students.
We're grateful to all of our partnerships,
but including our partnership in the governor's office
and the Office of Emergency Services
that has already allowed for personal protective equipment
to be sent to 10,000 schools in our state.
In many cases, this has already arrived.
And so we know that there's so many questions
about how school will look and how it can safely reopen.
There are questions about, will there be distance learning?
There are questions about instructional minutes
and the number of days and how to support districts
as we keep students safe.
But I'm grateful to Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond
and to many partners who've worked with our staff
at the Department of Education,
our chief deputy superintendent
who led the process of writing the document
and all of the stakeholders who joined us,
educators from every perspective and background,
teachers and administrators, classified staff, parents,
many all coming together to work through the scenarios
about what school reopening would need to look like.
Many of you know that we launched during the pandemic
a task force on closing the digital divide.
This was our way of helping to provide computing devices
and hotspots to students in need
and to advocate for closing the digital divide.
Thank you, Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond
and many others who joined us in making calls
for donations for our students.
Internet service providers have essentially agreed
to provide free internet for many of our students
and in many cases, low cost internet,
but there's still many, many challenges
that need to be addressed.
There are infrastructure barriers
that prevent our students from having access
to high speed internet
and many students don't have a computing device in the home.
We are continuing to work through our task force
on the ways that we can address the digital divide.
I want to let you know about a number of webinars
that have been provided.
The number is upwards of 40
that were provided during the pandemic
to go through various aspects
of how to provide distance learning,
how to support students with special needs and disabilities
and any topic that you can imagine.
We had virtual support circles for parents
to talk about how difficult it was
to be supporting their students while at home.
We had virtual support circles for educators
and for students.
We've also developed a counseling coalition
to help us fill in gaps
because we know that many of our students haven't checked in.
They may be struggling to find basic needs.
We know that meals were provided
at more than 5,000 sites across our state.
And so these are some of the things
that the Department of Education has put in place
to address many of the challenges that we are seeing.
As you know, since we last met,
we have witnessed one of the most devastating acts
of police brutality, the killing of an unarmed black man
that really exacerbates our feelings
about the loss of life for African-Americans
and for others who've been impacted
and impacted by violence.
And we've grieved together,
we've held many conversations together
about the work that we must do.
One of the things that we've taken up recently,
and I'm grateful to our State Board President
for joining us, is convene a conversation
about the impact of police in our schools.
As we join the conversations
that are taking place nationwide,
we wanted to make sure that we were also talking
about issues of safety in our schools.
And we've had a robust discussion
about alternatives to having police on campus,
and there are a number of recommendations
being explored right now, like more restorative justice,
more de-escalation programs,
and more counseling programs to support our students.
There'll be another hearing on this Friday at 10 a.m.
to speak to those matters.
I also wanna let you know
that the California Department of Education
has introduced a new initiative
to help bring implicit bias training
to our 10,000 schools in the state.
We're grateful to have received the grant
from the Bechdel Junior Foundation
that allows us to begin this conversation
to build out a framework for how to provide implicit bias
and to help us start with our own organization
with the 2,500 employees
at the California Department of Education
while we build out this campaign.
I wanna let you know about some of the staff
will be very important to the work that we'll do
in addressing implicit bias.
I'm excited to let you know
that we've been joined by a new Deputy Superintendent
for our Instruction and Measurement Branch.
Her name is Rachel Maves,
and she joins us after serving
at the County Office of Education in Sonoma County.
She's been an educator and a superintendent
and a top leader at the County Office of Education,
and we're glad to have her.
For those of you who are new to the board,
this is our branch that you will probably see her the most.
She and our Chief Deputy Superintendent at board meetings
as she oversees a number of divisions
like our assessment division
and our data collection divisions,
and you will hear from her often.
We're grateful to have her here.
We've added a new Director of Government Affairs
who was serving as our Interim Government Affairs Director,
Ellie Garner, who is a veteran Government Affairs Director
and will work closely
with the Government Affairs Director at the State Board
and with all of our legislative leaders to shepherd
through a great conversation
about the importance of education in the political process.
As you all know, Kai Jackson,
who was our Deputy Superintendent for Equity and Access,
did make the decision
to leave the Department of Education to return home.
He lives across the state and had decided to return home
about the time that the pandemic began.
I'm pleased to let you know
that our former Communications Director
has now taken on those duties,
Kendra Britt, who will now be the Deputy Superintendent
for the Equity and Access Branch,
which includes the work that we do in CTE.
Kendra, among many things,
is a former Director, a former teacher of CTE,
and we're grateful for the experiences that she brings.
As she moves over into that new position,
we were proud to be able to elevate someone
who was in our Communications Division
to take on our Communications Division as the new Director,
and that's Daniel Thigpen.
Many of you have met him.
He's a veteran Communications Expert
and has been very active in our work
in shaping the message of the work
that we do together at CTE
and the State Board of Education.
The final person I'd like to tell you about
is someone who is joining us brand new
in a brand new position that is grant funded
that we've been working on creating
for at least the last year and a half.
Since the day that I started,
we've talked about the need to create more work
and staff positions that are focused directly
on the conversation of equity,
and I'm grateful that through a grant provided
by the Hewlett Foundation, I can announce to you
that we now have a Deputy Superintendent for Equity
at the Department of Education.
His name is Dr. Daniel Lee.
He is a psychologist, a clinical psychologist,
and a school psychologist who is a veteran leader
in all areas around special education,
around coaching and counseling,
and around the work related to equity.
He has worked in a great length
at building cultural competency
for a number of school districts across a number of states.
We're grateful that he is joining our team.
Many things that we love to share with you.
We know you have a long agenda.
We're grateful for the work that you provide
and just know that we continue
to stand shoulder to shoulder with you
on the things that we can do to support you,
and we'll have more updates for you as we continue.
Thank you, Madam President, to submit my report.
Thank you very much,
and thanks for all of your very energetic leadership
during this very intense and impactful time.
We're in the moment of a, in a historical moment
with a public health crisis, an economic crisis,
and a civil rights crisis all happening at the same time,
and I think what we will see
are really some tectonic shifts in the society
and in our education system,
and that's really going to be part of what's on our plate
to handle, and it's really been quite extraordinary.
You see the way in which educators across California
have been stepping up to these uncertainties,
to these needs, to these events,
and inventing and supporting
and reaching out to each other and to our children,
and we, I know, all want to acknowledge
the extraordinary work that is going on across the state.
If one thing is clear, it's that we are going to be
in a very unpredictable situation for quite a while,
and I just want to add just a couple of thoughts
to what the state superintendent already offered,
that clearly teaching and learning
will be organized in many different ways this fall
in in-person, some distance learning,
some hybrid learning, et cetera.
It will need to be governed by purpose rather than by place,
and we'll see this wide array of arrangements,
and I think there are four things we should be cognizant of.
We'll need to design our system
and the way in which we support the system
to be continuous and supported by technology
in the right ways,
to be informed by useful formative assessments,
to be as authentic as possible
and focused on learning to learn.
We're seeing that the places where kids are engaged
and motivated and learning are those where
the work is being connected to their personal experiences
and to the world beyond the Zoom classroom,
and to be integrated with social and emotional learning.
And as Tony noted,
we've been working to close the digital divide,
and there will be new resources coming
from the federal government that will enable districts
to go further in ensuring that everyone
has access to technology.
Even when we go back to school,
schools will probably open and close
at various points in time with the rise and fall
of the virus, and students will need to stay home
if they have been exposed
or if people in their household have been exposed.
So this fluid approach to learning
will be very, very important.
Each district is being asked
to develop an instructional continuity plan
for seamless continuation of curriculum and instruction
wherever students are located,
and the department will be putting out a template
for that plan, and I'm being told
that my battery is low on my computer,
so hold on a second, I'm going to get my plug.
I would hate for us to get disconnected
when we're in the middle of this beginning process.
And so we'll need to continue to guide districts
in that regard.
Many districts have been establishing
successful strategies for distance learning,
and there's amazing and creative work going on,
and we'll be trying both at the department
and at the California Collaborative
to share those experiences that have been
the kinds of curriculum, the kinds of strategies,
and the excellent teaching that have been going on
across the state.
It'll be important as kids come back to school
to really assess where they are.
There's a lot of concern about learning loss.
Now, of course, kids are always learning.
It's a question of what they're learning,
but it's going to be very important
that we have good formative assessments
when students return to school
to understand where they are in their learning,
to deal with it as continuous progress forward
rather than a deficit approach that labels
or stigmatizes students when they return to school.
And just this week, we have released a set of guidelines
for formative assessment that districts can use.
The department already has approved a set
of diagnostic and formative assessments
that are aligned with the Common Core Standards.
They offer tools not only for assessment,
but also connections to instructional materials
and curriculum materials across the grade span
from K through 12.
And so those will be a very important part
of the school reopening process.
But as we all know,
as students return to school this fall,
they'll bring with them a wide range of experiences.
Even students who were in the same class
when schools initially closed
will have had different home lives,
experiences, responsibilities,
different access to devices
and support for distance learning,
different emotional reactions to the ongoing
and unfolding situation that Superintendent Thurmond noted.
Beyond the death of George Floyd,
there have been actually deaths
of multiple unarmed Black men and women
at the hands of the police and protests
that are raising all of the equity issues,
not only in that regard, but in our schools as well.
And we'll need to be tackling those as well.
We've had inequitable school funding,
inequitable access to teachers and curriculum.
These are long-standing issues
in school systems across the country.
California is stepping up around many of those issues
and we have further to go
that will need to be on our plates as well.
And the inequity in what students have experienced
during the pandemic is part of what we'll need
to be prepared to deal with once school reopens.
Some students may have been in daily online learning
with a well-planned curriculum
supported by teachers and counselors
since the week after schools closed.
And I know a number of those districts
where they hit the ground running, everybody had devices,
everybody was in class,
the curriculum just continued almost seamlessly.
Others may have had very little instruction
for a month or more after schools closed
and may have been working with a hard copy
instructional packets that they complete
by teaching themselves on their own time.
Some may have sheltered in place safely
with all of their needs met.
Others may have experienced illness
and the loss of loved ones.
Their families may have lost employment,
housing, healthcare.
They may be experiencing food insecurity
and teachers are going to need to take stock
of all of those experiences and needs,
social, emotional, health-related,
trauma-related and academic
as we build safe and welcoming communities
in line, online and in person
or a combination of both when school begins.
So we'll be offering as much support as possible,
both through guidance
and professional learning opportunities
and sharing successful experiences.
And when additional federal funds come through,
hopefully for supporting the wraparound services
and supports that will be needed
so that students can start the school year
with the kind of caring support
that we know all of our educators
are trying to provide in extraordinary ways
and that our policies and practices
should support them in doing.
And with that, we're going to launch into our agenda.
And we now will take up agenda item two,
which is our accountability item.
And this is going to be presented by Cindy Kazanis
with guest presenters, Eric Crane and Deb Sigman of WestEd
and Joseph Martino of ETS.
And the recommendation we're considering
is that the State Board provide guidance
on the proposed student growth model methodology.
Cindy, great to see you.
You may begin.
Thank you.
Thank you, member, rather President Linda Darling-Hammond
and welcome to the new board members.
I'm Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis,
Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division.
And as President Linda Darling-Hammond stated,
we're going to have a lot of folks
helping us to do this item today.
So this may be a long discussion
based on this board's prior engagement with the growth model.
And so we're prepared for pauses
in between each of our presenters
to allow for clarifying questions.
And we'll take this at the pace that you feel comfortable.
So I think the first thing I wanted to do today
is just do some housekeeping and to introduce myself.
And you're going to hear from a member of my team
in just a bit, Jenny Singh.
Our division is responsible for accountability,
for data reporting and for sharing data
with the research communities.
So I know later in our agenda,
you're going to hear from my colleague, Mal Vang,
and she is responsible for our assessment division.
So this item is not about assessments per se,
it's how we use the assessments
in our accountability division.
It's nice to see in the room a couple of familiar faces
that we haven't seen in about four months.
And so working remotely,
we've been able to put together this item
and bring the people that you're going to hear from today.
I also wanted to let you know that because it's summer,
we are joined yet again by another awesome
Stanford and government student, Parth Sarin,
who is going to be helping us,
has already helped us rather with the growth model
and participated in a discussion that we held
the first week he was on the job.
So today we will be covering in depth,
again, the student growth models
on communicating smarter balance results.
And then we'll do a brief overview
at the conclusion of the item on the legislative action
that has taken place since we last met
for the California School Dashboard
and the Local Control and Accountability Plan.
So to get us started,
the recommendation is that the Department of Education
is asking the State Board of Education
to provide guidance as appropriate
on proposed student growth model methodology.
So just to break this down for our new members,
this means that you're not literally taking action today,
we're asking for guidance.
So I think this is a good low stakes meaning
for you to ask clarifying questions
to get a thorough understanding of where we've been
and where we're headed.
I see this process similar to getting your graduate degree,
maybe even your dissertation,
because it's gonna take us about seven years
when we think about when we started in 2016
to completing this process in 2022 or 2023
with the incorporation of the growth model
into the accountability system.
So really there's two parts to a decision
that you'll be making in the future.
Part one is what you'll be taking up this fall,
which is the formal adoption of a model
so that we can provide results to the field
based on past information, prior students,
on how they're doing and get the field comfortable
and our parents and community members comfortable
with how this model works.
Part two is how it's incorporated into the dashboard.
And like every other state in this country,
we had a suspension of our assessments this year.
It takes two years of consecutive student scores
to create a growth model.
So all states will be in the position again next year
of having a gap in reporting out on their growth models.
So you'll hear from, again, my colleagues on
the timing of incorporating into the dashboard,
but that's not what's part of the discussion today
or even for this year.
This is again, future year action.
We have provided 10 information memos
about the growth model.
We've had four board meetings
in which we've discussed this item in general.
So we're now on our fifth meeting.
We are ready in September to talk about this again,
in November to talk about it yet again,
and hopefully again for you all to take action
to formally adopt the growth model.
The last time we brought this to you as a formal item
was about two years ago.
It was July of 2019.
It was following a discussion in May 2018,
rather, it was following a discussion in which,
I have my dates wrong.
The last time we brought this friendly to you was in 2018.
And in July of that year, you had asked us to take a pause,
take a year to really work with stakeholders
to understand the growth model process.
So you're gonna hear a little bit about that
from our colleagues at the Comprehensive Center.
This really, this effort could not be done
without our colleagues at the Comprehensive Center
to take this break in 2019
to gather a common understanding
of what growth models can do
and the direction the board had already set us
on the path for,
which was further exploring the residual growth model.
You're also gonna hear from experts
at the Educational Testing Services
who will review what questions the growth model
can and cannot answer
and provide an overview of proposed methodology
to stabilize the growth model.
So ETS, our colleagues through our assessment contract,
and we're working closely with our colleagues
in our assessment division on this matter,
are talking on a weekly basis.
So this is a very intense workload for us,
but because of the suspension of the dashboard,
which you're gonna hear about towards the end of this item,
we really have the right people working on this.
And I think we're ready to, again,
support the board in any way
so that you feel comfortable
in making a decision come November.
Finally, we will walk you through a couple of questions
to help generate some, hopefully some interest
and some guidance towards what we need to do
moving forward as we prepare, again,
to bring back this for action,
not only for the discussion in September,
but for action in November.
So before we get started, I wanted to remind you,
because I know this came up two years ago.
I actually looked at my notes this morning.
Education code section 442.58.9 prohibits the use
of specified data from being used
by a local educational agency
for purposes of evaluating certificated employees,
certificated employee performance determinations,
or employment decisions.
And why this isn't really important
is because today we're talking about a growth model
for use in the accountability system.
Accountability system doesn't measure teacher performance.
It doesn't measure individual student performance.
We're looking at things at a school level
and at a district level.
And so this discussion came up last time
because there are concerns now
that you're attaching a growth piece to a student
that this could possibly be used
in violation of this education code.
So I just brought this forward just as a reminder
that that is not the intended use.
And in fact, the state is prohibited
from doing just that by education code.
So with that, I'm going to turn it over to my colleagues
at the Region 15 Comprehensive Center,
Deborah Sigmon and Eric Crane.
Thank you, Cindy.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond
and Superintendent Thurman and board members.
And congratulations to the new board members.
I'm Deb Sigmon.
I serve as a senior managing director with WestEd.
I also serve as the co-director
of the Region 15 Comprehensive Center.
And I just want to give you a little background
about the center so that you have a sense
of why we are able to assist the California Department of Ed
as well as the state board in these matters.
Next slide.
So the Region 15 Comprehensive Center
is a part of a very large network.
There are 19 centers throughout the United States
and these technical assistance centers are funded
by a grant from the U.S. Department of Education.
What's interesting about this project, as Cindy explained,
this is a long process and California is rightly taking
its time to make the right decisions for students
and teachers as they consider a growth model.
We began this project in late 2018
after your July, 2018 meeting.
At that time, we were the California Comprehensive Center
and I was the director of that center.
We served only California.
Since that time, we are the recipient of a new grant,
which is now the Region 15 Comprehensive Center
and the geography has changed a bit.
We now serve California, Nevada, Utah and Arizona.
Next slide.
And our priority areas in order to provide
technical assistance to the Department of Ed
and the State Board of Ed are really centered
around three areas, equitable teaching and learning,
standards assessment and accountability
and systems improvement.
So when we were asked to provide some assistance
around the growth model, that fit squarely
into our standards assessment
and accountability priority area.
I just want to give a little bit of,
my colleague Eric Prang will go into the timeline
a little bit more, but as with all things,
we were able to shift as the needs of the stakeholders
changed as the conversations became really deep and rich.
And so we were scheduled for three meetings,
which is what we described to the department
and the State Board staff is what we would need.
As it turns out, we actually added a fourth meeting
for the stakeholder group and then an update meeting
that we just held last week.
All that to say that these are moving kinds of conversations
and I do want to give a really a shout out
to the stakeholder members who were so engaged
in the process and really committed to thinking
about growth models and what they did
and what they didn't do.
And so it was indeed a pleasure to be able to support
that work and facilitate those conversations.
So with that, I'm going to turn it over to Eric Crane.
Eric.
Thank you, Deb.
Board President Darling-Hammond and Superintendent Thurmond
and members of the Board,
thank you for the opportunity to speak with you today.
I'm Eric Crane and I'm a project director over this work
for the Region 15 Comprehensive Center.
And I wanted to start by describing the work,
the beginnings of it and what it set out to do.
Key here was stakeholder feedback about the growth model.
And so when the department reached out
to the Comprehensive Center to begin this work,
it was oriented with following goals in mind.
The department wanted to understand
what was on the mind of stakeholders.
So getting to the heart of stakeholder priorities.
There was a lot of discussion about various growth models
and to be some confusion about some.
And so another goal was to bring in technical expertise
to describe the growth models, to do some level setting
so that all stakeholders were at a pretty similar
starting place.
So clear up some of those misconceptions.
But to really talk about how a growth model in California
could be used to drive school and district improvement.
Another goal of the work was to make sure
that there was a trusting and well-facilitated space
where stakeholders could speak frankly and directly
about what was good and not so good
about various growth model options.
And then finally, the last major goal was to make sure
that stakeholders would lead conversations
well-equipped to go and be ambassadors for the work
to really explain what was happening
in the discussions at the state
and to share that with their communities.
And actually to solicit further feedback
so that this process could be well-informed
by stakeholder feedback and input.
So next slide, please.
I want to walk a little bit through the timeline
and go into a little bit more detail
about the stakeholder feedback work.
As I said, this work began and was motivated
by conversations for the board two years ago.
And as Cindy said, the antecedents
are even further back before that.
But in July, the board asked for some more work
and some outreach to find out
and take the temperature of the state on this issue.
And so the Department of Education reached out
to the Comprehensive Center.
And we put together a plan
where we would have three stakeholder meetings.
As Deb alluded to, we saw the need for a fourth
and built that into 2019.
I'll speak to that in just a moment.
And so throughout the early part of 2019,
we teamed the stakeholders group.
We met in February and not all the stakeholders could join.
And so we had a catch-up meeting
for the additional stakeholders in March.
And so by the end of March, we convened the group
and had a chance to explore some of the growth models
and do some level setting
around different growth model options.
And I should say something
about the growth model stakeholders.
They represent a lot of folks
who have been engaged in this work,
members of the Local Control Funding Formula
Equity Coalition, the Office of Education staff,
classroom teachers, the California PTA is represented
in the stakeholders group.
So it's a very diverse and engaged group.
And that brought us to our second meeting.
We had that in early April.
And the group walked through various interpretations
and they went through questions
that a growth model might help to answer and inform.
And all this helped to uncover
and unearth what stakeholders wanted from a growth model.
The work continued with our third meeting in May
where we touched on some of the analytic models
and reviewed what some other states had done
with growth problems and continued the discussion.
What that set up was kind of turning
from within the growth model stakeholder group
to how we could set up discussions
for the stakeholders to go back to their wider communities.
And so the comprehensive center staff
built a conversations kit that we armed our stakeholders
to go back and use that to help with discussions
back in the wider field.
And then we had that fourth meeting.
That fourth meeting in September,
we heard what they had heard when they went back
and spoke with their broader communities.
And it was pretty clear from this set of four meetings
that a 2020 update would be appropriate.
And so the department committed to that.
And we just had that, as Deb said,
we just had that meeting last week.
And so that's sort of an overview as to where we are.
This slide that you're looking at now
comes from last week's meeting.
And let me just say a little bit more
about last week's meeting.
Next slide, please.
When we gathered last week, here's what we did.
We went over the 2019 work,
and department staff summarized the timeline,
and you'll hear a little bit more about that shortly.
Partnering with Educational Testing Service,
they did a presentation that talked about
the recent technical work on the growth model.
And it had an emphasis on this estimated
best linear predictor model.
And then we had some small group discussion
where we asked stakeholders to give some reaction
to what they'd heard,
raise whatever questions were on their minds.
And then we kind of documented the discussion.
So setting things up for the continued work
in the remainder of 2020 and beyond.
Next.
And that's just our required material
for the US Department of Education.
So that concludes my remarks.
And Cindy, I will send it back over to you now.
Great, so I think we can take a pause here,
and I will turn it over to President Darlene Hammond
to see if there's any clarifying questions
from board members.
And I don't see any hands, Linda.
Okay, great, why don't we continue, Cindy?
Great, so with that, I'm going to turn it over
to my colleague, Jenny Singh to introduce herself
and this piece of the item.
Good morning, President Darlene Hammond
and esteemed board members.
And welcome to our new board members.
I'm looking forward to working with you
over the next few years.
I'm going to be talking, doing a brief overview
of how we got to where we are in the growth model.
Please note that we did a very in-depth overview
in the June memo.
So if you want all the details,
I think we did a good job of providing all those
in the June memo.
So as we shared at the March meeting,
we are recommending that we continue the work
on the residual gain model.
So just to refer briefly back to the board item,
remember that we did investigate many models
and we brought three models to the board
and we decided that we would investigate those models
more in depth.
So ETS did an evaluation on all three models
and in the end, the board settled
on the residual gain model.
So as we continued our work on the residual gain model
and looked at the results of how it acted over time,
we realized that we needed some technical adjustments
that could enhance the validity and cross time stability.
And recall from our several meetings
that we have conversations that we had about this,
that the state board decided that student demographics
should not be included as a control variable
in the growth model.
And that is a really important thing to remember.
So here's our original growth model timelines
starting with August.
I don't wanna go back to 2016.
That would take a long time.
And I'm sure you're gonna see right away
where this timeline will have to change.
So originally, and this is still gonna happen
in August of 2020, ETS is going to present their findings
on their modifications to the RG growth model
to our technical design group.
And our technical design group will recommend
any modifications if any.
Then in September, we're gonna be bringing,
coming back with a presentation of the results from ETS.
And then of course, in November,
we're hoping to come back and get an approval
of a growth model that will measure
individual student growth.
And initially, we thought that in September of 2020
with the release of the 2020 dashboard,
we would release growth scores using CAS data
from 2016 through 2020.
And of course, with the suspension of our assessments,
that's not gonna be possible.
And we had also anticipated that between January
and November of 21, we would work with LEAs
and stakeholders on communication data
and using some case studies.
And then we had anticipated that in December of 2021,
we would release the growth scores
using CAS data from 2021.
Then some small event came around called COVID-19.
And it kind of changed the way we started to look
at how we were gonna move forward with the growth model.
So nothing changed for August, September and November.
But of course, for December,
that meant that when we released the growth scores,
we could only use prior year data, 2016 to 2019.
So this is gonna be looking back
at the growth from previous years.
This also means that we have an extended window
to have some conversations with LEAs and stakeholders.
So we can go from January 21 through November of 22
to talk about really some good ways to communicate
what the growth model is telling us
and trying to figure out the best way to display this data
for the general public.
Because we all know that growth models are quite complicated
and we want to communicate it in a simple way
that people can understand.
So with December of 2021,
we will not have the data to release growth scores.
So we will continue to use the academic indicator methodology
that we currently have, the distance to met.
And then for December, 2022,
we can release another set of growth scores
using data from 2021 and 2022.
So as we mentioned earlier,
we had the stakeholder meetings
and CDE staff did attend those meetings
and it was very clear from those meetings
how deeply valued a growth model was
for the California accountability system.
But we also saw how difficult it was
to create a growth measure
that covers the wide variety of information
that various people had.
Growth models, each growth,
there's a lot of different growth models
and each growth model will answer different questions.
And there really was not a complete consensus
about which questions we should ask.
In fact, the suggestion came around,
well, maybe we should have more than one growth model,
but that's not gonna be possible.
But we concluded that from all the conversations
that we had, that the residual gain model
really was the best fit for the expectations
expressed by the group.
So beginning in February of 2020,
we began working on some technical modifications
that would improve the results of the residual gain model
within our accountability framework.
So specifically that meant
the year to year volatility of scores.
So you can remember we had that conversation
at the July 2018 meeting
about the validity of the scores from year to year.
So what did that really mean?
So as you know, when we developed our growth model,
we had some established criteria or requirements
that we wanted our growth model to meet.
And when we found out about this year to year volatility,
it impacted whether this,
impacted the fact that this model
did not meet that criteria.
So one of the criteria is reliable data.
This is the assessment results are reliable data
that we get from schools and districts.
We get the file directly from our contractor, ATS.
But we weren't sure that the outcomes
were gonna be valid and fair for all schools.
Even though the RG model performs
statistically similar in both years,
there was that low cross stability within the outcomes.
And that was particularly evident with low end sizes.
So then of course, the growth model would not be as fair
to small schools and small student groups
as it was to large schools.
And then we do like, we want our information
to provide actionable information.
The dashboard should do that
for when districts are developing their out caps.
So high volatility results can make it difficult
for LEAs to use the growth data for driving decisions.
Because the decision you make one year
might be contradicted by the data
that you receive the next year.
And we felt that there was a strong risk
of misinterpretation when the results
would be going up and down over time.
So we began our work with the TDG
to make some technical adjustments.
So the first one was changing
the highest obtainable scale score or the HAAS.
And that's on the CAS.
This allows more students to show higher growth.
Right now, the HAAS is capped.
And so students that are performing very well,
they are not allowed, it's very difficult for them
to show growth from one year to the next.
So we did make adjustments to the HAAS scores.
We are not the first state to do this.
In fact, we are one of the last
smarter balanced states to do this.
Many other states have already made adjustments
to their HAAS scores.
And then we thought about implementing
a new regression formula to counter
the end size and stability issues.
And ETS has been working on this.
They've been great to work with.
We have very knowledgeable, they have very
knowledgeable staff who are experts in this area.
And they came up with a formula known as
the Estimated Best Linear Predictor Model, or EBLIP.
Yes, EBLIP, sorry.
So we've been working on that together
and they have been looking at the data
to see how it's going to impact the RG model.
And they're going to bring those, as I said,
they're going to bring the results to you in September.
Member, President Lyndon Arninghamen,
would you like to pause for clarifying questions
before we switch over to the ETS staff?
We can't hear you.
I don't think your mic, you're on mute.
Sorry, can you hear me?
Yes.
I think we should go right ahead with the ETS presentation
because it's going to explain some of what
was just described.
Okay?
Great.
Thank you.
So we would like to turn it over to Joseph Martinow,
who is the Executive Director for the Center
for Operational Solutions and Innovations
with the Psychometric Analysts and Research
with ETS, Education Testing Services.
Joseph?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Board President Arninghamen, Superintendent Thurmond,
and members of the California State Board of Education,
thank you for the opportunity today.
I have with me as well, the person who is the primary,
the primary developer of the EVE-UP model.
His name is Jarrah Lockwood,
and he is one of our experts in growth.
He's done a lot of work in the area.
So just wanted to kind of talk about what are growth models
and how do we think about that?
How do we get there?
And so there's one concept of a growth model
where it's just pure growth.
And that kind of growth model actually assumes a scale
that doesn't change over time or over grades.
It does require multiple measures for the same person.
And this really is kind of what most people think of
as a growth model.
So these kinds of things are available for physical scale,
such as height, you can,
the difference between one inch and two inches,
and two inches and three inches,
and 24 inches and 25 inches, it's just, it's always one.
And it has the same meaning.
So you can think about that in terms of weight,
scales that we can use,
where a difference of one pound always means the same thing.
And things like temperature as well.
Unfortunately, those kinds of scales just aren't available
for academic achievement, except for in really rare cases.
So for example, for really young students,
if we want to know how many of the letters of the alphabet
the student recognizes, we can go zero to 26,
or zero to 52, depending on
inclusive upper.
But it's kind of an exception in education.
We tend to measure things that we can't necessarily see.
And we have to use special models
to be able to measure those kinds of things.
Next slide, please.
So essentially what we end up doing
measuring academic growth,
except for in those very rare circumstances,
is we use proxies for that.
So those kinds of models do not necessarily assume
the same scale over time.
And that's important because we know that the meaning
of achievement scales change across grades.
It's not the same scale.
We can approximate how students are growing
across these different pieces.
So that's why it's important that we have these proxies
so that we don't treat our academic achievement scales
as if they were pure scales,
where you can just measure across very wide distributions
or very wide ranges of achievement,
unlike what you can do with height,
weight and temperature and so on.
And it does require multiple measures for each student.
And so what we do in the absence of those prerequisites
for measuring true growth,
we apply statistical models to the data that we have
so that we can approximate that kind of true growth.
Next slide, please.
So this is a kind of a big challenge
issue that has come up in every state
that I have worked with around growth models.
It's important to become clear on what growth model can do
and what it can't do.
Kind of in broad strokes,
what it can do is it can give proximate measures
of the degree to which students kept up
with the increasing complexity
of content standards across grades.
And you kind of just think of this in general,
the complexity, for example,
of a third grade mathematics test
and the breadth of what it covers is very different
than what you would see, for example,
on a sixth grade test or an eighth grade test.
And in particular, you can kind of think about
one of the places where you have
one of these biggest transitions in mathematics
is moving from kind of the basic underlying parts
of mathematics to, for example, algebra.
When there's a switch to algebraic representations
and so on, that's a really different thing
that we're measuring now,
but it does build on those others, right?
So what it can do is take proximate measures
of the degree to which students kept up
with the increasing complexity
of those content standards across grade.
So it can do that.
It can give group level measures of that same thing,
how well the individual groups kept up
with those same increasingly complex standards.
And it can also give us information
about group level learnings
so that we can engage in policy evaluation,
program evaluation and interventions at a high level.
So it's one of the main purposes
of a state assessment to begin with
is it's intended to give information
about student achievement
that can be used at a high level
by state board members or local district board members,
superintendents, anyone who is kind of developing
and evaluating programs, interventions, policies and so on.
Next slide, please.
So what a growth model can't do,
at least with our existing scales
is to give information on the specific knowledge,
skills and abilities that have been gained
by specific students in a specific way.
And the reason for that is that
on our statewide assessments and Smarter Balanced
and pretty much every other state assessment,
those are such broad measures.
They cover so much ground that it is difficult to say
that we can identify that a student has learned
this particular content standard
because we don't have enough items
directed toward that content standard
and that content standard and we need more information
to be able to make the kinds of inferences
that we would want to make in terms of
what specifically is it that we can measure
with this growth model.
It can't give information about why
that degree of growth has occurred.
One of the reasons for that is the gold standard in research
is to have kind of a randomized controlled trial
that we would see in something like medicine.
And because we can't randomize
which students go to which schools
and we can't randomize which schools are in a given area.
So we've got a lot of things
that we can't necessarily randomize.
So that makes it more difficult
to make causal interpretations about,
okay, we saw this level of growth, but why?
It can't necessarily help us do that
except with extreme precision and care
in designing a research study
that can handle these kinds of data
called essentially a quasi-experimental study.
And it requires some advanced statistical analyses
that take quite a while to develop and run.
So, at the high level, it's very difficult
to identify why something has happened.
And in particular, it's very difficult
to identify the causes of differences among groups.
That's, if we want to say why something happened,
we need to go more into the research space
and work with people who specialize in causal modeling
or quasi-causal modeling from data
that don't come from our randomized control trial.
Okay, next slide, please.
So, selecting a measure of growth is, it's a hard thing.
There are so many variations that can come into
this deliberation.
And I have had the opportunity to work
with a variety of states around this,
around this selection of a growth model.
And so, you know, there is a white paper out there
that, you know, I worked on this paper
to kind of guide states in making that decision
that was kind of commissioned by Smarter Balanced
from a practitioner's guide to growth models.
And this is Catherine Castellano and Andrew Ho,
who did this work some time ago.
Andrew Ho is at Harvard,
and Catherine Castellano is also at ETS.
So, I developed a framework for understanding
and selecting a model or a growth measure
that underpins this work that was done
with the stakeholder feedback group.
Next slide, please.
So, if you look at this,
this was a framework that was developed.
It's kind of small,
but essentially it walks through why do we wanna measure
growth in the first place?
What is our theory of action?
What's the purpose that we want to use this for,
and how can we get to the kind of outcomes
that we want to have when we go through that process
of selecting a growth measure?
So, that's kind of the first purpose of this framework
is making sure that we tie the uses and interpretation
to the way that model can be used to make interpretations.
So, I'm not gonna go through the whole piece here,
but essentially we went through many of these parts
of the growth measure with California,
with the growth model stakeholder group.
We didn't go through all of them,
and I learned a lot about how I could have modified this
from what we did.
But California is the first state that I have worked with.
It has gone through this deliberate,
patient, and careful process
to identify what are the ways
that growth models could be used,
and identifying a growth model that produces measures
that can support that kind of use.
So, next slide, please.
Okay, so this is about the work that's ongoing at ETS
on improving the stability
of these group level measures of growth.
And this is done, led by J.R. Lockwood, who is on today,
and Katherine Castellana, who I just mentioned,
and Dan McCaffrey, who is also an ETS expert
in measuring growth.
Go ahead, please.
So, I just said the first part.
So, what they are working on
is an estimated best linear predictor model.
And this is something that
comes from the classical statistical approaches,
and the purpose of this estimated
best linear predictor model
is to improve accuracy of aggregated group level measures.
That's the primary purpose of the model.
And if you can go to the next slide, please.
What's nice about that is that improving accuracy
can have a fortuitous side effect.
Essentially, we can reduce year-to-year fluctuations
in group level measures,
and the degree of reduction is related
to the number of students in a group,
such that reduction in that fluctuation
increases as group size decreases.
So, essentially, what that happens,
this nice side effect is that it means
that the degree of stabilization
is the greatest where it's most needed.
Next slide, please.
So, what is the EBLOP model?
The EBLOP model is not a growth model.
It does not change individual student growth measures
from the residual gains model.
It doesn't produce growth measures.
What it is is it's a statistical model
that takes those growth measures
from the growth model, in this case,
a residual gains model,
and it creates a more accurate or group level measure
from those inputs by going beyond simple averages
of individual student growth measures.
Next slide, please.
So, the EBLOP model improves aggregate measures
by incorporating individual student growth measures
from at least two school years.
So, what that means is to gain a growth measure
or to obtain a growth measure,
you have to have two measurement occasions.
You have to have two times that they have taken,
the students have taken the assessment
in consecutive school years.
And so, what that means is that for the purposes
of this approach that is to be used
or is likely to be used or intended to be used
for stabilizing results from the residual gains model,
it would take two years for the first measure
and another two years from the second measure,
and that middle year often is what often overlaps
to constitute those two years of growth data.
So, what it does is it creates a weighted average
of student growth measures from multiple school years,
rather than just the simple average
in the current year.
And in calculating aggregate growth measures,
the EBLOP model gives greater weight to data
from the most recent school year,
growth measure data from the most recent school year,
and less weight to data from the previous school year.
So, what it does is that compared with simple averages,
the EBLOP model has the greatest impact for small groups
and almost no impact for large group,
and that's because the large group,
simple averages are already more accurate
and stable than for small groups.
Go ahead, please.
So, at this point, ETS is conducting an evaluation
of that EBLOP model using residual gains estimated
from the California data from the 2016-17 school year,
2017-18 school year, and 2018-19 school years.
And the results of that evaluation will be presented
at the September 2020 meeting.
And this is an important part of the process
to understand and evaluate how well this model is able
to stabilize the residual gains growth measures
from those three years.
So, we can see what it looks like
when these growth measures are provided.
Great.
And I think that is the end of my slides.
That is, and so I'm gonna turn it back over
to President Darlene Hammond to allow for questions
from board members, clarifying questions
to our experts at ETS.
All right, are there any questions
that anyone has at this point?
I know there's still a little bit more to the presentation.
I'm not seeing anyone raising their hand.
So, thank you very much, Joe.
It's nice to see you.
Are you actually out there in the mountains
or is that just a backdrop?
That's a Michigan National Lakeshore.
Lovely.
Nice to talk to you as well.
Oh, and I do see some hands going up now.
So, I'm gonna start with member Strauss
and then member Patio Bronson, member Navo,
and member Pangolinan.
And then I'm just scrolling
to make sure I haven't missed anybody.
All right, Eileen, do you want to start us off?
Thanks.
First of all, Cindy and West Ed and the whole team
and Joe, thank you so much.
We still have more presentations
so just so people realize we're not yet at the end.
I know.
Okay.
So, Joe, I just have a question.
We've been talking about, and I just need clarification
just because you had so many details
and I know you're trying to lay the foundation
because we have new board members
and we've been talking about this for a long time.
But would you clarify,
we've been talking about residual gain model.
That's what we've been talking about.
That's what we've narrowed down.
And now you've brought up
the estimated best linear predictor model.
Is that a model that is part of the residual gain
and provides for stability and less volatility
or is it a completely separate?
Could you just clarify the difference of the two?
Sure.
The difference is that the residual gains model
gives an estimate of individual student growth
that can be aggregated for a specific group.
The EBWEP model is a model with a purpose
of improving the accuracy of those group level results.
So it is layered on top of the regression,
the residual gains results.
So it takes the results from the residual gains model
and it creates group level aggregate measures
that are more accurate using the EBWEP model.
So they're separate models.
It does not change the nature
of the individual student growth measures.
It won't change them actually at all.
The only thing that it does
is it creates a weighted average
that is much more accurate than a,
that is more accurate than a straight
or simple average of those.
So it really is,
we're still on the residual growth model strategy
and this is really just a way to aggregate
the data that comes from that
in a way that allows us to use multiple years of data,
giving more weight to the most recent year.
Kim, you're next.
I just had a quick clarifying question
on I think it was slide 14.
I believe it was Deb's presentation.
So the last presentation actually.
And there was a bullet and I mentioned
that I think that there was a 2016 decision
to not include student demographics in the modeling.
And I just wonder if you could describe the background
for that decision and how that affects the model.
So there was a conversation at the board
with some of the criteria that they wanted to see
in a growth model.
And it was actually presented by our colleagues
in the assessment division.
And based on those conversations,
it was clear that they didn't wanna put student demographics
into the model.
A lot of states do put student demographics in a model.
And basically what that does is when you do that,
you're setting lower expectations for student groups
that traditionally are underperforming
because you're setting a different expectation for growth
based on the prior.
And the state board felt that that wasn't appropriate.
They felt that they wanted all students
to the same expectation for all students
in regards to growth.
And of course, when you have a residual gain model,
the expectations are based on prior year test scores.
So there is some slight adjustments
about the expectations for students
that are performing lower in one year
than higher in another year,
but it's based on prior test scores
and not on the fact that they're not on the race
or their program status.
And I will also just note that many states
do not use the demographics in a model as well.
It's a wide distribution of practices out there
among the states.
But this is kind of just purely saying,
where were you in time one
and where was the student in time two
and how much growth is essentially the theory of the model
that we're currently looking at.
Kim, did you wanna follow up on that at all or are you good?
Sorry, I just wanna make sure
I'm understanding it correctly.
So I get the idea of not wanting to set lower expectations
based on the most immediate year,
but we'll still have data to show obviously
sort of who's hitting standards.
Oh yeah, we will still be able to disaggregate the data.
We simply wouldn't be adjusting the growth
based on demographic considerations.
Okay, so in terms of the bird's eye view,
we still have the disaggregated data,
but we're not setting targets
based on the disaggregated data, is that right?
It doesn't have to do with the targets.
It has to do with how you get the growth metric.
So if you include demographics in the model,
it's basically saying that you're controlling
for the economic status or disability status
or language status or racial or ethnic category
of a student and the expected growth becomes,
is changed by that.
Yeah, sure.
And what the board previously said
is we're not going to make different expectations,
but once you've got the growth measure,
you can still set targets from year to year,
or you can disaggregate by any group
that you want to disaggregate by.
Okay, that latter part is very helpful, thank you.
Brenna, and then I have member Glover Woods in the queue.
Linda, we also have Ting
who would like to ask a question.
Okay, great.
So I have a clarifying question.
I believe it was on slide 23 and 24.
So I was a little bit confused about the last bullet point
and I'd like to ask some clarifying questions
just in regards to the statement that it says
it can help evaluate policies, programs
and interventions, however, at the next slide,
it says it can't tell what is causing the growth.
So what's the difference between those two
just for a little clarification?
Oops, you're muted.
Joseph, would you like to take that question, please?
Sure, sure.
The difference there is that program evaluation
does not necessarily try to look at these kinds of gains
as particularly causal.
So essentially what we are doing
when we do that kind of program evaluation
or policy evaluation work is to look at something
along the lines of, okay, here we had,
this is what the kind of the baseline achievement was,
the baseline growth levels
before we put this particular piece into play.
We put this policy in place,
we put this program in place,
we decided on an intervention and so on.
And so what we would typically do
is we would try to do as much as we can
to reduce any problems in the study design
or to reduce any issues that could be introduced
by not having a randomized control trial.
So essentially what we're saying is
when we put this into place, we should see X,
we should see an increase in achievement
or we should see growth get higher.
And that actually does take out one of the big things
that can happen with quasi causal modeling
is you actually have a point in time
where you can kind of say, let's break it right here.
And we can look at what was happening
before we put that into place,
we can look at what happened after we put it in place
and we can compare it with prior years
where we had no change at a given point in time.
So we're eliminating one of those pieces
that is a problem.
We can actually identify a place
where we have interrupted that time series,
essentially interrupted time series design
where we know what happened before,
we can kind of follow it over time.
Afterward, we can see how that changed.
And depending on how much people work
to reduce the other problems that we have with the design,
we can be more confident in it.
We can't ever get to perfect certainty on that
because we didn't have a randomized control trial.
But if we put in the effort,
we can reduce much of the issues that we're seeing
not get rid of them, but we can reduce the issues
that non-randomized control trials.
True.
Okay.
You good with that?
Cynthia, you're next and then Ting and then Patricia.
Thank you.
I had a question and this was probably for Joe
around the weighting of the data from the various years.
My understanding, and if I'm incorrect, please correct me
as that the use of the EBLIP really is gonna help
to stabilize the data itself
and the weighting of the data years will help.
How will the weight be determined
for each of the years of data that's being utilized?
I'm gonna ask J.R. Lockwood to respond to this.
He's the developer of the EBLIP method, primary developer.
Hi, thanks for that question, Cynthia.
That's a great question.
So the method takes all of the growth data
from the entire state for multiple years
and fits a statistical model to those data
that produces a set of weights or produces a method
for producing weights for a given school
that should produce a number that is as accurate as possible.
Accurate means it should be as close to truth as possible.
So the weights for a given school will depend
on how many students are contributing
to the growth measure for that school in various years,
as well as some other statistical parameters
that are estimated using data from the entire state
and the weights are selected to try to make accuracy
as large as possible.
I'm not sure that helps.
That helps a little bit.
I'll keep listening.
Thank you.
Okay, Ting, I think you're next.
And I just have a couple of comments and a question
and it may be because we may have more of the presentation,
but so as a person who've been pushing
and pushing this growth model,
I was very excited to see
that we are still continuing to work on it
and that the technical aspects of this is getting deeper
and that we are gaining a stakeholder input in this.
And I appreciate the presentation outlining
what we're looking at and what it can do
versus what it cannot do.
I think we really need to be very clear about that
going into this and since we're putting a lot of time,
energy and effort and resources into it.
I am concerned though, overall,
that it feels like it's getting further and further away
from what we had wanted it to be.
And I was hoping more along the lines
of getting to more of that individual student growth
and it's looking and sounding like
we're not able to do that.
So that's one thing that maybe somebody can address.
And then the other one I ask is that
given that we don't have the 2020 testing
and we come back in 2022 with the growth,
how will we, I guess we're anticipating
that there's going to be learning loss in this gap of time.
So what does that do to this model, growth model?
How accurately will it really be able to tell us
what is happening given that we have this huge
one year gap in scores?
So Ting, I would like to do your last question first
if possible and ask JR if he'd be willing
to respond to that question about learning loss
and figuring that into the growth score.
Yes, so one of the things that I think would be reasonable
to do would be to use assessment data from the state
prior to the pandemic and then to look at the data
and then starting again whenever testing resumes
to try to estimate the potential learning loss
that has occurred.
And I quickly jotted down some ideas yesterday
for how that could be done.
There's some well-established techniques
in the evaluation literature that can be used to do that.
It would require a lot of planning
and there's no one right way.
So a lot of different things would have to be looked at
and you're kind of looking for a bunch of corroborating
evidence from different types of analyses.
I think that that's a really important analysis to do
would take a fair amount of time to plan
and to figure out which approaches might be most promising
and feasible.
We can do some of that, that's not we,
that can be done with data to some extent
that already exists because there are certain types
of these methods that the data that we already have
could tell us something about the viability
of those methods once we actually have post-pandemic data.
I can go into as deep a detail as you want.
I shall stop now.
I think you should stop now.
I just, just a little flag, this item,
if we were on our schedule, we would finish by 11.
So just want to keep our conversation moving
and hopefully that's satisfying enough for the moment.
Patricia, you're next.
I was at Darling-Hammond, we didn't respond
to member Ting's first part of her question
about student growth scores. Oh, sorry, thank you.
I didn't know if you wanted to take that
or you want us to take that?
No, no, go ahead, please.
Okay, so I think member Sun,
this is something that has been at the heart of the confusion
that while this is a student level growth model
being used in the accountability system,
we're looking at how schools and student groups
as well as districts and student groups are doing.
Students receive their student growth,
their score reports on an annual basis
and how this will be incorporated into those reports.
I mean, currently they already are able to look
at multiple years of their assessment data
when they get their student growth scores.
So rather their scores annually for assessments.
But I know Malbang is on the line
and she can speak to if there's anything specific
around the student reports
that come through the assessment division.
Okay, I guess what's the difference
than we do already look at groups of students
and their growth from, well, we look at grade levels
from one year to another.
I mean, I guess what does this do more
than what we currently have?
Okay.
So what we have now is the change in distance to match.
And that is just looking,
it doesn't look at a cohort of students,
it just looks at the students that you have in the school
from one year to the next.
So the growth model is actually looking
at a cohort of students,
those students that have matched scores
from one year to the next to determine growth.
And that is something I think that all this,
the board members and the stakeholder groups want it.
Yeah.
And if you think about it this way,
there are some schools that have quite a bit of mobility.
So the kids who are in the school,
this year half of them weren't there last year,
for example, that's not uncommon in some communities.
So when you get two sets of scores,
they're not for the same kids necessarily.
Whereas the growth model allows you to say
for all the kids who were here last year
and are also here this year,
the kids we've got to teach all year long,
how did they grow?
And then that's really the conceptual difference
in what we would be reporting.
Right now we have a sort of a progress score,
but for each school,
but not a growth metric for the students.
Yeah.
But schools right now can do that.
They can take data of students
who were in fourth grade last year
and now are fifth graders
because they have the chance.
They can do that.
We will make by doing this,
we would make what gets done at any level more accurate
by for example,
allowing more growth to be shown at the top end of the scale
and some of the other things that we talked about.
And I see that as useful.
I was hoping that we would get a little bit deeper
into something that's actionable,
more actionable on a student basis.
So that's my bit of disappointment in this model.
But I understand technically how difficult it is to do.
Well, and one of the things that can underlies the process
that we've been going through over the many years
that this has been on the table
is that what you might do to satisfy some interests
in using the scores is different than what you would do
to satisfy other interests.
And as a state agency,
our primary responsibility is for the reporting
of the system on an accountability level
in terms of, as Cindy said,
groups of students, programs, schools, districts.
There are other technical issues that will arise
if you started to try to do something
at the level of the classroom or the student.
And so I just think we can come back to some of that
if we need to.
Is there anything you wanted to add to that, Cindy or Jenny,
before we go to Patricia and then back to your presentation?
No, I think we're good.
Okay, Patricia, you're next.
Linda, she put her hand down,
so I think she's no longer in the queue.
Okay, great, maybe that question got answered.
So please continue.
Great, so I'm gonna conclude this section
of the discussion with an overview
of our detailed timeline of action.
We started the presentation with action
that you're gonna be taking,
but I wanted to emphasize on this slide particularly
that there are six different opportunities for input
from the public prior to a decision
and approval of a growth model in November.
So just to walk through these so that you're left
with sort of what's on our to-do list
from the Department of Education,
working with our technical experts at ETS.
As ETS will be concluding their report
to present to our technical design group,
and I realize that our new board members
may not be familiar with this group,
it is an advisory group to the Department of Education
that is staffed by technical experts in the field
from major institutions in California,
as well as experts from school districts,
and so we do have a nice representation
from school districts.
We will then go before
the California Practitioners Advisory Group,
which is on here, the acronym is CPEG,
and that is an advisory group
to the State Board of Education
that is required under the Every Student Succeeds Act,
the federal law around education and accountability,
and we'll take that to their meeting in August.
We follow those meetings up with what we call
our Local Control Funding Formula Stakeholder Meeting,
and we'll use that opportunity,
which we did in the prior meeting this year,
to respond to questions
that the stakeholders may have about the presentation,
and this will give them an opportunity
to ask clarifying questions
and really have it be a dialogue.
ETS will continue to conduct additional technical work
on the growth model as needed
and requested by the technical design group,
so that by the time we come to the board in September,
we'll have preliminary results of the data,
so of the methodology as compared
to the prior residual gain model
that we presented to you back in July of 2018,
and we will be seeking, again,
direction on which model to pursue,
so within the residual gain model
and the EBLIP methodology.
October will be another technical design group meeting
of the discussion of that final ETS report,
again, with the intent of the board
providing us further direction in September.
We will put forward to you an information memorandum
with that report, so it'll be publicly available then,
and then we'll go again to the CPAG group,
to that group that advises you on this,
and then to present information on the growth model,
we'll have an additional LCFF stakeholder meeting,
and then we'll bring forward to you
a recommendation for action in November.
During this time, as we're getting the results
and the preliminary results of this data
and the final report is delivered to us from ETS,
we will be working on what a report looks like,
and so because this is not being used
for high-stakes accountability at this time,
we need to make this right,
so we are in a continuous improvement system,
this is how the accountability system was designed
back in 2016, and so December will be the first version
of getting that data out, but I am confident
that we'll be spending much of the winter and spring
really trying to get it right,
and also trying to educate, again, the public
to Member Sun's comment about what this is
and what it's not, and how it can be used in districts,
how it can be used at schools,
and whether it's appropriate
to use in individual classrooms.
So with that, we did have a discussion,
a couple of discussion questions,
and if this is okay, this would close out
the growth model discussion,
so the CDE would like the Educational Testing Services
to conduct data simulations to determine the impact
of the EBLIP on the residual gain model
and share the results at your September meeting,
so are you supportive of moving forward with this option,
and do you have any concerns
with what we've presented to date?
Thank you very much.
I want to really recognize the staff.
This has been a long journey for the staff,
and they've done Yeoman's work,
both with the stakeholder groups
and with the technical advisory group and so on,
so Cindy and your entire staff, thank you very much.
Public comment slide needs to go.
And then I'm gonna get people queued up.
There's a delay when people try to call in.
Linda, we still, we're not done with this item yet
for public comment, we still have more to go.
I thought Cindy was closing us out.
I'm sorry, we do have two parts to this slide,
and the other was the update on the legislative action.
So if you'd like us to proceed on that,
and we can come back to the discussion.
Yeah, please do that.
Okay. Please do that.
All right, so for this piece of the discussion,
I have just a few slides that relate to the dashboard,
and I'm gonna turn it over to my colleague,
Lindsay Tonatori, to talk about the local control
and accountability plan,
and what was done under the trailer bill.
So this past week,
the Governor Newsom signed trailer bill,
rather trailer bill, or Senate Bill 98.
And this has several references
to the California school dashboard.
The ones that I thought you would be most interested in
are really operationally what it means for us for fall.
So it prohibits the department
from publishing the dashboard in 2020,
and from identifying local educational agencies
in 2020, 2021 school year,
or technical assistance or intervention process.
So really, when we release the dashboard,
it's typically in December,
and so we would not release the dashboard
with state or local indicators.
We do, are anticipating to be able to release
school information on the dashboard this fall,
so information about student enrollment,
student group information, enrollment specifically.
So you wouldn't see a skip in the year
when you're looking at the dashboard,
you just simply not see information
on local or state indicators.
This bill further directs that the department
for purposes of identifying local educational agencies
for intervention or technical assistance a year from now,
so December of 2021 to use performance data
on the state and local indicators from December of 2019,
which is change on the dashboard
looking at status for December, 2021.
So we have a clear guidance from the legislature
that we are going to use nonconsecutive years
to create color on the dashboard for 2021.
So the second slide I have related to the dashboard
is about the things that are related
in absence of a dashboard,
in which this legislation requires or rather directs
the department to publish any valid and reliable data
collected through our student level data system,
commonly known as CALPADS
or California Longitudinal People Achievement Data System
that would have been included in the 2020 dashboard
on DataQuest, which is our publicly reporting site
or by any other means.
And so some of the things
that we are talking about here in the department
is being able to, of course,
produce graduation rates for this year,
potentially a college career indicator,
but just the status only.
That would not be on the dashboard.
It would be on a sister site.
Things like truncated suspension rate.
So those are the things
that we've been talking a lot about
and we'll have more information for you
as we actually start receiving that data
and we close out our data collection,
which takes place at the end of each August.
So right now, districts are reporting to us
the data that we would normally produce in the dashboard.
During the summer, we have about a three,
three and a half month window
for districts to report that information to us.
And then finally, just in this ongoing theme
of trying to align our systems,
San Joaquin County Office of Education,
who was our contractor for the dashboard,
this appropriates $450,000 to them
to support that integration of not only the dashboard,
but the local control and accountability,
electronic template system,
and the school accountability park card or the SART.
And with that, I'm gonna turn it over to my colleague,
Lindsey Tonatori.
Welcome.
Good morning.
President Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy Gregson,
members of the board, new members of the board.
My name is Lindsey Tonatori.
I am the Director of the Student Achievement
and Support Division,
formerly known as the Improvement
and Accountability Division here at CDE.
So prior to the holiday weekend,
we sent out an information memorandum
regarding the learning continuity
and attendance plan requirements as laid out in SB98.
Today, I'm here to provide an overview of that memo,
share our plan for collecting stakeholder input
while we develop the template
for our learning continuity plans,
and explain the three-pronged approach
that we are taking to support our LEAs
through the development and implementation process
of these plans.
So as Cindy mentioned,
the California School Dashboard shall not be published
in December 2020 based on performance data
of state and local indicators.
In addition to that,
Trailerville SB98 also waived the local control
and accountability plan requirement
for the 2020-21 school year.
SB98 also separated the development and adoption
of the budget overview for parents
from the development of the LCAP.
The budget overview for parents must be adopted still
by December 15th of 2020,
and the requirements for a separate public hearing
and adoption at a public local governing board meeting
are consistent with California Education Code 5206.4.1.
Still remain.
So the biggest part of SB98 that I'm here to talk about
is the establishment of Section 4.3.509 in Education Code,
which is, of course,
the Learning Continuity and Attendance Plan.
And though CDE, we love our acronyms,
we are referring to the Learning Continuity
and Attendance Plan as the Learning Continuity Plan
and not the LCAP, because this is not an LCAP.
It's very different.
And so to make sure that we are all staying in our lanes
and reminding ourselves, too,
of the approach that's going to be required for this,
we are referring to it as the Learning Continuity Plan.
The Learning Continuity Plan also requires for the CDE
under the leadership of our State Superintendent
of Public Instruction in consultation
with the Executive Director of the State Board
to create a template for LEAs to use
on or before August 1st.
The content that is to be included
in the Learning Continuity Plan template
is very much prescribed through this legislation.
And it is because this language is so prescriptive
that we feel we are able to create a high-quality template
that will be meaningful to our LEAs
as they develop their plans and get them adopted
by their local governing boards
by the September 30th deadline.
In addition to following the statute
to develop the template,
we are also seeking stakeholder input.
We have reunited the LCAP Advisory Committee
who worked on the LCAP three-year template
that was approved this past January
and includes representatives from county offices
of education, districts, charters, and advocacy groups.
The CDE internal process is going on right now,
and we are also looking forward to the input
that we will receive during an upcoming
stakeholder input session on Tuesday, July 14th at 11 a.m.
If members of the public are unable
to attend the stakeholder input session on the 14th,
but want to give feedback,
they can do so by emailing our LCFF email box.
The draft template will be posted on the CDE webpage
and shared through our listservs by this Monday, July 13th.
We plan to collect written comments from the public
between July 13th and July 19th,
and these comments will inform the final versions
of the draft template that we'll work on
with close consultation with members of the state board staff
before seeking our final approval.
And so I wanted to, of course, all of this information
is included in the memo sent out last week,
but I wanted to highlight some of the requirement areas
that LEAs must follow as they develop their plans,
you know there are a lot of new areas
that our LEAs are managing as they prepare
to reopen schools safely in the fall.
So the first is LEAs must hold
meaningful stakeholder engagement and adoption processes.
And so what that means is, again,
to highlight parts from the memo,
they must consult with teachers, parents,
principals, administrators, other school personnel,
other bargaining units and solicit recommendations
and comments of members of the public
regarding specific actions and expenditures.
Similar to the LCAP,
LEAs must present their learning continuity plans
to their parent advisory committee
and English learner advisory committees.
Throughout the plan development
and stakeholder feedback process,
LEAs must provide for remote participation
in public hearings.
The learning continuity plan
also has specific adoption requirements,
which include one public hearing for review and comment
and a separate public meeting after,
but not on the same day as the public hearing
to adopt the plan.
LEAs need to address what additional supports
they are providing for peoples with unique needs,
including English learners,
peoples with exceptional needs
served across the full continuum of placements,
peoples in foster care
and peoples who are experiencing homelessness
during the period in which distance learning is provided.
And the final area I want to highlight
are the last few bullets on this slide,
which are the content areas or the buckets
that LEAs will address in their learning continuity plans.
So again, to highlight information
that is included in the memo,
some of these buckets that we're thinking about
are instructional offerings
and specifically actions LEAs will take
to offer classroom-based instruction whenever possible,
especially for students
who have suffered significant learning loss
or are at greater risk of experiencing learning loss.
Thinking about student and staff,
mental health and social and emotional wellbeing,
a description of how LEAs will monitor
and support student mental health
and social emotional wellbeing
and the professional development
and resources that will be provided.
School nutrition,
this is specific to the continuation of meals
for students who are eligible
for free and reduced price meals
while they are participating in in-person instruction
or distance learning.
And also distance learning,
so inclusive of plans for the multifaceted approach
that it is going to take to focus on learning acceleration
and ensure that all students have equitable access
to instructional resources, technology and connectivity
so they can participate in distance learning.
Finally, again, to reiterate,
it's important to remember this plan is not no cap.
And we've had to, again,
we've had to remind ourselves of that many times.
So the approach and the process for the development
is going to be very different.
And therefore, we are working on multiple ways
that we will support our LEAs
through the development and implementation process
of the continuity plans.
So first, we have a series of upcoming webinars coming.
The next webinar is going to be this coming Tuesday
on July 14th.
I mentioned earlier about stakeholder input.
This webinar is going to be based on
to walk through the draft template we have.
We'll answer questions.
Participants can put questions and comments in the chat.
All of those questions and comments will be taken
and used to inform the next iteration of the draft.
Additionally, again,
if members of the public cannot attend
this July 14th webinar,
there will be opportunities for them to email the LCFF inbox
and also the template will be posted on our webpage.
We also have several other webinars coming up.
The times and topics are posted, again,
at this link here shown on this slide,
which is the CDE Tuesday at Two webinar webpage.
And login information to access that will also be included.
So in addition to the webinars that CDE will host,
we are also working across state agencies
and with our partners in the field
to support the development and implementation
of the learning continuity plans.
We have already had discussions
and set wheels in motion to align efforts
among CDE, CCEE, state board, and CSESA through CISC.
And actually one of our new board members,
board member Woods has been very instrumental
in helping us to align these efforts.
So thank you for that.
We see this work as having three big phases.
So the first phase, of course,
being the development of the template,
because of course the template will guide
the way in which LEAs have their discussions about the plans.
The second phase of this work is to cultivate tools
and resources that already exist.
We have a lot of high quality resources,
especially within the past few months
that have been circulating around for the field.
And we wanna make sure that we are pulling
the resources together in a way that is feasible,
digestible, manageable, and helpful to our LEAs.
So CDE and CCEE will take the role of air traffic control
to coordinate these efforts amongst all of our state agencies
and county offices and educational organizations.
Once we have the resources cultivated
and put into forms that are basic slide decks,
facilitation tools, and also indexes of resources,
then we're going to really mobilize the system of support,
asking all of our leads to take a role
in becoming comfortable with these resources
so that they can help all of their LEAs have conversations
and think about how they're going to use these resources
in the planning and development of their plans.
The main goal of all of this work, of course,
is to provide ongoing targeted support
for the process for the continuity plans
so that we can meet the needs of our LEAs,
take some a little stress and anxiety off of their plates
so they can focus on responding to the needs
of their communities, schools,
and most importantly, their students and families.
So with that, I will turn it over back
over to my colleague Cindy.
President Darling-Hammond,
this does conclude our presentation.
And the next slide has a public comment,
so I don't know where you want to start today.
That's great, let's go to that slide.
I know there is a lag for people
who are doing the live stream
to see that we're ready for them to call in.
We want to open the phone line for the public comment queue.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the number
that is listed here, 712-432-0075,
entering the access code 651905 out.
And then you wait for the operator prompt
to press star six and then another prompt
to press one to enter the queue.
While we're waiting for members of the public to call in,
I want to ask Eileen Strauss
as one of our accountability liaisons,
if she has any initial comments,
then I'll ask board members
if they have any other clarifying questions,
but we want to get to the public comment
and then return to board members
for any further discussion.
Well, I'll start with my initial comments
and just thank member Ting Sung,
who's also our assessment liaison
because I think it kind of combines
both issues at this point.
First, I think the state board's taken a long time
and a thoughtful process.
I think we're very, very committed
to having a growth model
and I think we want to get it right.
I think we have a lot we can learn from other states
and in the process and I so appreciate the work
of the CDE team and Wested,
but ETS and running our modeling
and trying to make sure we get it right.
I think the issues that were brought up
in today's presentation about stability
and to avoid volatility,
I think are really important
so that when we go for adoption in November,
we actually have the best possible model
to give us the right information.
I also believe that the comment about communication
so important that Cindy shared
and what member Sung shared
that we need to talk to people
about what a growth model does,
what it can do and what it can't do.
And so I think we want to make sure
that we pay attention to the development
of communication and tools
so that people know what to do with this model as well.
I just really appreciated the stakeholder input.
I think it helps to guide our work.
I know we have an overwhelming commitment
to see this through to adoption
and our stakeholders have been very helpful
and very clear about why we need to have a growth model
and why it's so important.
And so I think I'll look forward to the update in September
with the additional data runs that we're going to do
and then also participating later
after the public comment in our discussion today.
But I think just overall,
I believe that we are on the right track
and that we are intentional about getting this
as right as we can so that we adopt it
as an effective tool for LEAs to use.
Thank you.
That's great.
Thank you very much.
And member Sun as assessment liaison,
is there anything you want to add
before we hear the public comment?
Nothing more to add to what member Strahl had just said.
Okay, great.
Hopefully now we have some folks queued up
for public comment.
We encourage you to please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Please remember to turn down the speaker volume
of your computers if you're following the live feed
so that we don't hear both.
Speakers will be limited to one minute each.
Do we have any public comment?
Currently we have seven in the queue.
Okay.
Caller, you're unmuted.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, Marcia Zaragoza Diaz,
representing California Association for Bilingual Education
and the California Together Coalition.
My comments are specific to the growth model.
We are encouraged that work continues
on the student growth model.
However, there needs to be an opportunity
for public and stakeholder input using real data
and details on how different approaches
to presenting and explaining the growth model
might be considered.
Currently, assessment results reports EL and RFIP
in the last four years as one score.
When the board releases the student growth data in December,
it is requested that the English learner growth data
be disaggregated by English only
and RFIPs classified in the last four years.
Let us take the opportunity to do this
in order to establish a growth model
that will accurately show the growth
of our English learners.
Thank you.
Next caller, your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Maria Arias
and I have my son, Samuel Arias,
who wished to also give public comments,
so I requested two minutes, please, thank you.
Hello, my name is Samuel Arias.
I am a 10-year-old student in fourth grade.
I need help in math and in reading.
Montana Unified School District has filed due process
against me not to provide services.
Please help children like me and Nate.
Thank you for your support.
Hello, this is Maria Arias, mother of Samuel Arias.
I have three children with special needs.
I'm a community member
in the city of Fontana Unified School District.
I've been battling with the school district
for several years, approximately eight years.
The school district has misused taxpayer funds
to file against parents with special needs,
especially during the pandemic.
They filed against our family in April 1st, 2020,
and we wish accountability to ensure all cell buds
and school districts provide education, not litigation.
Thank you so much for the opportunity
to provide comments for my son and myself.
Please help children in need in the city of Fontana
and close by cities.
Thank you.
Next caller, your time starts now.
Shelly Coleman, your time starts now.
Shelly Coleman.
Okay, we'll go to the next caller
and perhaps Shelly can call back in.
Next caller, you're up.
Shelly can call back in.
Next caller, your time starts now.
I'm Leslie Lopez from EdVoice,
and we recommend the board direct the superintendent
to establish a section for evidence
of minimum daily instructional time by grade span
in the Learning Continuity Plan template
and require districts to explicitly state
what their minimum daily live interaction expectations
will be.
Direct synchronous instructional time
is critical to learning,
and this spring it was both lacking
and highly inequitable,
and if it continues into 2020-21,
we believe the state will be sanctioning
new unconstitutional next year of opportunity
on top of known achievement gaps
and clear violation of but for the state of California in 1992.
EdVoice also requests the board provide
additional opportunity for public input
before taking action to finalize
the residual gain student growth model,
as we believe it is critical to receive
broad stakeholder input prior to making key policy decisions.
Also, we recommend the board direct staff
to evaluate the use of a two-year residual gain
measure of growth that students have made
from spring 2019 to spring 2021
and allow for comparison to past groups.
The value of the analysis would help the state
and districts better understand overall learning loss
and the loss that individual students
and subgroups have experienced.
Time.
Low income English learners cost.
Thank you so much.
Next speaker, your time starts now.
Good morning and welcome new board members.
My name is Jessica Saco here on behalf of Children Now.
SB 98 requires the learning content template
to be developed by the state superintendent
in consultation with the state board
and includes the requirement that distance learning
include daily live instruction.
Consequently, we urge the board to consult
with the superintendent to include
specific requirements in the template
that would require districts to define
what their minimum daily live interactions will be.
Relative to the growth model,
we're appreciative of the progress
that has been made to date
on the development of the growth model.
We urge the board to direct CDE staff
to explore ways to measure student learning loss
as discussed by the ETS expert during the presentation.
In that expert, we encourage the board
to direct CDE staff to explore ways to measure student learning
loss as discussed by the ETS expert during the presentation.
In that exploration, we encourage the evaluation
of a two-year residual gain measure of growth
that students may have made from spring 2019 to spring 2021
and allow for a comparison to past growth
over a similar time period.
In conclusion, I refer you to our two letters
that we are co-signatories on from the LCFF Equity Coalition
and the Alliance for Students
Next caller, your time starts now.
Good morning, I'm Sarah Lilis,
Executive Director of Teach Plus California.
First, we'd like to associate ourselves
with a letter from the Equity Coalition,
both on the growth model and on the request
to put on September's agenda a discussion
of the work plan of the state's effort
to establish objective criteria for priority one,
namely the teacher quality criteria.
We appreciate the work that the department staff is doing
to respond quickly to the new requirements
articulated in SB 98, particularly
the learning continuity plan.
Our teachers in reviewing the plan the draft plan
template were pleased to see the focus
on stakeholder engagement, especially including efforts
to reach students, families, and other stakeholders
that do not have internet or speak
languages other than English.
They're also very pleased to see the focus
on mental health and emotional well-being.
As it relates to mental health and emotional well-being,
we hope that the new plan template does not just ask
for generalized information, but really frames details
over how and who will support students
and what follow-up and supports will be provided.
Our teachers hope to continue to engage
in the feedback process, but also wanted to elevate
these issues with the state board as you advise
the department staff on how to proceed.
Thank you.
Next caller, your time starts now.
Madam President, members of the board,
this is Brian Revis calling in on behalf
of the Education Trust West.
We have some concerns about the education trailer bill.
Although it took some important steps forward
regarding distance learning, our interpretation
is that the policy framework provided
does not require any kind of minimum standard
for online or synchronous instruction,
and we think that's a pretty big disconnect.
We think students that receive synchronous instruction
are going to be advantaged quite a bit relative to their peers,
and so we would ask that in your work on the template
that you adopt a minimum standard
for this type of instruction, and if that's not possible,
we think there needs to be a lot of transparency
so that families and communities know what they're receiving
and they can advocate locally to get more
of this type of instruction.
Our fear is under the current framework,
low-income students and students of color
will get a lot less. Thank you.
Next caller, your time starts now.
Good morning, Chair Darling-Hammond
and board members and superintendents.
This is Lucy, I'm a public advocate,
also a member of the LCFF Equity Coalition.
I want to echo a lot of our colleagues
from the coalition that have already spoken.
We are in support of you directing staff
to evaluate the use of a two-year
residential gain measure of growth
so that comparisons can be made from spring 2019
to spring 2021.
This will allow for comparison to past growth
and will be an opportunity for districts
to understand students' learning loss,
especially for low-income English learners
thought to be special education and racial
and ethnic student groups.
We appreciate very much the frank conversations
we've had with staff regarding the board's
obligation to create objective criteria
for priority one teacher data to be included
in the dashboard and the accountability system.
This was a duty created in last year's education budget.
Time.
And we think it should be taken up in September.
Thank you.
Next caller, your time starts now.
Hi this is Angela DeRamos.
I'm representing California Teachers Association.
We appreciate all the hard work of the CDE
on this growth model and we're honored to be
included in the growth model stakeholder group.
There's only been one meeting since the last May board
update and so some of the concerns we have
I'm going to bring up now.
One is that only one of the methodologies
was presented to the stakeholder group.
There were others brought up but no discussion
was held on those other models.
And as previously mentioned no data runs
were provided on the methodologies presented.
Also there's been as previously mentioned
there's no discussion about the implications
of using the data from the previous year
given our lockdown and limited data.
So we are looking forward to having additional discussions
on the use of the growth model and accountability systems.
And I want to make sure that it isn't used for teacher
evaluation purposes as laid out before. Thank you.
Next speaker you're unmuted.
Your time starts now.
Hello this is Shelly Spiegel-Coleman.
Sorry about the previous time.
I got confused on which buttons to push
but I'm here representing Californians together.
I want to reinforce what Martha Zaragoza-Dia said
and I also want to suggest that in September when data runs
and information about the application of the EBLE
are presented to the state board
that those runs show student subgroups
that from the very beginning we start looking at the effects
of all the particulars of the RG model with the EBLE.
But we look at it not only for all students
but for the student subgroups from the very beginning.
And we would hope at least for information
that we're able to look at English
the current English learners and RFEP students
in those data runs to see what the implications are.
And then I want to reinforce the suggestion
from my other colleagues from the LCFF Equity Coalition
about the template at a minimum having district
report the amount of live interactive
instructions that will be delivered
if they cannot tell us what they're going to require
for a minimum at least report to us what is going to be delivered.
Thank you very much.
Susan Nisman you are not currently in the queue
but I'm going to unmute your line
if you'd like to provide public comment.
Thank you.
Susan Nisman will speak up and in agreement with our partners
Ed Voice and others from the Alliance.
Direct synchronistic institutional time is critical
to learning and was both lacking and highly
inequitable during the spring.
A recent Speak Up Parents survey in Los Angeles shows
that one in three students had contact with their teachers
only once a week or less and only 40 percent
of students received any daily live online instruction.
African-American and Latino students were up to three
times less likely to have participated in live
classes at least once a week and up to seven
times less likely to have interacted with teachers.
We believe in whether distance learning or hybrid
delivery approach we believe that the state must be clear
on minimum standards for how much live and synchronistic
instruction is required instead of delegating that decision
entirely to the local level.
We recommend that the board direct the SBI to include
a statewide minimum requirement in the learning
continuity plan template and that districts
explicitly state what their minimum daily live
and action expectations will be.
Thank you very much.
David Legstein you are currently not in the queue.
I'm going to unmute your line if you'd like to provide
public comment.
David would you like to provide public comment.
Thank you.
There are no further public comments.
Okay given that there's no other public comment we're now
open for board discussion.
Board members please remember to raise your hand in the
participant panel of the Zoom if you have a question or
comment and when we're done with comment we will move
to a break before we get to next item.
I see Patricia Rucker Matthew Navo in the queue.
And let me see if there's anyone else.
So that will start with you Patricia.
Okay so like all of my colleagues on the board I have
been I have really been looking forward to and have
appreciated the conversation presentations that have been
made about the growth model.
This is very technical stuff and I have to tell you up
until today I thought I was following the conversation
rather well because this is a register of English.
I do not speak and so it was very interesting to hear and I
do appreciate Dr.
Martino's explanation about the EBLIP because that did add
some clarity to me and alleviate some of the
concerns I have about the failing of the current model
that we're following.
My frustration is as the board member San has said is with each
successive conversation and attempt by the staff to make
the regression model work we are moving further and further
away from the intent behind the reasons why the board
originally had an interest in the regression model.
So let me suggest that in going forward and I'm hearing
clearly from the stakeholders there are multiple
expectations about what this growth model is supposed to do
and there is no consensus among the stakeholders about what
they're expecting from the growth model yet when we
finally get to the point when we are ready to start doing
the data runs and even adding this growth model to the
multiple metrics we have to give information about the
system of instruction across districts in our state.
People are going to be expecting this growth model to
do things that Dr.
Martino has clearly stated it cannot do.
So I think that while we can congratulate ourselves for the
amount of attention to the technical detail about what the
growth model will do and about the fact that we are being
thoughtful and being careful with the development and choice
to choose to implement this growth model I think that what
is clearly being shown is we're going to have to do a lot of
educating with our stakeholder community not only about what
the growth what California intends to use the growth model
for but in choosing to use the growth model what the
limitations may be but what the explicit and wonderful
potential for what the growth model will do for school
districts should be and so I appreciate the statisticians
and their expertise on that but I think we're going to have
to spend a little more time in conversation both as a board
and with all policy makers to make sure that we remain in
consensus on what we are hoping the growth model will
accomplish and that that overall goal has not changed with
and how the development of the growth model is going to work.
Thank you member Navo and then I have member Patio Bronson
and member Pangolinan in the queue.
I couldn't agree with board member Rutgers more I think
you hit it on the head in terms of educating and bringing
consensus this conversation predates my time on the board
but I do appreciate the conversation about moving to
the residual gain and I appreciate the EBLIP as it
pertains to small school districts and stabilizing the
results of the small school districts because of the small
end size so I do appreciate that discussion and I under I know
that we're trying to move efficiently and effectively
through this so I'm going to change my questions in the
comments board president just for things for the staff to
think about as they move forward as opposed to me asking
questions in relationship to what the last the last portion
of the presentation I think we're going to have questions
from the field around the technical assistance Cindy and
how that affects the current county office relationship with
current districts in technical assistance will those continue
and because it sounds like they're going to continue for
some time so there's going to be some questions there I think
there's going to be questions Cindy about how the county
office of Ed's special education schools and their
classrooms are they responsible for continuity learning plan or
is that embedded within the district's plan and last but not
least I think there's going to be quite concern or many
questions about the number of public hearings that are
necessary to adopt the plan so if I understood it correctly I
thought there were two which led me to believe there was a
public hearing and then a board meeting for additional public
hearing adoption I thought I heard there needed to be two
public hearings and then an adoption which would mean that
a district that has two board meetings a month would have to
have their plan written stakeholder engagement done by
September 4th minimum so I think there's going to be concern
for the field with those and I'll leave it at that as opposed
to dialogue a board president I appreciate that thank you very
much our member Patel Bronson and then I see that member
Glover Woods is also adding coming into the queue I wanted
to address the memo from CDE on the upcoming template that I
believe is going to be released on July 13th around what is
the distance learning plan at the LEA level and I think
there's maybe two things about structure of how it comes
forward and as I understand it the template isn't coming to
the state board for approval before it goes to LEA's and so
we don't have a formal vote to suggest one way or another but
I do think it's important for us to actually found off on it
and make sure that some of the things that I think have been
raised in public comment and also in the correspondence are
lifted up which is that to the same extent that our LCAP has
been I think moving in the direction consistently of trying
to lift up where there are racial disparities where there
are economic disparities, making sure that we don't have
COVID and distance learning become not a space where
education has been the backstop around disparities and has been
or has had the potential to be the great equalizer in the face
of great disparities but that COVID does not instead take on
the role of exacerbator of racial disparities and
educational outcomes. So I think continuing to track that
very closely is going to be incredibly important and I think
this issue of live and synchronous learning time is also
a very important one. The statute and I want to thank the
state board staff for walking us all through it but the statute
does already provide a fair amount of direction and sets the
expectation that it is minimally required that there should be a
reporting requirement around live participation around people
progress around synchronous learning time and so being clear
that the statute actually says that already that there must be
some reporting at the LEA level of what the expectations are and
what if there's something that is locally bargained what those
decisions are that have been made but I also think it
certainly is very clear that what has made California schools
great is the teacher to child interaction right and that is
the basis for learning and making sure that it is not just
you know a bunch of Khan Academy curated links is very important
because our our kids are depending on talent that is only
accessed through actual interaction. There's a quote
from Supreme Court jurisprudence which is about this idea of an
inexorable zero when zero is happening then you know it is a
undeniable problem and in my own home county there have
certainly been reports where some students haven't had any
live interaction during the three months of the last school
year and that needs to be something that the distance
learning plan addresses and enables the support necessary
for teachers to interact directly but to make sure that we
are are providing the flashlight and the sunlight that data is
supposed to provide to locals to actually be able to engage and
say this is either happening or this is not.
Thank you. It looks like member Pangolinan has come back into
the queue. Are you? Yes. There you go. You're next and then
member Glover Woods. I will also transfer my question into a
comment but so to my understanding it seems that the
process will end with a submission of the learning
continuity plan and my only concern is that I hope that once
those plans are submitted there is a way to provide support if
we feel that those plans maybe aren't comprehensive enough so
just moving past reading those plans and requiring those plans
really being interactive to make sure that what districts are
doing are really helping students just because I feel
like we could get caught in a place where it's just a
requirement once again and we have to make sure that it's
meaningful rather than just a requirement that districts have
to do. Thank you. Member Glover Woods.
Thank you. I'd like to make two comments on one based on the
growth model and the other on the learning continuity plan as
it relates to the growth model again kudos and much
appreciation to the CDE staff for all that's been done over
these last few years. I just wanted to take an opportunity
to underscore how essential it is that the data is stabilized
as I'm sure many of us know data drives a lot of what is done
at the school level and at the LEA level. Plans are written
the LCAP and others based upon what the data shows. So as
there is opportunity for the data to become more and more
stabilized the better the plans are and more importantly the
implementation of those plans will be. So again I just
continue for CDE staff to continue to look at that. I know
the EBLIP which is the estimated best linear predictor
methodology is one that seems to have the most promise in that
data stabilization. Just to encourage you to continue to
look at that and be sure that is going to be the best
methodology to be utilized with the residual growth model. My
last comment is in relation to the learning continuity plan and
again I really appreciate differentiating the local
control accountability plan or LCAP from this particular plan
because they are not synonymous and intentionally not using
LCAP as an acronym even though it's ironic that they really do
have the same acronym is going to be very, very helpful. So as
this plan in the template is being developed it is going to
be important that the template is reflective of the
information that needs to be known not only in the LEAs but
also for the community and all of the stakeholders. Also I'm
appreciative of the collaborative approach that is
being taken with the state system of support through CCEE,
CDE, CSESA and the state system of support leads and providing
resources that are going to be needed. There's a lot to be done
and I'll close with saying this. There's a lot to be done in the
next 90 days. All of our schools and districts and LEAs and our
charters are grappling with how to best reopen school within
really the next few weeks with the pandemic that continues to
shift from one way to the other. In addition to that, it's
essential that the learning continuity plan is thoughtfully
developed, that there is stakeholder engagement at all
levels so that this plan is one that helps to really chart the
path for what will take place in the 2021 school year. So there's
a lot of work to be done and I'm very confident that LEAs across
our state are grappling with all of these things and the more
that we're able to, through the state system of support through
our state agencies, provide a collaborative approach that
offers resources and guidance, the better it's going to be for
our students when they return to school for the 2021 school year.
Thank you so much and I'll encourage you to put your hands
down so I'll know when you raise them again later. And with that,
I think we thank Cindy and her team for all of the good work and
we will take a 10 minute break. I'd like to ask you to please
turn off your microphones as well as your cameras and then
turn your cameras back on and you come back in 10 minutes to
reestablish the forum. It is 1120. I will look for you precisely
at 1130. See you then.
Here.
Jim McQuillen.
Tim Sung.
Here.
Eileen Strauss.
Linda Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Cynthia Glover-Woods.
Matt Navo.
Here.
Ade Rodriguez.
Ade, you're muted.
She's frozen.
Oh yeah, her Wi-Fi froze.
Yeah.
Ade, keep on mute.
Kim Patia-Bronson.
Here.
Okay, let's see if we can get...
Ade, are you there?
Yes, I'm here.
Okay, everyone's present.
Terrific.
So agenda item three is a public hearing regarding the Arts
Education Framework item. The item is presented by Shanine
Coates of the CDE with guest presenters, IQC Chair Jose
Inegas and Arts Subject Matter Committee Chair Julie
Tonkovich and the CDE and the IQC recommend that the State
Board hold a public hearing and adopt the Draft Arts Framework.
I hereby open the public hearing at 11 33 a.m.
and Shanine, you may begin.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Linda Darling-Hammond, members of
the board, Superintendent Thurman.
As you know today, my name is Shanine Coates and I serve as
the Executive Director of the Instructional Quality
Commission. It's my honor and privilege to be in front of you
to present the Arts Education Framework for California Public
Schools Transitional Kindergarten through grade 12.
Our recommended action today is that the State Board hold a
public hearing and adopt the Draft Arts Framework, including
the additional edits recommended by the Instructional Quality
Commission on April 17th and authorize CDE staff to make any
non-substantive technical edits necessary for publication.
Together, we will provide an overview of our process and
highlights of the framework.
We will start with a snapshot of where we have been and where we
are going next.
So Assembly Bills 2862 and 37 required the California
Department of Education to revise the 2001 VAPA Visual and
Performing Arts Standards and create new standards for media
arts. This began with focus groups in January 2017 and
concluded with the State Board of Education adoption of the
California Arts Standards on January 19th, 2019.
The Arts Education Framework we present today is the second
milestone of three in the VAPA revision project.
New instructional materials are scheduled to come before the
State Board of Education and Adoption in November of 2021.
It may be useful before we delve into the arts framework itself
to talk a little bit about standards, frameworks and
instructional materials just to ground the conversation.
I'll start with standards.
Standards essentially are the what they're what we want
students to know, understand and be able to do by the end of each
grade level and at the end of their transitional kindergarten
through grade 12 experience.
And for teachers, it is also the what for instruction.
So we have standards in a variety of content areas.
Once standards are adopted, it's important to help educators and
administrators understand the standards and how to best provide
instruction for each and every child.
And we provide this through our curriculum frameworks.
Curriculum frameworks include guidance on how to deliver high
quality instruction to each and every student.
And then finally, after a curriculum framework is adopted,
we move into the world of instructional materials.
Instructional materials are the tools.
They are tools to help that in the classroom instruction to meet the standards.
Instructional materials come in different forms, such as textbooks,
worksheets and digital formats.
The state provides an initial review of kindergarten through eighth grade materials.
And this review is based on alignment to the standards and content of the frameworks.
So in summary, standards, curriculum frameworks and instructional materials
are all key supports for high quality instruction for student success.
Since the arts framework we will present today is meant to support the recently
adopted arts standards, I'm going to provide a brief overview about
what is new regarding these standards.
The new arts standards articulate standards for media arts as a separate discipline.
They are student centered, open and inquiry based.
They focus on process and are organized by four artistic processes and they
include three proficiency levels for high school.
Commissioner Tonkovich is now going to elaborate on some of these points.
Thank you, Executive Director Coats.
The discipline of media arts has been around for a very long time.
However, media arts is articulated as a separate discipline in the 2019 arts standards.
The new standards emphasize process and provide general guidelines and benchmarks,
which can be adapted to specific media.
They can be developed through and support learning in interdisciplinary contexts
such as STEAM. All of the arts disciplines may integrate aspects of media arts,
but media arts can also be taught as a separate, discrete discipline.
These new standards can help equip students to access the many opportunities
in California's creative economy.
Some applications of media arts include multimedia communication,
interdisciplinary integration, design thinking, such as in STEM and STEAM
learning and media and digital literacy.
The 2019 arts standards include enduring understandings known as EUs
and essential questions known as EQs that work together to support an inquiry
based approach to arts education.
They state big ideas or important understandings, which is why they're worth
studying in order to provoke inquiry.
They also make connections to other disciplines within and beyond the arts.
2019 arts standards focus on process and are organized by four artistic
processes shared across the five disciplines.
The four processes are creating, responding, connecting and performing
for dance, theater and music, producing for media arts and presenting for
visual arts. They focus on what students do rather than prescribe what teachers
teach and provide multiple entry points for learning.
The increased focus on process embraces inclusion and social and emotional side
of arts learning and the development of creative and resilient learners.
It reduces emphasis on products such as gallery quality artwork and polished
performances.
The artistic processes are broken down.
Could we go back to the last slide, please?
Thank you, thank you.
The artistic processes are broken down into process components in each
discipline. For example, in media art shown here, the process of creating
includes conceiving, constructing and developing.
When producing, students engage in integrating and practicing.
When responding, they perceive, interpret and evaluate.
When connecting, they synthesize and relate.
The PK through 12 performance standards are discipline specific and measurable
end of year, end of grade and course learning targets.
They are also grade level and end of course outcomes.
In terms of content, they are open rather than prescriptive.
The high school proficiency levels are flexible enough to accommodate
varying degrees of achievement by students during high school, including
those who explore a wide range of artistic pursuits and experiences, as
well as those who build on their PK eight foundation by pursuing deeper
engagement in one or more of the arts disciplines.
Here's an example of a media art standard for grade five.
The artistic process is create, the process component is conceive.
The enduring understanding is media arts, ideas, works and process.
The media arts, ideas, works and processes are shaped by the imagination,
creative processes and by experiences both within and outside of the arts.
The essential questions are how do media artists generate ideas and how can
ideas for media arts productions be formed and developed to be effective
and original? And the performance standard for students to reach by the
end of grade five is envision original ideas and innovations for media
artworks using personal experiences and the work of others.
Now I'll turn it back over to Executive Director Coates, who will
overview the framework process.
Thank you, Commissioner Tonkovich.
CDE began the development of the arts framework in August 2018 by conducting
focus groups with nearly 50 arts educators across California.
We had support from San Diego, Santa Clara, Tulare, Humboldt and Siskiyou
county offices of education who hosted the focus groups and supported this
process to ensure the inclusion of urban, suburban and rural educator voices.
We had representation of all five arts disciplines in the focus groups and
educators from 35 school districts.
Clear themes and points of agreement emerged in the focus group meetings and
the input gathered became the foundation for the IQC recommended and state board
of education adopted guidelines.
During this time, we also recruited educators and content area experts for
the curriculum framework and evaluation criteria committee, otherwise known as
the CFCC.
After the CFCC was appointed by the state board of education, they came together
at six two day meetings where they discussed and made recommendations for
revisions to the draft framework chapters.
Each CFCC meeting was publicly noticed, open to the public with opportunities for
the public to make comment during each meeting.
During the entire process, we have had steady attention and participation from
members of the public.
We have also had steady attention and participation from the arts education
organizations such as the California Music Educators Association, the
California Educational Theater Association, the California Dance Education
Association and the California Art Education Association.
I would like to call out the California Music Educators Association's
participation in the process because they were also very active in getting the
legislation passed that led to the revision of the standards and framework.
Once the CFCC completed their work, they forwarded their draft to the instructional
quality commission known as the IQC.
The IQC approved the framework for the first public comment review period.
After the first public review period ended, the IQC reviewed all of the public
comment, made its edits and its revisions and then placed the framework out for
another 60 day public comment review period.
After April 17th, 2020 meeting, the IQC made additional edits and revisions.
And that brings us to today.
I'd like to just take a moment to thank those that have been involved in this
process.
I'd like to start off by thanking Constantino Silva, Administrator of the
Curriculum Frameworks Unit and Letty Strauss, Lead Consultant for the Arts
Framework.
I'd also like to acknowledge the lead writing team, Chris Alexander, Armelon
De La O and Courtney Sawada, as well as the CFCC members.
The primary writing team worked with the guidelines to produce drafts and then
received feedback and requests and edits from the CFCC.
The CFCC was comprised of many experts with all five disciplines represented
dance, media arts, music, theater and visual arts.
The CFCC included kindergarten through 12th grade teachers, university professors,
a teaching artist, a museum educator and a librarian.
Seven members of the CFCC had been on the 2019 Arts Standards Advisory
Committee.
The Curriculum Framework and Evaluation Committee even included two individuals
who helped write these standards, the 2001 Arts Standards.
They were a knowledgeable and thoughtful group and the writers were responsive to
their feedback and requested edits.
Thank you again.
As mentioned previously, all of the CFCC meetings were open to the public and
public comment has been welcome during this entire process.
We had a dedicated email to receive that public comment.
There were two 60 day public comment and review periods.
Most stakeholders who reviewed submitted comments based on their expertise.
For example, music teachers tended to have a lot of to say about the music
chapter. There was a good balance of affirmation and critique that overall
helped condense, clarify and improve the document.
We had a good balance of participation in public comment, including some of the
SESSA Arts Initiative, regional arts leads and several university faculty who
are also pre-service credential teachers, as well as members of the California
Alliance for Arts Education.
In response to the first round of public comment, the IQC requested that chapters
four and eight be revised.
They requested that chapter eight be revised again after the second round of
public comment.
Commissioner Iniguez will now share how the framework is organized and some of
its highlights.
Commissioner.
Thank you, Executive Director Coates and good morning Superintendent Thurman,
President Darlene Hammond and members of the board.
As mentioned, my name is Jose Iniguez and as chair of the instructional quality
commission, I'm excited to discuss the organization of the arts framework with
you today.
When developing the curriculum frameworks, the IQC carefully considers how best to
support educators.
For example, we consider how to support multiple subject educators, not just
those who are content matter experts.
We also consider other audiences, including parents, administrators,
counselors, institutions of higher learning and publishers.
I'd like to note that based on the development timeline, the framework does
not explicitly address online learning strategies, something we know is highly
sought after during these challenging times.
But based on the framework development process that began two years ago, there
was no hint at that point of a pandemic necessitating increased learning online.
Nonetheless, the framework is useful in this regard.
For example, it includes pedagogical approaches such as universal design for
learning or UDL that may be used to help design online learning experiences.
With this in mind, the draft arts education framework is intended to help
implement the 2019 California art standards in TK through 12th grade
instruction and to provide guidance for developing the artistic voice of all the
students while preparing them for college and career.
The framework is composed of 10 chapters, as well as a guide to reading and using a
framework and a set of appendices that include many useful resources.
Next slide, please.
Thank you.
The guide to reading.
I'm sorry here.
Okay.
I'm having a hard time balancing the outline here on zoom.
Thank you very much.
All right.
The guide to reading and using the framework is a range of lists of the CCC and
is intended to provide entry points for different users, as I've just mentioned.
Additionally, each chapter contains a short guide to reading and using the
framework, including summary statements of that particular chapter.
We hope the guide will increase the usefulness of the framework based on
readers' backgrounds and needs.
For example, an elementary teacher may look at the integration chapter and then
at specific discipline chapters as they plan foundational arts learning
experiences to build an integrated unit or lesson.
Chapter one introduces the philosophical foundations of
lifelong goals of the standards.
It also articulates the intersection of social, emotional learning and arts
learning, something that we know is important during these trying times.
This chapter also introduces the national opportunity to learn criteria to assess
and report whether students and teachers have the necessary resources for students
to achieve the state standards.
I will address chapter two in the next slide.
Thank you.
Chapter two includes an explanation of the four artistic processes and the
process components as explained by Commissioner Tarkovitch.
It also elaborates on the arts standards, including learning targets
and a focus on student inquiry.
Given that high school students have different grade level entry points to art,
this chapter also focuses on proficiency levels for high school.
It also elaborates on inclusive practices for instruction, culturally and
linguistically responsive teaching, and universal design for learning, as I've
mentioned.
Next slide, please.
Thank you.
As indicated by the titles, chapters three to seven are specific to each arts
discipline.
Each of these chapters provide a discipline specific overview of the
standards by grade bands, TK through two, to second grade, I'm sorry, third
grade through fifth grade, sixth grade through eighth grade and high school.
Also within each discipline specific chapter, the framework elaborates on
universal design for learning, culturally and linguistically responsive teaching,
supporting students who are English learners, supporting students with
disabilities and considerations for instruction in the discipline.
A note about chapter four, public comment during our initial 60 day
public review window indicated a need to tease out something Commissioner
Tonkovich mentioned earlier.
That is how media arts may be taught as a discrete discipline or by integrating
it into the other arts discipline, prompting us to revise chapter four.
Next slide, please.
As mentioned by executive director Coates, we revised chapter eight twice.
Once after each public comment period, after thoroughly considering public
feedback, it became apparent that we needed to tease out the concept of
co-equal arts integration for the idea that integrating art with non-art
curriculum like math or science promotes higher level thinking skills such as
problem solving or recognition of patterns.
This chapter also includes a discussion of the differences in learning
foci and outcomes of sequential discrete arts learning, arts integrated,
and arts enhanced approaches.
Finally, this chapter also includes models and examples of how arts teachers
and non-art teachers might collaborate to plan for and implement integrated
instruction.
Next slide, please.
Thank you.
This quote or the quote on the slide is an excerpt from chapter nine.
Chapter nine is intended to be used in conjunction with the discipline
specific chapters, three through seven.
This chapter elaborates on how to implement effective and equitable arts
education, school and district wide programs.
It also provides guidance on how to effectively monitor and assess arts
education programs.
And it provides guidance on planning and implementing arts education program
professional learning, as well as engaging all stakeholders in leadership
and advocacy for arts education.
Chapter 10, as I mentioned, is meant for diverse audiences, including
publishers and school districts.
Chapter 10 outlines criteria to help guide and adopt a comprehensive
The IQC is scheduled to review arts related instructional materials for
grades K-8 in the fall of 2021, after which we will submit recommendations
to you, the State Board of Education.
That said, the criteria in this chapter is intended to serve as a guide for
the adoption of instructional material.
The appendices include links to a variety of important and useful resources.
The IQC is intended to provide guidance on how to implement effective
and equitable arts education programs.
And with that said, thank you for your time.
I will now turn over the presentation to our executive director, Kokes.
Thank you so much.
Now that you have some background on the standards and the content of the draft
framework, which will support the implementation of the standards, let's
talk quickly about what, what will happen if the board acts today to
approve this framework.
Legislation has scheduled a K-8 instructional materials adoption process
pending State Board action and also pending State Board action, CDE would
begin the, the editing and design of the arts education framework.
This brings us, brings us back to the action recommended before you today.
I am, we are available to answer any questions that you may have.
Thank you so much for those excellent presentations.
We'll now open the phone line for public comment queue.
And there's the slide with all the directions.
While we are waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to ask
vice president Eileen Strauss as our arts curriculum liaison, if she has any
initial comments, then if there are any clarifying questions from the board,
we'll take those and then we'll get to public comments.
Yeah.
So thank you, president Darling-Hammond.
So the visual and performing arts framework and the content standards
and I believe evaluation criteria were originally the liaison role was
Nikki Sandoval who finished her term in March.
So I've been on liaison since Nikki completed her term.
And I just want to highlight just a quote from chair Anikas is that, that
Barbara Jordan said, which was the arts can lift us up and has the potential
to unify.
And I think that's been the feeling of this framework development.
Just remember when you looked at the timeline, the last standards work in
2001 and we are in 2020 and we will not have a recommendation to the state
board for aligned materials for K-8 until November of 21.
So this 20 year process.
So I would just say as my sister, as a chair of a VAPA department at the
school, they, the arts department have been so waiting and so supportive of
this process.
So I just want to say that this is a long time in coming.
It's been very, very thoughtful, a credit to the three writers who work
with the California arts project.
They're part of the subject matter projects who play very critical roles in
our framework development and our professional development.
And to Julie Tonkovich, who's the IQC liaison to the arts, Julie lived every
word of this framework.
I would say she has been an amazing resource and Shanine Coates and her
leadership following Stephanie Gretzen in the work of the IQC, that everyone's
worked really, really hard on this.
And I just think the public comments, just so the board is aware of the
public comments, helped to influence the rewriting and the writers really
listen to the public comments in both 60 day review and in the IQC dialogue.
So this, this, this framework comes to us as a state board being really
refined and addressed.
I just wanted to highlight a couple of things.
I think the guide for reading and using the framework is going to be very,
very helpful to the field, both for the teachers and discipline specific and
those that can look to integrate across discipline.
We know that art has an ability to do that.
And I think that the addressing of universal design for learning,
particular addressing the English learners and the students with disabilities,
an important component of this framework, we have gotten really stronger as
Patricia Rucker and I have worked with instructional quality over the last 10
years, we have really seen a development in the framework process that adds
really specific chapters to really help the implementation.
It's a wonderful resource and a wonderful tool.
And I do want to say that I think the arts integration is an important
component to think about as we think about the rollout and how to help
everybody embrace the arts going forward.
So with that, let me just say this framework has gone through a wonderful
development process and refinement and lots of input and I think it's ready.
And when we listen to the public comments, I'll be ready to make a motion.
Thank you.
Okay.
I don't see anybody asking for clarifying questions at this moment.
So we'll go to public comment and then come back for board discussion.
Do we have any public comment?
Yes, we have two speakers so far.
Speaker, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Martha Zaragoza-Diaz and I'm representing the California
Music Educators Association.
CMEA is in full support of the proposed arts education framework.
It is comprehensive and provides guidance on reviewing, improving, and
developing equitable standards based arts education programs for all students.
The framework is organized into chapters that address the full range of arts
education, including the five arts disciplines through discipline specific
chapters, and it provides a clear and concise chapter on the co-equal approach
to arts integration in chapter eight.
The arts education framework is sorely needed in the arts education field and
our arts educators are waiting to use it.
All California students will benefit from this updated and comprehensive arts
education framework.
Please approve and adopt the framework.
Thank you.
Next caller, you're now unmuted.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Okay.
That particular caller has not dropped into the queue.
I'm going to attempt to unmute.
Hello, this is Carol Huddy.
I am a theater educator for the past 35 years and a member of the California
Educational Theater Association.
And I want to state our full support of the new framework.
We appreciate the transparent process of developing this framework.
We believe that our voices were heard throughout the timeline, not only through
members of the VAPA curriculum framework and evaluation criteria committee focus
groups, but through the opportunity to give public comment and the transparency of
this process solidifies the validity of the document.
The California arts framework is a valuable tool that will inform all
stakeholders to implement the standards and develop the tools necessary for
executing standards based curriculum in this classroom.
Our go-to is our goal is to aid students in arts literacy.
And this document helps educators develop creative ways to design and
implement implement the California arts standards.
This framework finally modernized tools we use in the classroom.
Please support.
Thank you.
And that is our last caller.
Okay.
With that, we'll turn to board discussion and vote on the recommendation.
Is there any, you need to close the public hearing now that.
Oh, so the public hearing is now closed at 1201 and we'll open up for board
discussion of the recommendation.
Anybody want to add anything before we get a motion to vote?
Sounds like it has been a wonderful process.
I want to thank the staff for shepherding this along so beautifully.
Do we have a motion?
Yes.
I move approval of the California arts framework, um, recommended
unanimously by the IQC.
All right.
Sorry.
Was that a second from member sun?
Yes.
Second.
Okay.
Uh, and I think we need to hold a roll call vote.
Is that unless there any further discussion?
No, we need to hold a roll call vote.
Um, Karen, can you call the roll?
Yes.
Um, Linda.
Uh, yes.
Cynthia.
Yes.
Jim.
Matt.
Yes.
Brenna.
Kim.
Yes.
Auday.
Patricia.
Yes.
Eileen.
And Ting.
Aye.
It's unanimous.
It passes.
All right.
And we have hoped to have, um, the world languages, um, framework heard before
lunch, if you can hang in there, uh, I'm seeing nods, so, um, I hope that will be okay.
Uh, we have the CDE and the IQC recommending that the state board hold a public hearing
and adopt the world language framework.
This too will be presented by Shanine Coates, uh, with, um, IQC chair, Jose
Iniguez and the world languages subject matter committee chair Alma Delia Ranteria.
Uh, I hereby open the public hearing at 1203 PM.
Shanine, please begin.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
It is my honor and privilege to be in front of you today to present the world
languages framework for California public schools, kindergarten through grade 12.
We are very excited to be here to discuss a framework that lays the foundation for
schools and districts to implement robust opportunities for California's diverse
student population, to develop multilingualism and global competence.
Today, we will briefly discuss how the contents of the world languages standards
and the guidance in the world languages framework can help strengthen the learning
of languages and the development of global competency and literacy at schools and
districts throughout California.
We had many generous partners along the way to whom we owe our deepest gratitude.
I'd like to start by thanking Constantine O Silva, administrator of the curriculum
frameworks unit, as well as Alejandro Hernandez, lead consultant, but also like
to recognize the members of the world languages standards advisory committee.
They gave shape to the direction and defined a vision for world languages education that
would be aligned to 21st century learning.
The world languages curriculum framework and evaluation criteria committee took the
standards and created guidance that ensures that the standards are fully implemented.
The writers for both the standards and the framework did an exceptional job listening
to the committee members, fleshing out the guidance and making countless edits and
revisions. The writers for the world languages standards, Brandon Zaslow and
Christine Lanfear, Tanya Byram, and Svetlana Lazarova, served in the world languages
standard advisory committee.
They then collaborated to write the world languages framework.
And so we are so very grateful to them.
The California World Language Project and the California Language Teachers Association
have consistently provided support, public comment and encouragement during the
development of both the world languages standards and the framework.
They got the word out when the framework needed snapshots and vignettes and the
world languages community responded.
This their work is an integral part of these documents.
And of course, thank you to the educators in the instructional quality commission who
ushered this work forward, advocated for language that was inclusive, provided
clear guidance to educators, parents and other stakeholders.
Last but not least, we'd like to thank Nicole Nates, who attended every meeting and
conducted presentations to both the advisory committee and the CFCC chaired the
World Languages Subject Matter Committee for years and in May 2020 facilitated a
webinar focused on providing instruction to students of world languages in a
distance learning format.
During this presentation, we will provide an overview of the content and the status
of the draft world languages framework.
And I would like to begin by sharing the two recommendations we would like the
members of the board to consider the California Department of Education and the
Instructional Quality Commission recommend that the State Board of Education hold a
public hearing and adopt the world languages framework, including the additional
edits recommended by the ICC on April 17th, 2020.
The CDE also recommends that the State Board of Education delegate authority to
the State Board of Education and CDE to make any necessary revisions as the
document is professionally edited and prepared for publication.
I'd like to start a presentation with building background, knowledge and
providing context around standards, frameworks and instructional materials.
Let's start with the standards.
Standards are what we want our students to know, understand and be able to do at
the end of every grade level and at the end of their K-12 experience for
teachers. It is the what for instruction.
Excuse me. The world language standards were adopted by the State Board of
Education in 2019.
Here is one example of a goal for a communication standard one interpretive
communication.
Students demonstrate understanding, interpret and analyze what is heard, read
or viewed on a variety of topics from authentic texts.
They use technology when appropriate to access information.
The goal is then followed by world languages standards for the novice,
intermediate, advanced and superior range of proficiency.
Once the standards are adopted, it is important to help our educators and
administrators understand the standards and how to best provide instruction for
each and every student to meet the standards.
And we do this through the support of the curriculum frameworks, which provide
guidance to teachers on how to deliver high quality instruction to each and every
student.
So members of the World Languages Committee in California are very excited to
have updated standards and a curriculum framework that supports the implementation
of those standards. Why, you ask?
Well, because this is the first time that we have both in California.
Some of you may recall that in 2003, California had a framework, but no
standards. Then in 2009, we had content standards, but due to the national budget
crisis, we were unable to develop a framework.
Exactly 10 years later, we are about to do something historic.
Provide the world languages teaching community and other stakeholders with a
framework that is aligned to our content standards.
The standards provide critical information about what students should know and be
able to do as they progress in their proficiency in languages other than
English. So after a curriculum framework is adopted, we then move to the
instructional materials, which, as we have stated, are the tools that teachers
use in their classroom to help students meet the standards.
Instructional materials come in a variety of different forms, including textbooks
and digital formats.
In summary, standards, curriculum frameworks and instructional materials are
all supports for high quality instruction for students.
I will now turn it over to Commissioner Enigas to discuss the frameworks
development process.
Thank you, Executive Director Coates. And hello again, it seems like a while.
The world languages framework development process parallels the arts
framework timeline that we mentioned earlier.
The CDE began the development of world languages framework in August 2018 by
conducting focus groups with world languages educators across California.
We have the support from San Diego, Santa Clara, and Los Angeles County
offices of education, as well as the CDE, who hosted focus groups to support
this process to ensure the inclusion of diverse perspectives.
The focus group feedback, including the several things, are the foundation for
the instructional quality commission recommended and state board of education
adopted guidelines.
During this time, we also recruited educators and world language experts to
serve on the curriculum framework and evaluation criteria, commonly referred to
as the CFCC.
After the ICC recommended to the State Board of Education approved appointments
to the CFCC, the CFCC members met for six sessions.
Each session is composed of two long meeting days or days, I should say, where
they discuss and make recommendations for revisions to the draft world
languages framework chapters.
The world languages framework development process is transparent and open to the
public.
Each CFCC meeting was publicly noticed, open to the public, and included
opportunities for members of the public to make comment each day of the meetings.
In fact, many members of the public participated in these meetings.
Once completing recommendations, the CFCC forwarded their draft to the IQC, where
we, the IQC, then reviewed the draft framework and made additional edits and
improved the draft for the first public comment review period.
After the first public review period, the IQC, with the help of the CDE, who, by
the way, meticulously and regularly reviews and organizes public comment,
thank you very much.
We can't thank you enough CDE for thoroughly organizing these comments.
Sometimes these comments are well over a thousand, so thank you.
But together with CDE, we thoroughly considered the public comment and made
additional edits based on these comments and prepared another draft for the
second 60-day public review window.
During the April 17th, 2020 meeting, the IQC review public comment received
during the second public window period, and then made additional edits and
revisions in preparation for today.
Next slide, please.
Given what I've just shared, I'd like to publicly acknowledge the work of
the following contributors.
First, the CFCC composed of content experts, including K-12 educators,
school and district administrators, and university professors.
The CFCC volunteered many hours in the development of the draft world
languages framework.
We are certainly grateful for their passion and dedication to providing
quality world languages education to the students of California.
I'd also like to thank the work of my IQC colleagues past and present, who
also volunteer countless hours to the front-end development process, which
truly a collaborative effort.
And as the slide indicates, I'd like to delve into some detail about
the public comment period.
The public comment period allows the public to review and review detailed
graphs of the framework graphs and are part of a large group of students
and are part of a larger effort to make this process as open as possible
to the public.
For example, as I said earlier, all meetings are open to the public and
the CDE established a dedicated email to receive public comment throughout
the entire process.
The first 60 day public comment and review period occurred from October 1st,
2019 through December 2nd, 2019.
During the public, during this particular comment, public comment period, we
received over 80 comments submitted via online survey, email, regular mail,
phone calls, and verbally during IQC and world language subject matter
committee meetings held in January of 2020.
During the January 2020 IQC meeting, we requested that the CDE staff
collaborate with the framework writers to ensure there was consistent voice
in all chapters, particularly chapter eight.
The second 60 day public review comment, public comment and review period
occurred from January 30th, 2020 through March 30th, 2020.
During this timeframe, we received 11 comments from 11 individuals and
organizations through email.
The CDE staff also submitted comments during this review period to help refine
the alignment between the world languages framework draft and the CFCC
recommendations and the world language framework guidelines, particularly to
ensure that the framework is comprehensible to a wide audience.
Several comments also suggested increased clarity of the guidance in the
framework.
Thank you.
And I now pass the presentation baton to the IQC world language subcommittee
chair, Alma Dele Arendt-Villal.
Thank you, Chair.
And you guys.
So this brings us all to today.
And we are so very happy that the edits, the public, the world languages subject
matter committee, and the instructional quality commission have all been
addressed and the version of the framework that is currently posted on the
world languages framework webpage, the world languages standards and the world
languages framework reflect 21st century world language education programs that
promote linguistic, global and intercultural competency for all learners
and ultimately led to some important pedagogical shifts that are represented
in the standards.
The world languages framework provides guidance for the implementation of the
world languages standards that the state board of education approved back in
January of 2019.
So the world languages framework is comprised of a total of 14 chapters and
two appendices.
Chapter one explains the vision of the world languages standards and discusses
the instructional shifts needed to fully implement the standards.
There's also a discussion of how the 2019 world language standards recognize and
leverage recent initiatives such as the California education for global economy,
global California 2030 and the state sealed by literacy, just to name a few.
Chapter two then goes into detail regarding the provision of access and
equity. However, specific teaching strategies aligned to this guidance are
also incorporated throughout the entire framework.
Chapter three suggests a variety of ways that educators may embrace and implement
after schools and districts to ensure that more California students have
pathways to learn a world language.
Chapter four describes how the 2019 California world languages standards
aligned to the American Council on the Teaching of Foreign Languages or ACETFL
standards.
Chapter five discusses best practices for implementing the world language
The chapter begins with an overview of universal design for learning, provides
reasons for using authentic materials and suggests technology tools and
resources that teachers can use to provide a high quality world languages
instruction.
Chapter six, seven and eight are all dedicated to each of the three strands of
the standards, the communication standards, the culture standards and the
connection standards.
These chapters include a robust series of figures, snapshots and vignettes that
illustrate how to implement the world language standards.
Then we go on to chapter nine, which explains how the global competence
domains relate to world languages instructions, describes the ranges and
phases of language proficiency and identify scaffolds to support language
learners to develop their language proficiency.
Chapter 10 describes appropriate use of formative, interim and summative
assessments with all students, including students with visible and non-visible
disabilities and students in need of differentiated support.
Chapter 11 identifies strategies for leadership and advocacy to ensure access
to world languages education for all students, kindergarten through grade 12.
Chapter 12 focuses on the ways that language differ and how those
differences impact teaching and learning.
Chapter 13 provides criteria for the evaluation and guidance to help students
education agencies regarding the adoption of instructional materials for
the instruction of world languages.
Chapter 14 is the glossary of all the terms that appear in both texts
throughout the framework.
Then there's our two appendices who are super helpful.
Appendix one contains numerous tables that stakeholders, which are teachers,
students, parents, administrators, and others interested in the progress of
world language learners may use for placement, articulation, and the
development of new language programs.
And then appendix two offers a substantial list of resources consulted
in the preparation of a framework that may be of interest to language education
scholars and world language educators.
Now we'll turn it over back to executive director Coates.
Thank you so much.
The design of this world languages framework is based on four principles and
beliefs generated by world languages, educators and leaders around the state
and approved by the instructional quality commission.
The principles guide student access to world languages.
Education highlight the value of developing multiculturalism and
multiliteracy as a key component in global competence and career readiness,
underscored the importance of high quality curricula that incorporate
culturally authentic materials and prioritize ongoing support for
professional learning opportunities for world languages educators.
The educators we talked to during the focus group meetings, during the standards
development process and during the framework development process have all
had a common message.
California is ready to expand opportunities for its unique and diverse
student population to acquire world languages, develop intercultural
competence and become global citizens.
And California educators will find that the world languages standards are aligned
with and support recent legislation and initiatives that champion these outcomes.
Naturally, these standards establish a path for students to become multilingual
and prepare to attain California's still of biliteracy.
The world language standards also provide guidance in light of two
significant pieces of legislation.
The charge of this legislation and a subsequent initiative, global California
2030 speak, learn, lead is for K-12 schools to support multilingualism for
California's unique and diverse student populations through access to world
language programs.
The passage of proposition 58 education for a global economy in 2016 initiated a
statewide effort to promote linguistic, global and intercultural competency among
California students.
The roadmap was designed to assist local educational agencies as they implement
California's 21st century college and career ready standards, curriculum,
instructional programs and assessments for English learners.
It is also intended to provide resources and information to students, parents and
community members about education and effective research based practices.
Pending state board education action today, we will begin the editing and
design of the world languages framework and additionally, we are scheduled to
conduct a state level K-8 instructional materials adoption process pending state
board of education action.
This brings us back to the action recommended before you today.
We would be happy to answer any questions that you may have.
Thank you very much.
It's exciting to have our first ever such framework.
We will now open the phone line for public comment queue and then we'll come
back for, while we're doing that, I'll ask member Eileen Strauss to give some
comments, but let's get the public comment queue going and then we'll get
Strauss to give some comments, but let's get the public comment slide up.
The very next one.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by
following the instructions on this slide.
While we're waiting for members to call in, I'll ask Eileen Strauss, who's been
our world languages liaison also, if she has any initial comments, and then we'll
ask if there are any clarifying questions before we take public comment and then
resume the board discussion.
Thank you, President Darlingham.
So let me just acknowledge that the world language framework development was
originally, the liaison was Dr.
Karen Valdez, who was on our board until last year.
And then I assumed as one of the liaisons to IQC along with member Rucker.
So I'm delighted to be the liaison to recommend, and I will make a motion at
the end of the discussion.
But I do want to highlight this was a really collaborative process.
It went really well.
I want to thank Alma as the liaison to CFCC and Jose as the chair of IQC.
All the work that was done, this was a long time in coming.
And I think to have a standards and a framework in one document is really, it's
time, it's been overdue and it's done in a really collaborative and quality way.
I do want to highlight some things that I think our presenters talked about, but I
think it's important that the board know as well.
So frameworks typically take a longer time than we think from the time we adopt
standards, then we do a framework when it goes out for all the public comments and
the edits, then it finally comes back to the board and then we get the materials,
which is for this one is also November twenty twenty one.
So for the field who is so anxious to use this and it's so rich with guidance, I
just want everyone to realize that we're not quite done yet, but we can start to
share this and help collaborate with with our leaders in the field.
Again, the the writers were incredibly responsive.
A couple of highlights.
It's aligned to the national standards.
I think that's really important to know that the connections, there's some figures
and snapshots and vignettes in the framework, which we put in our frameworks
now that really help train teachers.
So you can look at a little snapshot, a little vignette, you can practice what it
will look like for class and practice.
You can also teach administrators and leaders what it's going to look like when
they're working with their teachers to facilitate this.
Also, American Sign Language is in the framework, so I thought that would be
interesting to share as well.
And the equity and access is actually embedded throughout, but there's also some
explicit area where it's dedicated and also it's it's really addressing an asset
based approach of what all learners bring to the classroom and to the learning
setting, and I thought that was really important to share.
We also address English learners and students with disabilities.
So that's with a deeper understanding, which is important to understand what that
means for teachers with a diverse student population in their classroom and how to
address it. This was a true collaboration also across departments in CDE.
So I think we'll hear from the public comment in the board, but this is a
resource guidance document that we need to really enhance and use with the field
to make sure that the next generation of students get quality world language
experience. So with that, I just want to thank everyone for the work that they did
on it and thank Karen for her early liaison work and for all the people who
were part of it. I think it is going to be a quality document that will live for a
while to help guide our work.
So thank you with that.
I'll turn it back to President Darla Hammond and the public comment process.
And seeing no hands raised for clarification at this time, we'll begin
the public comment.
If you do we have any public comments?
Yes, we have two for public comment.
Speaker, you are now unmuted and your time starts now.
Good afternoon, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association
for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
We are in full support of the 2020 World Languages Framework.
The framework provides a blueprint for the implementation of the world
languages standards adopted by the board on January 2019.
Teachers will have guidance on implementing a high quality world
languages program for every student from kindergarten through 12th grade.
The framework is complemented by and supports other frameworks such as the
English Language Arts English Language Development Framework and supports
the California Common Core State Standards for English Language Arts
and Mathematics.
The adoption of the world languages standards in conjunction with the adoption
of the world languages framework, we believe represents the commitment of our
state to increase multiliteracy throughout California.
Let's provide our students with opportunities to learn more than one
language, increasing their intercultural appreciation and global competence.
Please approve and adopt the 2020 World Languages Framework.
Thank you.
Thank you, Speaker.
Next speaker, you are now unmuted.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hi, I am Nicole Nates.
I'm a program specialist for instructional technology and world languages in San
Juan Unified School District.
And I just want to also duplicate what the previous speaker said and what
everybody in this meeting has said and add my support for the adoption of this
world languages framework.
Having witnessed the work firsthand from the start of the standards development
process through most of the framework development process, I am beyond
overwhelmed with the quality of the writing that is going to support world
languages education for all of our learners and provide multiple pathways.
Thank you.
There are no more individuals for public comment.
All right.
Thank you.
Given that there's no other public comment, we'll now close the public hearing
for this item at 1230 p.m.
and commence with board discussion and action.
And I'll kick that off simply by saying how proud I am to be part of a state that
is so explicitly committed to a multilingual future for all of us in the
state and for all of our students.
So I think this is a wonderful step in that direction.
And is there any discussion from members of the board before we take a motion?
I am not seeing any hands raised.
So do I have a motion?
So I'll be glad to make a motion.
I move approval on adoption of the world language framework as unanimously proved
for IQC with the edits and any necessary revisions as it goes to formal publication.
And do we have a second?
I'd like to second that.
Did you catch that, Karen?
No.
Who second?
I think a couple of us did, but this is Aid, and I would like to second Eileen's motion.
Thank you very much.
And so we're going to have a roll call vote.
Karen, will you manage the roll call?
Yes.
Patricia?
Patricia Rucker?
You may be muted, Patricia.
Yes.
Thank you.
Brenna?
Brenna, you're muted.
Yes.
Thank you.
Jim?
Yes.
Ting?
Eileen?
Yes.
Linda?
Cynthia?
Yes.
Matt?
Aid?
Yes.
Kim?
It's unanimous.
And unanimous and enthusiastic.
So thank you, Shanine, for all this great work.
And you'll be pleased to know we're now going to take a 30 minute lunch break.
It is 1232.
I will see you back here at 102.
Please turn off your microphones and cameras during the break.
And then when you come back, turn them on again so that we will reestablish our quorum.
See you then.
So we need to reestablish our quorum.
So Karen, please take the role.
Okay.
Patricia Rucker?
Here.
Thank you.
Brenna?
Pangelinan?
Here.
Jim McQuillan?
E.
Tim Sung?
Here.
Eileen Strauss?
Linda Darling-Hammond?
Here.
Cynthia Glover-Woods?
Matt Navo?
Here.
Aid Rodriguez?
Kim Patio-Bronson?
Here.
All present.
All right.
So we are going to take up item five, the California Assessment of Student Performance
and Progress System and the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California.
This is an update on program activities.
We are now on a schedule that gets us finished after dinnertime.
So we're going to try to keep things moving.
And I'm going to ask Mao Vang, who is going to present this, to just keep going through
all the segments.
And if you have questions, please keep a notepad nearby and keep track of your questions so
that we can take them all at the end.
Okay?
Mao, please present the mega assessment item.
Okay.
Thank you.
Superintendent Thurman, President Darling-Hammond, and board members.
I'm Mao Vang, the Director of the Assessment Development and Administration Division
at the California Department of Education.
The item before you today is an information item.
Given that we have a few new State Board of Education members, I would like to start by
providing an overview of California's system of assessments.
I will also provide information about resources that are available for parents and guardians.
And then I will move into the assessment program updates.
I will finish with some time for questions.
So let's start with an overview of California's assessment system.
System of assessments, excuse me.
The Assessment Development and Administration Division manages a number of assessments for
the State of California.
At the forefront is the California Assessment of Student Performance and Progress, or CASP, system.
Which comprise of seven different assessments.
The Smarter Balanced Assessments for English Language Arts and Mathematics,
the California Science Test, or CASP, the California Alternate Assessments for English
Language Arts, Mathematics, and Science, and the California Spanish Assessment, or the CSA.
The CASP system was established in statute in 2013 and became effective on January 1,
2014.
The statute provides for the development and administration of assessments through the use
of technology where feasible.
All of our assessments are at various stages of development and transitioning to online
assessments.
The primary purpose of the CASP system is to assist teachers, administrators, students,
and parents to promote high-quality teaching and learning through the use of a variety of assessment
approaches and items.
So the implementation of CASP was significant in that it shifted the primary focus away
from accountability and toward promoting high-quality teaching and learning.
Our divisions work really place our assessments meaningfully within the teaching and learning
process.
So the starting point for transitioning all of California's state assessments was the adoption
of the Smarter Balanced Assessments for English Language Arts and Math from the Smarter Balanced
Assessment Consortium.
It is a state-led partnership whose goal is to provide leadership and resources to improve
teaching and learning.
And currently, there are 12 states, one territory, and the Bureau of Indian Education
that are members.
So since its inception, California has played a key leadership role in the governance of
the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium.
California has members on numerous advisory committees.
Our state has made a significant investment in this comprehensive system by ensuring it
is available and no cost to local educational agencies and their staff, and has financially
supported numerous professional learning opportunities in support of our assessment
system's purpose.
In order to leverage all of Smarter Balanced components, this means that it's accessing
a balanced and comprehensive system of assessments that include end-of-year tests,
referred to as summative assessments, interim assessments to be used as periodic check-ins
during the school year, and Tools for Teachers, which has replaced the digital library as the
formative assessment component of the Smarter Balanced Assessment System.
The digital library was decommissioned on May 28th of this year, and the Tools for Teachers
preview site was launched on June 16th.
Tools for Teachers consist of instructional, professional learning, and formative assessment
tools and resources.
Each of these elements work together throughout the year to support teaching and learning.
Our Smarter Balanced summative assessments are aligned to the Common Core State Standards
in English Language Arts and Mathematics for grades 3 through 8 and 11.
The English Language Arts or Literacy measures the domains of reading, writing, listening,
and research or inquiry.
Mathematics measures the domains of concepts and procedures, problem-solving, and data
analysis and communicating reasoning.
Moving on to the California Science Test, which is aligned with the California
Next Generation Science Standards for grades 5 through 8 and high school,
and provides models of high-quality items that reflect fidelity to the standards.
The first operational administration of the CAST, or California Science Test, was
conducted in the 2018-2019 school year.
The CAST measures the domains of life sciences, physical sciences, and earth and space
sciences.
The engineering, technology, and application of science performance expectations are
embedded within the three science domains being tested.
And the environmental principles and concepts are used as context for the assessment
items when appropriate.
The California Alternate Assessments are available for English Language Arts,
Mathematics, and Science.
And these California Alternate Assessments are aligned to the connectors and they are
linked to the same standards as the general assessments.
Sorry, I think I went a little too fast.
So our California Alternate Assessments provide students with developmentally appropriate
opportunities to demonstrate what they know and can do as it relates to adaptive grade
level content.
The California Alternate Assessments are designed for students with the most significant
cognitive disabilities and only students with an individualized education program that
designates the need for an alternate assessment can take them.
So unlike the California Alternate Assessments for English Language Arts and Mathematics,
the California Alternate Assessment for Science consists of four embedded performance tasks
which are administered shortly after science instruction throughout the school year.
And again, they're aligned to the same general standards as the general test through the
connectors or the alternate standards.
Next, we have the California Spanish Assessment.
It is an optional test used to measure a student's achievement in Spanish reading
language arts that is aligned with the Common Core State Standards in Espanol for students
in grades three through eight and high school.
This assessment measures three domains, reading, writing mechanics, and listening.
Another assessment program we have is the English Language Proficiency Assessments
for California or LPAC.
LPAC serves multiple purposes.
The initial LPAC is given to eligible students whose home language survey indicates a primary
language other than English to determine English proficiency and identify students as being
either an English learner or initial fluent English proficient.
This is done within 30 days of enrollment in a California public school.
Students will take the initial LPAC only once in their educational career.
The summative LPAC is given to students who have been identified as English learners
based on results from the initial LPAC or previously by the California English Language
Development Test and measures a student's progress toward English proficiency.
The results support decisions for students to be re-designated as fluent English proficient.
The English Language Proficiency Assessments for California is aligned with the 2012 California
English Language Development Standards and assess four domains, listening, speaking,
reading, and writing.
The summative LPAC transition to a computer-based assessment in spring of this year 2020.
The initial LPAC will transition to a computer-based assessment beginning on August 20, 2020.
So the alternate LPAC is like the other California alternate assessments in that it is for students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities and it's used for the same purposes as the
initial alternate LPAC and summative alternate LPAC for this population.
It is aligned to the 2012 California English Language Development Standards through the
English Language Development Connectors that are reduced in breadth, depth, and complexity
for students in kindergarten through grade 12.
And it will replace all locally determined alternate assessments for students with the
most significant cognitive disabilities who would normally take the summative LPAC
starting this year in an operational or census field test.
Each of the CASP and LPAC assessments are carefully designed to be accessible to all students.
Our comprehensive system of accessibility resources sets a national standard with such
resources as translation glossaries, text-to-speech, and tools such as calculators and periodic
tables that are accessible to students who are visually impaired.
These resources provide equal opportunity for all students to access
the assessments and demonstrate what they know and can do.
So in terms of the test takers, just a quick summary for English Language Arts and Math,
that's for grades, students in grades 3 through 8 and 11.
For the California Science Test, grades 5 and 8 and once in high school, that is grades 10,
grade 10, 11, or 12.
If the students cannot take the regular English Language Arts, Math, or Science and their
individual education program team indicates that they take an alternate assessment,
then they take the corresponding alternate assessments.
For the CSA or California Spanish Assessment, it's an optional test for grades 3 through 8
and high school.
And for the LPAC, whether it be the initial, summative, or alternate, it is given to
eligible students in kindergarten through grade 12.
So in these challenging times of distance learning and other challenges that parents
and guardians are facing with their children's education, I want to remind us that we do have
resources to support our parents and guardians in California.
In collaboration with the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium, the CDE, the California
Department of Education, has developed a website that is dedicated to helping families become
familiar with our assessments so they can better understand their children's score
and have easy access to family resources.
There are two starting Smarter websites, one for the CAST system and the other is for LPAC.
Currently, the assessments on these starting Smarter sites include the English Language Arts
and Math, the alternate assessments for the English Language Arts and Mathematics,
and the California Science Test and the California Spanish Assessment.
The California Alternate Assessment for Science will be available later this year.
And on the LPAC Starting Smarter website, we have included the initial and summative LPAC
and the alternate LPAC will be available this year.
So on these websites, we have samples, student score reports, and an explanation of the domains
of each assessment.
We also have sample test questions and links to the practice tests and other
no-cost parent and guardian friendly resources that support learning.
Both of these sites are available in English and Spanish.
Our division also supports the work of several other assessments,
including the Physical Fitness Test, the Grade 2 Diagnostic Assessments,
the High School Equivalency Test, the California High School Proficiency Exam,
and the National Assessment of Educational Progress.
Our division does have a lot going on.
So with that, I want to move on to the written item before you that provides updates on most
of our programs.
I will begin with the assessment program updates.
So over the last few months, our division has made critical changes to support the movement
to distance learning.
The following table is a summary of some of the events that took place.
So with testing paused in the Federal Waiver Security March,
there were a lot of questions from local educational agency staff about next steps.
In April, then, we hosted a cross-divisional webinar for all coordinators to discuss how the
Executive Orders and the Federal Waiver Impact Assessments, Accountability,
and the California System of Support, as well as the Local Control and Accountability Plan
Development Process.
Also in April, we worked with the Smarter Balance and our contractor Educational Testing Service
to make the interim assessments available to be administered remotely without the need
for a secure browser through June 30.
This option provided local educational agencies with the flexibility to incorporate the interim
assessments into distance learning.
Moving on to May, we identified assessment resources for supporting the Learning Acceleration
webpage, as well as pivoting very quickly to whole educator involvement activities
in a virtual workshop environment.
In June, we contributed to the development of the California Department of Education's
Stronger Together guidebook, and we also developed a webpage that provides answers to
questions that our division has received in response to the coronavirus pandemic.
We contributed to the implementation tool, Guidance on Diagnostic Informative Assessments,
with the leadership of our Board President Linda Darling-Hammond and Superintendent Thurman
that was released yesterday.
When the statewide testing was suspended on March 18, testing across the state had already
begun prior to that suspension.
The following table here represent content from Table 1 from the item.
When analyzing the summary data for our Smarter Balanced English Language Arts, Literacy,
and Mathematics, the California Science Test, and the California Spanish Assessment,
we can come to a conclusion that the numbers of students who completed testing prior to
the statewide suspension represent such a small portion of the anticipated testing population.
For reference, there were 1,956 local educational agencies in California who have students in
these grade levels that the tests assess at.
The number of local educational agencies that started testing also represented a small
portion of the total.
With the numbers so underrepresented of the testing population, that any reporting of
data would not have potential use in any meaningful way.
And these data is also from Table 1 following the same trend for the alternate assessments
for English Language Arts, Mathematics, and Science for the alternate assessments.
And then this table shows the summary data for the summative LPAC.
And it's considerably higher, yet still only a small portion of the total number of registered
students.
As we get the K through 12 or kindergarten through 12 writing tests scored throughout
the summer, the numbers at the end here, the number of students who completed testing
will increase.
As you're aware in grades K through 2, the writing test is still on paper.
So what about student score reports?
Student score reports and student level data files will be provided to
local educational agencies at the end of the month.
Only students that submitted a complete assessment will receive a score report.
So for the California Spanish assessment, due to the low numbers of participants for
each grade level, we will only provide the percent correct for the students.
For the California alternate assessment for science, due to the suspension of testing,
we were unable to conduct standard setting because it was the first year that was supposed
to be the first operational year.
So standard setting work was not completed and the development work of the first operational
assessment of the California alternate assessment for science has been delayed.
So we will not provide score reports for those students either.
We will provide instead preliminary indicators like we did when we had the 2018-19 field test
administration.
And there will be no public reporting and no federal reporting.
So moving on to another update of the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessment status.
Since 2015, the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments have been an integral part of
the CASP system of assessments designed to support teaching and learning for
English language arts and mathematics throughout the year.
The 2019-20 testing volumes for the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments was on track to
exceed the approximately 11.3 million administered during the 2018-19 school year.
As of March 18, approximately 7.9 million interim assessments had already been administered,
which exceeded the approximately 7.1 million the year before.
Between April 14 and June 11, while interim assessments were available for distance
learning, about 15,595 were administered remotely statewide.
So in June, the Smarter Balanced members voted to continue making this option available for
the 2020-2021 school year.
The interims will be available starting on August 20, 2020.
There are more than 160 interim assessments, and there are three types.
The Interim Comprehensive Assessments, which assess similar targets as the summative.
The Interim Assessment Blocks, which assess about one to eight targets.
And the Focus Interim Assessment Blocks, which assess about one to three targets.
They're smaller bundles.
So although these interim assessments are developed for grades three through eight and
high school, the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments can be administered to students
at any grade level, K through 12.
And the results from these assessments will be electronically available to educators
within 20 minutes of administration after a school or district coordinator creates the
student groups for the teachers to access in our California Educator Reporting System.
So another update I wanted to share with you is that the CDE will implement the January 2020.
I want to remind us that the State Board of Education approved a revised California Science
Test Blueprint in January of 2020.
And due to the stoppage of testing, the CDE has decided to delay the implementation of
the revised blueprint by one year and reuse the 2019-2020 test form with modifications
to the field test sets.
One reason for this is the California summative assessments were suspended in March, right,
and less than 27,000 students took the California Science Test.
So with this insufficient number of students responding to last year's field test questions,
we were unable to build a new test form that would
allow for the implementation of the revised blueprint.
And the revised blueprint will now be used to develop test forms for the 2021-22 administration
of the CAST.
And that was one way of us looking at some cost savings for the contract as well.
So another update is the California Assessment for Science.
The timeline for that is also updated.
I mentioned that the first operational administration and standard setting for the
California Alternate Assessment for Science has also been delayed for a year.
The first operational test now will begin on September 8, 2020.
Standard setting is scheduled for August 2021.
And if all things go as planned, the CDE will present recommended threshold scores for
approval at the November 2021 State Board of Education meeting.
Next, we have the update on summative LPAC.
So when the summative testing was suspended on March 18th, it has raised questions from
the field of whether or not students who were able to complete the summative will receive
their test results.
As a result, we will offer the electronic student score reports for students who completed
all of the summative testing.
The student score reports for students who completed all four domains in the spring of
2019-20.
And the student score reports will be available in two waves.
For grades 3 through 12 reports, it will be available sometime now in July.
And kindergarten through grade 2 reports will be available in late summer or early fall.
As I mentioned, once a local educational agency submit their answer books for scoring,
then we will combine all those scores and report them out.
For students who completed testing in 2019-20, their results from that summative LPAC can
be used to determine reclassification eligibility.
So for those students who did not complete testing in the spring, an optional fall summative
LPAC window will be open and available between August 20th and October 30th.
Recently through Senate Bill 98.
During this window, educators can administer the optional fall summative LPAC assessment
and use the results to meet the assessment of English language proficiency eligibility
for reclassification.
The optional fall summative LPAC is highly recommended for all English learner students
who have already met other criteria in 2019-20 except for that first criteria.
Students in grades 4 through 11 are highly encouraged to take this opportunity.
Another update about the initial LPAC is that for the initial LPAC administration,
the window just opened on July 1st and the administration will begin somewhat differently.
From July 1 through August 19th, LEAs have the option to continue to administer the paper
pencil version of the initial LPAC.
Alternatively, they can wait until August 20 to begin administering the assessment
as a computer-based initial LPAC.
This paper pencil option was set in place for the first six weeks of the administration
window to provide additional time for the California Department of Education and
Contractor ETS educational testing service to prepare for the optional fall
administration of the summative LPAC.
Following up with another update on the Tools for Teachers preview website, it is now available.
The rollout of the new Tools for Teachers website from Smarter Balanced,
which is the new formative assessment component of the Smarter Balanced assessment system,
did rollout, and in May we presented a demonstration of the key features of the
Tools for Teachers preview website.
Since then, Smarter Balanced launched the Tools for Teachers website,
and it is now available for all public school staff.
Tools for Teachers offer instructional and professional development resources aligned
to the Common Core State Standards for English Language Arts and Math.
So, for our 2020 Tools for Teachers status and training opportunities, we are offering
several opportunities for local educational agency staff to receive training on how to
use Tools for Teachers.
The day after the June 16 preview launch, the California Department of Education
hosted a live webinar to demonstrate the new website for California members
of the State Network of Educators.
On June 22, we hosted a webinar to provide a live demonstration of Tools for Teachers.
All of the approximately 296,000 local educational agency staff members who previously had
a digital library account were invited to attend this webinar.
Approximately 1,300 public school staff members attended.
A recording of this webinar and other Tools for Teachers resources are available on the
Tools for Teachers resource page on the CASP.org site and the ALPAC.org website.
So, on July 28, the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium will host a virtual
Train the Trainer workshop for California staff members only.
We will be training other California educators on the Tools for Teachers and the Formative
Assessments.
This workshop will prepare their staff to conduct local trainings to assist educators
in the use of the Tools for Teachers.
With the grand opening of Tools for Teachers planned for September 30, 2020, in conjunction
with the Smarter Balanced's 10-year anniversary.
We are planning to have a webinar in late September to offer another demonstration for
California educators focusing on the resources and features in the Tools for Teachers.
We will also offer Tools for Teachers sessions and presentations at CDE-sponsored conferences
and other events such as the California Assessment Conference that will be offered virtually
in October and the Interim Informative Assessment Training that will be offered in fall 2020.
This training is the Summer Institute Training that is being reconfigured to offer virtually.
So, in addition to the above trainings, the CDE will continue to offer sessions and presentations
throughout spring 2021.
We have regular updates in our assessment spotlight and will continue to send out periodic
emails to our coordinators, site administrators, and Tools for Teachers users.
So, with the understanding that Tools for Teachers contain excellent resources to support
English language arts and math instruction, California continues to develop similar resources
to support science instruction.
The California Department of Education has worked with the California science educators,
with a number of California science educators, to develop high quality formative assessment
resources that are aligned with the California next-generation science standards.
And we are very excited to announce that we are preparing resources to be added to the
Tools for Teachers website starting in the fall.
So, through the development of these formative assessment science instructional resources,
it included a project that we are working with the California Department of Education
to develop a process with quality criteria that ensures these assessments are aligned
with the California next-generation standards.
They have embedded instructional differentiations such as formative assessment strategies,
and equity and access considerations for all students that include embedded accessibility
strategies.
And in addition, these resources are authored in a multi-step collaboration process with
multiple peer reviews, vetting, and assistance provided by coaches.
Each science instructional resource contains these key features.
Focus on phenomena and opportunities for active learning such as hands-on exploration and
peer-to-peer collaboration.
And these resources also integrates learning standards such as science and engineering
practices and cross-cutting concepts and references common core state standards.
So, there are 39 instructional resources that are developed through these two virtual
workshops conducted in April and June.
And while these resources are developed for kinder through grade five, educators from
all grade bands participate in the development and ensure vertical articulation of the
resources.
And as I mentioned earlier, the CDE is working with the Smarter Balanced staff to arrange
for the inclusion of these resources on the Tools for Teachers website this fall.
We are constantly accepting applications for our trainings and educator opportunities.
To access these opportunities, you can navigate to the home page of the CASP.org and LPAC.org
pages and then select the training tab for upcoming training activities for the assessment
programs and then select the Get Involved tab for upcoming educator involvement opportunities
such as standard setting and item reviews.
And with that, I have our contact information available.
For each of the programs here, you may also sign up for our assessment spotlight by
following sending a blank link to subscribe-CAASPP at mlist.cde.ca.gov.
And we encourage you to follow us on Twitter with the handle at CDE assessments.
And with that, I will thank you all for allowing me to share our assessment program updates
with you.
I would like to take this time for any questions if you have them.
Thank you.
Well, what I'm going to ask us to do then, thank you so much, Miles, very helpful to
hear what's happening in the last few months, especially.
I'm going to ask us to open up the queue for public comment.
And then while we're doing that, I'll ask for some clarifying questions.
You can see that members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by
following the instructions on the posted slide there.
And while we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I'll first ask Ting Sun
as one of our assessment liaisons if she has any initial comments.
And I'll ask board members if they have any clarifying questions before we go to public
comments.
Okay, great.
Thank you, Madam President.
So a couple of things.
First of all, thank you, Mal, and your team for continuing the good work during these
very trying times.
And I just wanted to emphasize a couple of things in Mal's presentation.
One, around the purpose of assessments under CASP.
That is to promote high quality teaching and learning.
So what we've been trying to do is to decouple the assessment from accountability at varying
degrees of success, right?
And then coupling that with using assessments as a tool for teaching and learning.
And so you'll have heard a myriad of tools that this division has put together for educators
to be able to do that.
And I know that we have been all very disappointed that we were not able to conduct the summative
assessments this year, and no doubt it's a setback for us in our work with assessments
and looking at our equity work and making sure that we are making progress and assessing
where we are with students who have been left behind.
So but, you know, given that we don't have the summative assessments, what it does allow
us to do in the fall, instead of focusing on what the students did last year, right,
now we can really pivot and focus this fall on how students are coming into our system
this year.
So I think pivoting from our usual focus and fall on how students performed in the
summative assessments to really focusing on interim assessments, gathering information
on where students are coming into schooling this year, and being able to then start
addressing any kind of learning loss from the get go.
We had talked about the continuity of learning plan, and I don't see how we can address
continuity of learning without first understanding where the students are who come into this
fall and where they are performing.
So I would just highly encourage us to focus on those interim assessments.
The guidelines that Mal had talked about that was just released that was led by President
Darling Hammond and the work of Superintendent Thurmond, I think is very comprehensive in
the types of assessment, the interim assessments that are out there and how they can be used,
and certainly there are lots of tools, and they're still continuing to build more tools
to support educators in that.
So thank you, and I'm our other assessment liaison, so I'm just going to add a couple
points to the ones that Ting has already brought out.
One key thing is that the new interim tools that Smarter Balanced has developed, which
allow you to go into a much deeper dive around specific topic areas, are also linked to
tools for teachers around instruction and curriculum to then address the needs that
may be highlighted by those assessments.
So we're bringing them much closer together with the tools for teaching themselves
and connecting those.
There are other tools that are offered by Smarter Balanced, and under Ting's leadership,
we're exploring some of those to see what else can be made available to the field to help
us move kids along in a continuum.
In addition to those, the other diagnostic assessments that the state approved originally
for second grade testing, but most of them have a long continuum of being able to assess kids
along a scale beyond grade level from wherever they happen to be across multiple grade levels,
and then use that regularly to see growth and progress are part of the guidance that
we just talked about.
That's going to be really important because every teacher knows that when you get a
heterogeneous classroom, the kids in that classroom are not all functioning at the same
skill and grade level, and we want to figure out where they really are along the learning
progressions and then really help them grow and monitor that growth.
For districts that had some of those diagnostic tools in place, and many districts do, they use
the DRA, or they use Acuity, or they use iReady, or they use NAP, or something else,
they do have a way from last spring to see where kids are in the fall when they come in,
and then to track their progress over the year.
We really want to emphasize how districts can use the most productive tools, and all of those also
have links to curriculum and instructional materials, to figure out where kids are starting
and then to really accelerate their progress over the course of the year.
So thanks so much, Mal, for all of your great work on that.
Are there any clarifying questions from the board before we go to public comment?
I'm not seeing any hands raised in the hand raising place, so we'll go to public comment
at this point, and we want to encourage everyone who makes comments to please state your name and
affiliation for the record. Remember to turn down the volume of your computer if you're following
the live feed, and you'll be limited to one minute each. Are there public comments?
We have one caller in the queue for public comment.
Great.
Hi, my name is Jessica Ibarra. I am a parent of a student that attends a public school in California.
I just had a question because my daughter has been struggling to reclassify
out of ELD. She's now entering high school, and we kind of had, she's met all the criteria
except her summative test, and she was only a point away, so I'm not sure exactly how
we can push her past that threshold and any advice for that.
And that's actually a question we can return to Mal when she comes back to the podium.
Are there any other public comments?
Hearing no other public comments.
We have two other callers that have not yet entered the queue.
Okay.
Callers, if you can please press star six and one when prompted.
Hello, caller, would you like to make a comment on this item?
No, thank you.
Okay, and that concludes public comment.
Okay, and I want to open then the ground for board discussion,
and be sure you raise your hand in the participant panel.
I do want to also ask if Mal is still available to us.
If you want to say anything about fall testing on the English learner progress assessment.
For the parent who called in, if your child finished or completed testing on the English
language proficiency assessments for California, the LPAC last spring, you could use those scores
to see if she's meeting that criteria one of having the LPAC of level four
for reclassification purposes.
We have not sent those score reports out.
So you need to determine whether she completed testing or not,
and you'll have to probably consult with her school that she took it at.
Once you have that information, if she meets that criteria,
she's a perfect candidate for what we were talking about.
If she meets the level four for reclassification purposes, she can be reclassified.
If she did not meet it, or she did not complete the test,
and she has like one or two domains left, or even if she didn't start at all last spring
because of the school closures, she has an opportunity to take it this fall.
As of August 20th, we will make it available for all school districts
to be able to give it to students like your child who are on the cusp of
being able to be reclassified.
So those are some of the things you could think about and maybe talk to her former school
as well as her new school to make that happen.
Thank you very much.
Any board discussion, comments, or questions about this item?
I'm not hearing any, and this is not an action item.
It's just an information item.
Linda, Eileen has her hand up.
Eileen has her hand up now, yes.
Member Strauss.
Thank you.
I just wanted to make a comment to follow up on Member Sung's liaison report
because I think we're all really worried about our students coming back this fall
in whatever format they come into and knowing where they are and how we begin to connect
and work with them.
And I just think through Smarter Balanced and through CDE, we've worked really hard
to try to provide resources, not just summative, but formative.
And I think the interviews in the past have been quite helpful in helping teachers start
to align their practices and to check in and see where their kids are.
So I just think we want to make sure we reach out to districts and counties as people think
about opening and to highlight some of the resources that Smarter Balanced will offer
with the Tools for Teachers.
And I just appreciate Member Sung's comment that this is about tools for teaching and learning
and that we need to remember that that's what this is about.
And I think things are so different now than they were six months ago and will be going forward.
And so I think as students come back this fall, we need to remember that we have a lot
of tools together that are available, but we got to connect to our students to look
at how we can meet them where they are and help them progress.
Thank you.
That's great.
And seeing no other discussion, then we will conclude this information item.
Thank you very much, Mal, both for the clear rendering of the system and where we are
and for all the work that you've done to get us here.
Thank you.
And we're going to move to item six, which is the School Accountability Report Card,
approval of the template for the 2019-20 School Accountability Report.
The CDE recommends that we approve the proposed
SARC template for the 2019-20 school year.
And the item will be presented by Cindy Kazanis from the CDE.
So Cindy, please begin.
Good afternoon, Cindy Kazanis, Director of the Analysis,
Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division.
There we go.
And this item, as you mentioned, President Darling-Hammond,
is an annual item that the board takes action on, the approval of the SARC template.
And so our recommendation is that you approve the proposed
SARC template for the 2019-20 school year.
Did you want to say anything else about that?
This item is normally on consent.
There's not really a lot of additions this year.
If anything, with the prior board item that you just heard, our update on assessments,
we've had to remove several items that would normally be reported on because we do not have
any data for our assessments that are required to be part of the SARC.
The other thing I would note is that our suspension tables, so discipline records,
we are recommending that that be separated from the discipline tables from prior years because
we will have a truncated, we anticipate that we will have a truncated set of data
in that we will only have discipline records between July and March or end of February of 2020.
And so it's not appropriate to compare those incident reports from prior years to
this past year that we just finished since students were not physically in the classroom
for a large part of the end of the school year.
Thanks. I know people are wondering what kind of data they will be able to see, so that's very
helpful. And we're also in the process of doing some work to think about how the SARC will evolve
over time. So I wonder if you could say a little bit about that.
Sure.
For people's reference.
So I mentioned this briefly in item two because the legislature and the governor just signed into
law SB 98, which provides some additional funding. It piggybacks on a budget item from last year,
which provides $350,000 to align the SARC with the LCAP e-template and what's on the dashboard.
And so we are spending this fall and actually this summer working with our contractor,
which is San Joaquin County Office of Education to redo really the SARC. It's one of our oldest
applications that we do in accountability to make it something that is more aligned with what you
see in a current data system. It's a very old data system. So I think if anything,
from the field's perspective and on the data input side, administrative side, they'll see
something that's a little bit more user friendly. And our hope is with this additional funding
that's in the current year budget, we'll be able to even put something out on the template side
that is much more 21st century as opposed to 1990s version of what you're currently seeing
in the template that you'd be adopting today. And I think the other thing that you were really
excited about, my recollection was when we spoke about this a couple of weeks ago, was that
as opposed to when the SARC template first rolled out and we didn't have a lot of usage by
districts that were using third party contractors, we do have over 75% of our districts using
the template that the CDE pre-populates. And we do pre-populate over two-thirds of that document.
And so we're really happy that it has wide usage out there and that we're saving districts
money by providing this template and the pre-populated data to them. And I'm still
excited about that. So thank you. Okay, great. We will see if there's any public comment and
open the phone line for public comment. It's displayed. Any members who wish to provide
comment can do so by following the instructions on that slide. And while we're waiting to see if
we have any public comment, I want to ask Eileen Strauss as one of our accountability liaisons,
if she has any initial comments. Oh, let me just make a comment. And I appreciate Cindy
helping us understand where we're going and what the governor's budget will do to help us.
But we've been talking for a long time about trying to get all these required reports that
districts have to complete connected and integrated and pre-populated whenever possible.
If you've ever been a district leader who's worked on these things, there's all these different
reports. And so I feel like we're starting to move forward on that and trying to make a connection
so that the reports, when they overlap, we don't have to sit there and input all the different
pieces again. So I'll be excited to look at the process going forward that the budget is helping
us do. I know Subaru and I, who are both liaisons to accountability, really support the integration
and connection of all the items and the pre-population whenever possible. So after
the public comment, I'll have a recommendation. Thank you. Okay. And are there any other clarifying
questions? I don't see any. So we'll see if there is any public comment. There are no speakers for
public comment. All right. So given that there's no public comment, we'll open for board discussion
and then for a motion. Is there any further discussion of this item? I'm seeing none.
Sorry, I didn't get my hand up. But I just wanted to flag one thing, and this is more for future
reference, as sort of the conversation comes up about both how to pre-populate, which I think
obviously has incredible efficiency opportunities, but also just to begin planting this idea that
where we sometimes have some distinctions, for example, I was just thinking about the
the curriculum, the conversation about
TK versus K. And there are a couple places within the attachment on pages 13 and 14 where there's
the potential for disaggregating the data to actually be able to look at class sizes and
distribution of class sizes and provide data that can help school districts look at what they're
doing at the early years of instruction and whether they're actually offering different
models for TK versus K. So this isn't for today, but it's more a preview of things to come,
especially as we're thinking about the potential for boilerplates where it can be automatically
uploaded. And if we can build that into the system, I think we'll be a step ahead rather
than needing to do it after the fact. Can I respond to that? Sure, please. So I
think it's important to note that transitional kindergarten is not considered a grade for
purposes of reporting. It's considered a program. And so the SARC is very strict on what we can
add. And actually, we haven't had anything added to the SARC since 2008. So it's really something
that the legislature has driven. It was actually part of the original Prop 98 over 30 years
ago. So if there is an interest from the board to head in this direction or to add pieces,
it may actually be a function of the legislature to put that into this document. Whereas,
as opposed to the e-template or the dashboard, you have a lot more authority and control over
what goes in those reporting systems as opposed to the SARC. And that's why it is the way it is,
very clunky, because we are bound by legislation on what goes in here. So we have a very structured
model on this piece. Whereas, compared to the dashboard, I think there's a little bit more
freedom there. Great. That's helpful to know. And it may be something that we want to evaluate
and make some recommendations about. Is there any other discussion of the SARC?
I'm not seeing any other hands raised in the participant queue.
So I'll make a recommendation that the state board approve the proposed
SARC template for the 19-20 school year. And do we have a second?
I'll second that. Thank you very much.
Now I think we need to do a roll call vote. So Karen, can you facilitate that?
Okay. Yes. Linda?
Yes. Cynthia?
Yes. Jim?
Yes. Matt?
Yes. That was Matt, actually, Patricia. I didn't call you yet.
Okay. That's funny. Okay. Brenna?
Yes. He did not respond. Kim?
Yes. For Kim, not Matt. Yes, I understand that. I did.
Yes. Patricia?
Yes. Eileen?
Eileen? Yes.
And Ting? Yes.
Okay. I'm back.
You're back. Yes.
You're yes. Okay. Thank you, Matt. Okay. It's unanimous.
All right. Thank you very much. And thank you, Cindy.
And now we're going to put the public comment slide back up to prepare for the consent items.
And you will get a 10-minute break to give time for callers to get into the queue for
providing public comment on our waiver consent calendar. And then following that break, we'll
take up our calendar, which includes waiver items W1 through 15. And please, if you want
to comment on this, members of the public, use the instructions that are shown on the screen.
Board members, please turn off your microphones and your cameras.
And we will reconvene at, let's say, 2.15. That's a nine-minute break. See you then.
Are we live?
Okay. Linda, we're live.
Okay. Is everyone reassembled? Do you need to reestablish the quorum? Yes, please do.
Yes. Okay. Hi.
Okay. Linda Darling-Hammond. Here. Cynthia Glover-Woods.
Here. Jim McQuillan.
Here. Matt Navo.
Here. Frena Pangelinan.
Here. Kim Patio-Brownson.
Here. Ida Rodriguez.
Here. Patricia Rucker.
Here. Eileen Strauss.
Eileen, you're muted. Eileen. All right. Ting Sung.
Here. Okay. We got a quorum. We can go.
Okay. So, we'll now open up the phone line for the public comment queue. Members of the public wishing to provide comment, please identify yourself and your affiliation for the record and the waiver item and the district name to which you are speaking.
Remember to turn down the speaker volume on your computers if you're following the live feed and speakers will be limited to one minute each.
Is there any public comment?
We have public comment.
Please state your name for the record. The waiver number and-
Alan Garde.
Your time starts now.
Thanks. Hi. My name is Alan Garde, Assistant Superintendent of Business for the Hayward Unified School District. I appreciate the State Board of Education's time in considering waiver W13 for our Hayward community.
I fully support the waiver based on the following two reasons. One is it's critical for our community. There have been a substantial amount of our schools built in the 1950s. With our latest facilities master plan, there's a significant amount of investments needed to bring our schools up to par.
And this was reiterated with our community's overwhelming approval of our 2018 bond measure to implement critical fire alarm, roof replacement and safety projects across our 31 schools and also regarding the legislative need for the waiver.
This legislation is based on the law from 1878, which does not consider the size of safety, energy efficiency, or program bank needs of our young learners today. And so it's also, oh, sorry. Thank you.
Muted.
Any other public comment?
We have another public comment.
Caller, please state your name for the record.
Hello. Hi, caller. Please state your name for the record, your affiliation and which item you're speaking to in the district.
Unmuted.
Hello, caller. Would you like to make public comment?
Yes.
Please state your name for the record.
Lorraine Richards.
Your time starts now.
My name is Lorraine Richards. I represent California Teachers Association. As highlighted in our letters on items 13 and 15, CTA continues to be concerned with the funding determinations for non classroom based charters at 100% as well.
Please call back at the appropriate item.
The next time we dig it up.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name.
And any affiliation? Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Michael Jubin. I represent California Teachers Association.
I'm speaking on letters that we turned in for items of consent, items 12 and 14.
CTA continues to be concerned with the funding.
Please call back at the appropriate time. We're not taking up these items at this moment.
Let's clarify that we're only taking up the waiver, the waiver items. I think that's the confusion, right?
For those who are in the queue, this is for the waiver items.
We have no caller at this time.
Okay.
I think people are already queued up for the next part of our agenda. So given that there's no other public comment, I'll now ask for a motion on waivers 1 through 15.
I'll motion.
Thank you, member Navo. Do I have a second?
I will second.
Thank you, member Rucker. We'll now hold a roll call vote. Karen, can you please call the roll? Sure.
Patricia?
Yes.
Brenna?
Jim?
Yes.
Ting?
Eileen?
Yes.
Linda?
Cynthia?
Yes.
Matt?
Aide?
Yes.
Kim?
It's unanimous.
Okay. Very good. Now we're going to allow the callers to get into the queue for providing public comment for the regular items on the proposed consent, which we know we have a few people to comment on.
And we're instructed here to take a five minute break so that people can get into the queue. I think they're already in the queue. So Karen, do we still want to take that break?
Sounds like we don't need to because people are already queued up.
I think they are. Yes. So let's just keep moving. We're almost back to our time schedule. So let's keep moving.
And please ask any callers to identify themselves by name and affiliation as they respond to items eight through 15.
Hello. Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello. My name is Michael Juba, and I represent the California Teachers Association.
As highlighted on the letters that we sent regarding items of consent, items 12 and 14,
CTA continues to be concerned with the funding determination for non-classroom-based charters at 100%,
as well as the process in which the funding determinations are happening.
Furthermore, we believe that the state is asking the members of SBE to provide public oversight on these funding determinations
in a manner that's impossible given the limited amount of information on the item.
The funding determination forms and budgets for each of the NCBs should be provided when the agenda is posted for public consumption.
So in closing, CTA opposes the CDE's recommendation for the 100% funding determination for the non-classroom-based charters listed on this item.
CTA believes that the CDE must share the funding determination forms and budgets to help ensure that another A3 scandal does not occur. Thank you.
Thank you.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
This is
Hello, caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
This is Claire Crawford within the public interest. Your time starts now.
Yes, thank you. I am speaking in opposition to items 12 and 14, and specifically the non-classroom-based funding determinations for Trivium charter schools, as well as for Heartwood Charter.
In both cases, these schools have drastic disparities in their enrollment.
For Trivium, with 750 students across three schools, they enroll zero foster youth, only four English learners, and only two homeless students.
Similar numbers for Heartwood Charter School. Heartwood Charter School also continues to have an illegal practice of requiring a phone interview before enrollment.
They are also not in compliance with the posting requirements of SB 75, and it appears that their enrollment practices are in discouraging enrollment of students with disabilities.
They only have two students with disabilities, zero English learners, so similar problems at both of those schools.
Time.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
My name is John Lupo, and I want to comment on item number 16.
I support the petition to establish the Pinecrest Expedition Academy.
Caller, that's the, we are not taking up that item at this time. Please call back at the appropriate time.
We are on items 8 through 15.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation and the item to which you're speaking to. Your time starts now.
I support the petition to establish.
Caller, would you like to make a public comment on any of the consent items?
These are items 8 through 15.
We have no additional public comment at this time.
All right.
Given that there's no further public comment, I'll ask for a motion on consent for items 8 through 15.
I'll move.
Okay, we have a motion from member Rucker. Do I have a second? I'll second.
All right, we'll take a second from member Navo, and is there any further discussion?
All right, we'll take a roll call vote. Karen, please call the roll.
Okay, Linda?
Yes.
Cynthia?
Jim?
Yes.
Matt?
Brenna?
Yes.
Kim?
Eileen?
Yes.
Ting?
Okay, unanimous.
All right.
At this point, we're going to proceed to get ready for two public hearings for items 16 and 17.
We will take, because these may be long items, we will take a short break now.
It is 2.27. Let's come back at about
2.35.
And we'll ask you to please turn off your microphones and your cameras and do not leave the room.
I will see you back in a few minutes. Get yourselves ready. This will be a longer spell.
All right, we are reassembled. Are we live?
Give us a minute here, Linda. We'll make sure.
Okay. Okay.
Yes. Okay. We're live.
Okay. Agenda item 16 is a public hearing regarding petition for the establishment of a charter
school under the oversight of the State Board of Education, consideration of Pinecrest Expedition
Academy, which was denied by the Twain Heart School District and the Tulum County Superintendent
Schools. The CDE recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the request
to establish Pinecrest Expedition Academy, a TKK through grade eight charter school,
and this item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of the CDE.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond, board members, and welcome to the newly appointed
board members. Before we get started on the Pinecrest appeal item, because we have three
new board members joining us for the first time, I wanted to do a quick overview of the charter
school process, authorization process, and appeals process to the State Board before we get started.
Okay. So I'm going to go over the authorization process, and I want to be clear that this is the
authorization process that was used for the five appeals before the State Board during this meeting
pre-AB 1505. So I know July 1, some new laws went into effect, but we are using the pre-AB 1505
criteria for review and renewal and appeals. So that's what we're going to go over today.
Rest assured you all will be getting a workshop or a review of the new process in the coming months,
but for today it's just pre-AB 1505. So we're going to talk about appeals to the State Board,
the types of appeals that we receive, a quick little summary of what the State Board currently
has as you're off to price schools, and the role of CDE in the charter schools division.
So we have two types of appeals that come to the State Board. We have establishment appeals,
which is a new school that was denied at the local level and has come to the State Board,
and then renewal schools. So schools that were up for renewal denied at the local level and have
come to the State Board for authorization, and then revocations of charter schools that happen
at the local level and are appealed to the State Board. When petitions come to the State Board and
if the charter school division finds that the recommendation will be to deny, that can only
happen with written factual findings. Those findings include whether the charter school
presents an unsound educational program, the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to
successfully implement the program, the petition does not contain the required numbers of signatures,
the petition does not contain an affirmation of specified assurances, and the petition does
not contain reasonably comprehensive description of the 15 required elements of a charter petition.
So those are the findings that we must find and the Board must find in order to deny a charter
school at this level. For renewals, if renewals are granted by the authorizers for a period not
to exceed five years, the Board does consider increases in pupil academic achievement for all
groups of pupils served by the charter school as the most important factor. The State Board does
also consider past performance of the school's academics, their finances, their operations,
which also includes their governance, and future plans for improvement. Charter schools authorized
by the State Board are required to submit a renewal petition to the local authority that
originally denied the charter. So academic renewal criteria under Ed Code 47607, as I said, this is
pre-1505, this has since changed, but before, and it's kind of an odd thing because some of
this is way out of date, as you will see. Academic renewal criteria before, schools needed to meet at
least one of the four criteria, which you can see the first three are, were based on the API, which
has not been in existence for quite some time. So because of that suspension of the API and that we
no longer use that, those first three renewal requirements or criteria are no longer
applicable. However, the fourth one is what we are currently using and is what we used for the
renewal charters that are before you tomorrow, and that is the entity that granted the charter
determines that the academic performance of the charter school is at least equal to the academic
performance of the public schools that the charter school students would otherwise have
been required to attend, as well as the academic performance of the schools in the school district
in which the charter school is located, taking into account the composition of the student
population that is served at the charter school. So when we look at renewals under the pre-1505
criteria, we are looking at comparable school performance across the district where the
charter school is located compared to the charter school. And that academic renewal criteria is
really the threshold. So you must meet that academic renewal criteria in order to be considered
for renewal and approval, but it's not the only thing that we look at.
Also, we can look at alternative measures. Since the API, as I said, is old criteria and it hasn't
been calculated for many years, Ed Code 52052F allows for alternative measures to show increases
in pupil academic achievement. And there are listed there some of the types of alternative
measures we look at, which graduation rates. We now look at dashboard results, dropout rates,
internal benchmark data from the charter schools themselves, suspension expulsion rates,
those types of data. The appeal timelines, petitioners submit to the local district for
review and approval. If they're denied, they can elect to appeal to the County Board of Education
within 180 days. If denied by the county, petitioner can elect to appeal to the state board.
Appeals must be received by the state board no later than 180 calendar days after the denial by
the county. State board has 120 days to act on the appeal and the state board conducts a de novo
review, which means a new review, a brand new review. We do obviously take into account the
findings from the local district and we take into account responses from the charter school,
but the Department of Ed Charter School Division does do an independent analysis of the petition.
And as I mentioned earlier, written factual findings are required for the denial of the petition.
So currently, so this, we're just brand new into July and this slide is a little off because we've
had a few charter schools close, state board authorized charter schools. So I'm going to
correct this slide just verbally and say that we currently have 25 state board of education
authorized charter schools. We have three charter school division consultants who provide ongoing
technical assistance and support and site visits to the state board authorized charter schools.
We have one statewide benefit charter which includes nine sites and we have seven all
charter districts which includes a total of 18 schools and those are authorized by the state
board of Ed with oversight conducted by county offices of education. The role of the department,
CDE charter schools division as staff to the state board thoroughly review and analyze all
the appeal documents including the educational program, academic performance, fiscal viability,
and prior history. Appeals first are presented to the advisory commission on charter schools
who hears all of the appeals in a very similar manner into which you do and provide a recommendation
to you, the board, for each of the appeals they hear and then we present them to the state board
for action. The charter schools division provides oversight to charters approved by the state board
and then we do that through monthly calls, annual site visits, review of all the fiscal reports that
are required to be submitted annually, technical assistance, and then we also provide the following
annual memos to the state board on their state board approved charters, an annual review
of each school's academic performance, and an annual review of each school's fiscal viability.
So that is a quick overview for board members.
Now I'm going to go to item 16. Are there any questions about the overview?
No, but thank you for that. Okay, great. Okay, so item 16 is petition, it's a petition for the
establishment of Pine Crest Expedition Academy. They are seeking authorization for from the state
board to establish a transitional TK through grade eight charter school within the boundaries of the
Twain Hart School District. The petitioner submitted their petition previously to the Twain
Hart School District on November 20th and were denied 2019. They then chose to move to the
Tuolumne County Board of Education on February 3rd, where they were also denied and they appealed
to the state e-mail address. The petitioner submitted their petition previously to the
state board and we received their appeal on February 20th, 2020.
The CDE recommends that the state board hold their public hearing to deny the request to establish
Pine Crest Academy a TK through grade eight charter school under the oversight of the SBE.
As I stated in the overview, this did go to the advisory commission on charter schools
in June. They met and they heard the appeal and the ACCS moved the CDE
recommendation to deny the request to establish the Pine Crest Academy petition by a vote of eight to one.
The CDE's, our basis for recommendation is the petition does not present a sound educational
program. The petitioner is demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the intended program
and the petition does not provide a reasonably comprehensive description of all required 15
charter elements. A little background on the school and what their mission and vision are,
it is a rural area and they do plan to, their plan is to do some
expedition type program from their school. They want to inspire a diverse group of learners to
achieve academic excellence while developing a strong sense of character and community.
They intend to open with 52 students in TK through grade eight and grow to serve 65 students in TK
through grade eight by 2024-25. They plan to, their intention is to offer a site-based
and independent study program.
A little more detail in our findings, unsound educational program. The petitioner is
intending to offer the following, two multi-grade classrooms for 52 pupils, TK through eight.
The petition does not describe how instruction will take place with the anticipated gaps in
learning, age, and instructional approaches based on the target student population. They do plan on
their independent study program, will have a home study program component as a choice for families,
but the petition did not give a comprehensive description of how that model will include,
including in pupil enrollment numbers, how they plan to implement their instructional
model or how all pupils will be adequately served. Additionally, the petition does not
sufficiently describe how and when English learners will receive targeted English language
development instruction. I would say this petition was very weak in details. The petitioners have very
little education experience in terms of their petition, the petitioners and the board that
they have put together. Very few have education experience and it shows in the lack of detail
and description of the program implementation. They intended to open this August. Obviously,
that's up in the air. SB 98 allows new schools to put off their opening date for a year, so that's
something that can be considered, but we did have a lot of concerns regarding their ability
to recruit staff, create a high-quality instructional program, and administer two
separate educational programs really within their school, the home study option and the site-based
classroom option, which really doesn't, our concerns are not alleviated by putting off opening a year.
Inability to implement in terms of their budgeting. Obviously, we've had COVID-19 has
impacted school budgets and charter school budgets. There was a large variation between
the governor's proposed budget and the proposed May revision, and now we have an agreement that
includes deferrals for 2021. That is definitely something that will affect charter schools,
and it's something that they will have to consider if approved. They already have a burden of
fronting cash and maintaining cash flow just on the regular with this particular school, so
add deferrals to that, and it can be really detrimental.
Our original budget that they submitted to us with their petition is not viable. As you can
see here, they have negative ending fund balances for the first three years of operation with no
reserves at all. I think it goes back to the lack of experience within the petitioners
that they, in the budget that they did give us for revenue and expenditures,
they overstated by quite a bit their LCFF revenue and the funds they would get from the lottery,
and they understated what their expenditures would be, which really leads us to not be confident
that they would be able to implement their program. The petition does state that non-certificated
full-time staff shall participate in CalPERS and federal social security, although the petition
and the budget did not project any expenditures for CalPERS, and they did not project any startup
funds. I think their intention is to apply for the Charter School Revolving Loan Fund in 2021,
if obviously those dates are a little in flux right now. They also had very several deficiencies
in the charter elements in terms of reasonably comprehensive descriptions. Description of the
educational program, as I've said before, it was very a weak description, insufficient description
of the multi-grade instructional program, not a strong description of how English learners
will be educated. They did not include a framework for instructional design, especially with the fact
that they're having two separate types of programs within their school, and then also, as I said,
the English language development instruction was not sufficient. Measurable pupil outcomes,
they do plan to reside within the Twain Hart School District, which is only comprised of 257
students, 58% of which identify as socioeconomically disadvantaged. However, their petition does not
outline pupil outcomes for this group or for any groups of peoples. Charter elements 5, 10, and 14,
employee qualifications. The petition does not describe general specifications and qualifications
for non-certificated and certificated employees. Their suspension and expulsion procedures were
weak, and the dispute resolution procedures does not include all the necessary language for those
elements. The CDE recommends that the State Board deny the petition to establish Pinecrest
Academy, as the petition does not provide a sound educational program. The petitioner is
demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the intended program, and the petition does not
provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all required elements. Okay, thank you very much,
Stephanie. At this time, I'll open the public hearing at 2.54 p.m. First, we'll hear from the
petitioners. The petitioners will have 12 minutes. Then we will note that we're allocating an
additional two minutes to each side because of technological delay. Then we'll hear from the
district and the county that are opposing the petition. Together, they will also have a total
of 12 minutes. After the presentations from both sides, there will be an opportunity for public
comment from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each. So we'll
invite the petitioners to the podium at this time, or to their Zoom location.
Thank you very much for the opportunity to speak with you today. My name is Heidi Lupo,
and I am the lead petitioner for the Pinecrest Expedition Academy. My screen should be sharing
at this time. Can someone confirm that maybe it is? Okay. The picture you see on the cover is a
picture of the Pinecrest area from last winter under substantial snow, which is indicative of
where Pinecrest is and some of the difficulties that we face by our location. I've shown on this
next slide some of the driving distances from the Pinecrest area to more urbanized locations in
California, which you may be more familiar with. As a general rule, Pinecrest is at least 25 to 30
miles from other more populated areas. So you may be asking yourself, why do we need a school in
Pinecrest? Why are there even people there? Pinecrest is a very popular tourism destination on
Upper 108, our highway. And because of that, we see a large influx of visitors, both in the
summer and wintertime, and have a substantial amount of businesses and high tax-based homes
in our area. Our community provides a great deal of support to Tuolumne County and our $240 million
tourism industry. The realities of our location bring into account that our proximity matters.
There's a significant distance from the Pinecrest area to other schools, such as the
Twinhart School District. It's at least 20 miles from all areas, and for some of us, even closer
to 30 miles. So the development of this petition is Pinecrest Expedition Academy. Why this school?
Why here? We have an active outdoor community similar to areas like South Lake Tahoe or Truckee.
Our curriculum from EL Education is innovative. It's unique. It encompasses outdoor classrooms,
project-based learning, and a relationship directly to our community.
The slides I'm showing now are our facility. This is the former site of a district Pinecrest
Elementary School located within the Pinecrest area. This is a 10,000 square foot facility that
is now privately owned. This facility is available to us under a lease. As you can see,
the facility is comprised of three classrooms in the main building and one exterior portable
classroom. It has a play structure, a multi-purpose room, office space, and outdoor space. This
property sits on nearly five acres in the town of Strawberry, which is three miles from Pinecrest.
There's been a lot said about our lack of educational experience and our lack of charter
school experience, and I can't tell you otherwise. I can tell you that we are business leaders.
We have substantial nonprofit experience. They are a highly responsible group of people
who understands accountability and transparency, and Peggy Herndon and our new board member Chris
and our new board member Chris do bring substantial education experience to our board.
The petition was designed uniquely because we do have a low student count and our staff is unique.
It has a lead teacher designed to serve as a principal and a classroom teacher, a business
operations manager to oversee some of the back office and business end of the school,
second classroom teacher, and two part-time independent study teachers to oversee
the independent study program as well as being able to serve in the classroom as substitute
teachers and assist with special education as needed, and an administrative assistant who can
also serve in the classroom as a teacher's aide if and when needed. This petition was developed
to be by using the EL education design principles. There are several EL education charter schools in
California. The principles behind their program focus on these that I have put up on the screen,
the primacy of self-learning, having wonderful ideas, responsibility for learning, empathy and
caring, success and failure, collaboration and competition, diversity and inclusion, the natural
world, solitude and reflection, service and compassion. These building blocks build upon
the whole curriculum which is based in project-based learning and learning outside of the traditional
classroom. This encompasses case studies, field work, collaboration and service learning with
other area agencies and businesses. We have agencies such as the United States Forest Service,
the Strawberry Fire Protection District, Tridam Project, which is a major hydroelectric project
in Strawberry, and other local businesses such as Pinecrest Lake Resort and Dodgewood Ski Area
very actively interested in being collaborators with this program.
The instruction and design is designed to run two lateral programs, a site-based program and a
homeschool program. The homeschool or independent study program was envisioned so that each student
has a scheduled weekly meeting with their teacher using the same curriculum modified as needed as
we are using in the classroom. The homeschool students would be eligible to participate in the
learning expeditions that occur outside of the classroom with the site-based students.
Multi-grade classrooms are decidedly unique. Everyone knows that. We understand that we will
meet the needs through standards-based instruction, rotating daily whole group and differentiating
small group instruction based on data from assessments that are ongoing.
COVID-19 has obviously posed unique circumstances to every one of us in everyday life. However,
we feel that our program is very well poised to navigate COVID-19 and close gaps that are
left by the district and that the district only has one main campus, no ongoing independent study
program and no satellite campuses either. This program is designed to have a smaller school
with adequate spacing in our facility, the ability to use outdoor classrooms, a smaller staff
and an easy transition to distance learning if and when needed thanks to the independent study
homeschool program already built in. A lot of you will ask where do these students go to school now?
Many of them have transferred out of the district to provide for other opportunities with emergency
contacts. It's hard to be 30 miles from your student when they're in elementary school.
They need something throughout the day. Many of these kids are homeschooled without using a public
school program at this time and we also have a large amount of parents who drive into our area
and work who would prefer to have their kids go to school close to the workplace. The financial
viability of our budget is there. We did qualify on June 25th, 2020 for the $250,000 charter school
revolving loan. That money was removed from the budget that we submitted to CDE and that created
the negative fund balances. The county found a deficiency in special education. We have included
12.37% for special education funds including $29,952 which would be listed for AB 602
and $44,928 for encroachment. The original budget assumed that the SELPA would act as a
pass-through and intercept the AB 602 funds. On the screen is a revision to the LCFF money based on
the May 20 calculator. I believe the calculator is version 21.1a. When including the $250,000
charter school revolving loan, we do have positive reserve balances. They are substantial.
Our startup costs are minimal as our facility is actually already very well equipped with desks,
chairs, library books. We have a substantial amount of computers that are up to par which
have been given to us from the community. I ask you to consider what it is like for these kids
to travel huge amounts of time, what it's like for their parents not to be directly involved
in their education and see the importance of this school in this location and know that our business
sense is capable of hiring the appropriate people needed to run this school so that it
is successful and academically and financially very viable. I look forward to your questions
to myself and our board members on this call. All right. I think now we're going to hear from
the district and the county. Hello? We're having a hard time hearing.
Well, I want to make sure. Can you hear me? This is Rick Hanna, superintendent.
I can hear you, yes. Would you like me to proceed?
Stay here for an hour. Somebody is talking in the background then.
It's not me. It's not. I'm by myself. Okay. Everyone else, please mute and please continue.
Thank you. I am Rick Hanna, superintendent of the Twainheart School District. Our district spent a
great deal of money and time to develop our summary of findings, which I believe you have
reviewed as well as your advisory committee. Back in 2018, this petition was presented to
the Twainheart School Board and was denied 5-0. It came back with only one change, and that was
the addition of an independent study program, which in our opinion is very unreliable and
unpredictable. It was denied by our board by 5-0 vote. As Kathy Parker will talk to the county
superintendent and county office of education denied it by a 6-0 vote. Your advisory committee
denied it by an 8-1 vote. Before I go on, I want just to present that, please pay attention that
that's only received one positive vote in this process. I've continued to question the number of
enrollees that the petition has stated. I at one time authenticated, and I didn't authenticate,
but more than 20-21 kids, but that's debatable. I'm still not sure that those students are there.
One of the businesses, Genest Park, which was going to provide a substantial number of students
to the charter, or as they hoped, has closed down out of business, and I don't know that the petitioner
has mentioned that, but I think that's going to have a big impact on the small number of students
they're already looking at. The charter is alluding to the concerns about the distances from
our school to the Pinecrest area, but I want to point out that the charter provides no
busing at all in the petition, where we do drive up and pick up the students. We firmly believe
that driving the bus in any snowy conditions, it's not as far as the petitioner states, is much safer
than private automobiles. And lastly, we continue to question the fiscal stability of the petition.
Thank you. Thank you. Are we hearing from a county administrator? Yes, my name is Kathy Parker. I am
the county superintendent of schools. Just to give a little history of the Ptolemy County Board of
Education, they have supported two charter school petitions on appeal. Both were the only
charter schools that came on appeal, and both were approved in the past, Golden Lakes Charter School
and Foothill Leadership. So they have a history of supporting alternative education models in
our county and support innovative practices. However, when this academy was first
coming to the county on appeal in 2018, in that particular review, we found a lot of the same
deficiencies that we found in this current review, which was done as a de novo review as well.
The main concerns are some of the things that have been highlighted by
the commission, the CDE, and also the LEA Twain Heart School District.
Setting aside the educational program concerns, the amount of money that is set aside for
special education in that particular budget is woefully deficient. We have about a 13-14 percent
identification rate for special education students in Ptolemy County. We also have an allocation
that districts need to build in. We sweep basically all of their special education funds
and do a bill back to districts of approximately $750 per ADA to provide moderate to severely
disabled student services in our county. The county office provides all of those services,
so independent living skills, nexus programs for students with emotional disturbances,
structured preschool programs. The county office provides it all.
Districts have to use their general fund dollars to provide support for special education services
offered at a district level. In addition, they have to pay $750 per ADA to support the cost of
providing services for students with moderate to severe disabilities.
That was a piece in the budget that was very concerning. In addition, there were no contingencies
for students who may qualify for additional services such as speech, OT, adaptive PE,
or for students who might be placed into a program offered by the county office because
then there is a cost associated for that as well. Additionally, we're concerned about the
employee qualifications. These concerns were brought up by the CDE. We're concerned about the
racial, ethnic, special education, and EL balance requirements in a petition. But again,
it all comes back to the operational budget and the startup budget. And while the county office
reviewed this petition separate from the previous petition that had been submitted,
we also identified that there wasn't much of a difference between the one petition that had
been submitted and this new petition. We feel that they are unlikely to successfully implement
the program. And so as a result, the county board denied the petition. It was a 6-0 vote with one
of our board members abstaining from the vote. And that's my contribution to this conversation.
Unless you have questions.
Thank you very much. Well, we're going to prepare now for public comment before we raise any other
questions. We're going to open the phone line for the public comment queue. And if somebody can put
up that slide again so that folks who are watching can see it. Members of the public wishing to
provide comment may do so by calling 712-432-0075. Enter the access code 651-905 pound. Wait for the
operator prompts to press star six and then another prompt to press one to enter the queue.
We encourage you to please state your name and affiliation for the record.
And please remember to turn down the volume on your computer if you're following the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to one minute each. Are there any public comments?
Yes, we do have public comments for this item.
All right. And do you want to put up the public comment slide? I'm not seeing it. Thank you. Okay.
Hello, my name is John Lupo. Thank you for taking my call.
I support the petition to establish the Pine Crest Expedition Academy. The Pine Crest community
desperately needs this school culturally and economically. And more importantly, by creating
the opportunity for children to attend school where their families and friends live and work,
you will be offering these people the choice to determine the environment where learning best
occurs. You can help make their lives better. So I respectfully request that you work with Heidi
and her team and approve, at least conditionally, this petition. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
State board members, this is Sheila Whitley and I represent the California Teachers Association.
CTA recommends that the State Board of Education vote to deny this petition of establishment
for Pine Crest Expedition Academy. We oppose this petition for the following reason. PEA does not
represent a sound educational program and is demonstrably unlikely to implement the program
set forth in this petition due to unrealistic financial and operational plans, including
negative ending fund balances. Secondly, this petition does not contain a reasonably comprehensive
description of all the required elements 1, 2, 5, 10, and 14. Currently, Twain Hart School District
serves only 257 students in K-8. Pine Crest is proposing to enroll 65 of these students
in their K-8 petition. The physical impact of new charters, especially during the pandemic and these
unusual budget times, is not prudent. Therefore, we recommend the State Board of Education deny
Pine Crest petition. Thank you. We have no additional callers in the queue right now,
but we do have additional callers on the line, so I'm going to check with them to see if they
would like to provide public comments. Good afternoon, caller. Did you wish to make a comment
on item 16? Caller, did you wish to make a comment on item 16? Good afternoon,
caller. Did you wish to make a comment on item 16? Yes, I would like to, please.
You may begin your comment now. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi, I'm Chuck Retwining. I'm a board member of the PEA. I'm sorry, sir. Can you please get closer to
your phone or to your microphone? Sure. Can you hear me better now? That's better. Thank you.
Thank you. I'm Chuck Retwining. I'm a board member of the PEA. I'm calling in favor of granting them
the petition. I spent 21 years on the Tuolumne County Board of Education, and we've gone through
several charter school applications, and I understand that Kathy is a little weary of them
because two of the last ones we approved failed. I've been out of the County Board of
Education for a year now, so I haven't been following what's going on. There's lots of
unique things that are offered being in the mountains. Some of you probably would love to
have grown up or raised your kids in an environment like we have where it's safe and sane and in the
mountains, and it's a great area for raising kids. Hence, we need a school for them. In the
six years the school has been gone. That's your time, caller. Thank you for your call. Thank you.
That concludes all of the public comments on the conference line.
Okay. Given that there's no other public comment, I hereby close the public hearing for this item
at 317 p.m. and we'll commence with board discussion and action. First, I want to ask Ting's
son as our state board liaison if she has any initial comments. Then we'll ask board members
if they have any clarifying questions or comments as part of our board discussion. Ting? Hi.
Hi. I wanted to start my remarks with maybe adding a little bit to what Stephanie had
described about the state board process because we do have some new members. One of the things
I wanted to emphasize and to remind our board is that these appeals, these petitions that come
before us are de novo reviews, so we're not looking at how it was reviewed by others,
but looking at a brand new fresh look at the petition in the process. The other that I don't
think was mentioned is that under current law, which is what we are looking at under the reviews
under which we're looking at these petitions and appeals, is that it actually does compel
the authorizer, the reviewer, to approve the petition unless we can
prove that there are these various elements that was described by Stephanie.
And so what I have found that when we have looked at these,
you know, on face, it looks like it could be very technical, right? Whether the program is unsound,
whether the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely or likely to be able to be successful with the
program, whether the elements are reasonably comprehensive, you would think you could
checklist this, but in actuality, it's really fairly subjective in how we look at this.
And so what I do and when I'm looking at these situations is a lot of times it is about context,
and I look at time and place in which these petitions were here. I look at innovation,
is this offering an option or choice that doesn't currently exist within the system,
which is part of what chartering is about, and then I mostly look at benefit for kids.
And so, you know, you have to take all of these things in mind, and this is not necessarily to
this particular petition right now, but I'm just making some general comments about the context
from which to look at these petitions. So with that now, specific to PEA, I'm quite inspired by
the concept by the petitioners have brought forth. It kind of reminds me of this kind of one room
schoolhouse concept, and I am empathetic to the distance that the school is from the school sites
that the students would otherwise be attending. And so I understand, and I really laud the
petitioners for their efforts in bringing forth a program that they feel best meets the needs of
their students in their community. At the same time, I am concerned with also the other side
of this, which is looking at operationally and physically whether this school can stand alone,
and it is particularly related to the size of the program and the size of the district in which this
this program would be opening. And from my understanding is that there used to be a pinecrest
district, I think, right in the area or something to that effect, which ended up having to close
or something like that. So I am very, very concerned about the size and the ability of
just within the size of being able to provide the scope of services for to meet the needs of
all students. Because while it does harken on the full idyllic one room schoolhouse concept,
we're not in the 19th century US, we are in 21st century. And so there are lots of requirements
and to be operational as a LEA for special education, for a myriad of other things,
accountability. I do have a lot of concerns.
Right. Is there further discussion from the board? Let's see if I see any hands up.
I see a member Navo and then member Strauss.
Yeah, thank you, board president. And Stephanie, I have a question. I'm trying to wrap my head
around the financials, because it's clear that pinecrest has a different view of what their
ending balances are compared to ours. And I'm trying to grasp how we're so far apart
from one another in terms of where they are financially if they included the $250,000 revolving
fund in their funding calculator and that created the discrepancy. Can you shed some light on that
from your perspective? Sure. So I'm on, right? So yeah, so we based our analysis on the budget
that they submitted with their petition. The numbers that they are showing today during their
presentation, those were not submitted to us. They did not submit a new budget to us.
So we've not been able to analyze that or provide any analysis. We're seeing it on the screen with
you. Okay. Does that, doesn't that constitute a material revision?
Or no? I'm gonna, I'm gonna let Judy answer that.
Hi, this is Judy Sias with the Chief Counsel for the State Board. What defines a material
revision under the old law is certainly complicated. I think in the past, the board has
acknowledged that budgets change. And certainly in this instance, when petitioners do their
budget in the fall and what shows up this spring given the pandemic is different.
I do think, you know, when they put stuff out for us at the beginning where we haven't had a chance
to review it, that certainly adds a layer of complexity to the analysis. But whether or not
it's a material revision is a complicated question that we've struggled with at the board. But the
budget is certainly one of the things that we have, petitioners have submitted updated figures
given the changes in the budget circumstances that are often beyond the control of the school.
Okay, thank you. I have other questions, but I can come back and let others weigh in.
Why don't you go ahead, Matt, and ask your questions and then I'll move to member Strauss.
This is for the petitioner. I do agree with the county regarding your special education funding.
I'm trying to understand how you, how you came up with your special education funding plan. What
did you base that on? The original budget did not include funds from AB 602 as we assumed that a
SELPA would intercept those funds. So the original budget submitted to the county included the 44,000
in special education. If we were to become a member of say the El Dorado SELPA and retain those funds
from AB 602, that would raise our special education budget to $12.3 million. So that's
3.7% and it's $74,000. Okay, so if I understand correctly, it goes back to the original question
about the budget. You included that as a new, as a new item in this budget. CDE hasn't,
didn't see that. County didn't see that. We included that as a rebuttal to our county findings
and we did submit a revised version of the LCFF calculator and I did present this same slide
to the advisory committee in June. For the county office, you had mentioned you have
charters that you've approved, Golden Lakes and Foothill. Can you tell me a little bit more about
what the difference is between those two in this, in this request? At the time that those petitions
were submitted, they had a budget that was sustainable, at least in their charter petition
at the time. That was one of the largest, so the likelihood of a program being successful
and the soundness of the educational program as well played, that was the deciding factor for the
county board. I will be frank that on both of those, I was not the county superintendent on either
of them. Both of them were two different county superintendents. The county superintendents and
staff recommended not approving those charters and the county board did decide to approve those
charters despite the recommendation. So I just want to make sure that that's understood about
how the county board operates. They are very independent in that they will very much give
a lot of latitude in their approval process, trying to again encourage innovation, trying to
encourage different ways of addressing some of the challenges we have in small rural
counties, meaning small districts, not small geographically, geographic areas. And so that's
the history behind Golden Lakes. Unfortunately, Golden Lakes, within two years of operating and
opening, there were some issues and they changed their charter approver to a school district in
Stanislaus County and then shortly after decided not to seek approval for a renewal and close.
Foothill leadership, which was the most recent one that was approved, did not receive a renewal
again under very sad circumstances, a lot of inexperience on the fiscal management side of
the house. And we've actually, it's taken a year for us to finally close out that school. And so
that's the history with our charter schools in Tuolumne County. And then there's only one other
charter school in Tuolumne County, but it is about the third largest school of the district
in Tuolumne County. So it attracts quite a few students. Thank you. Anything else, Matt?
No, that'll do it for now. Thank you. Okay. We're going to go to member Strauss and then
member Glover Woods. Yeah. So my understanding is this is a rural setting and there's a small
number of students that the local Twainheart district serves and then also the petitioner
is proposing to serve. I do have some particular, I think there's some strengths that the
petitioner presented today. Certainly they personalized knowing the kids well, the experience,
the outdoor in that area sounds really exciting for parents, particularly how hard things have
been lately and knowing in a small personalized setting. However, I do share the concerns of the
educational program that member Sung reminded that we are responsible to make sure that English
learners have the right support, that special ed has the right support. And there's a lot of
requirements. Those of us who've led schools and districts know, even though you have good intent,
there's some legal guidelines. I do think the SOFA would provide support, but I think it's a broad
proposal with 60 some odd students in two classrooms with home independent school as well.
And I guess I have another concern that having originally submitted the petition in 2018,
that there's been very little change and modification to the petition over time.
And yet the findings have really said you need to address the changes. So I just,
again, I have mixed feelings in that I think there's a wonderful belief in opportunity to
create a nice setting and learning opportunity for a small number of students. But I still
believe that we have requirements in the educational program that we must ensure are there for those
students. Okay. Member Glover Woods. Thank you. And my question is to the petitioners,
it can also be to Stephanie as well. And it really builds off of board member Strauss' comment.
As it relates to the review that was done, there was a concern about the descriptiveness
of the English learner program and the support that English learners would receive.
I wanted to hear a bit more from the petitioners on the specifics on how you would ensure that
our designated as English learners receive the proper program. I would like to have our board
member Chris and Peggy answer that question if it pleases the board. Okay. Are they there?
That's fine. Okay. Chris? Did we lose Chris? Oh, no. Here I am. Well, they,
as I can appreciate that a small school has challenges when you have only two classrooms
and, you know, eight grade levels. The idea would be that you would have a block of whole
group instruction for students in K, for language arts anyway, in TK or K3. And you would deliver
on rotating days the core standards. Embedded in the, not embedded, but along the ELD standards
are part of the ELA standards. So there would be an alignment to the integrated parts of ELA,
I mean, of ELD in the ELA time, as well as in science and social studies times.
And the idea is to give differentiated instruction for ELA, ELD, and ingrain
the designated parts with small group instruction with rotating centers. So it would be,
you're talking about, you know, when you're thinking about the number of students here
and you're saying roughly 54 students, you're talking, it sounds like you have this amazing
challenge, but you need to picture that, say, roughly, you can't control exactly how the
distribution by grade level is, but let's just say there were 25 students in K3, and they're not
going to fall neatly into grade level, but if you begin to think about the size of the classroom in
and of itself, it's a lot easier to differentiate instruction. We're not talking about trying to
provide ELD designated and integrated to hundreds of children. There's 25 students, and so you're
able to really determine through the LPAC, through ELA assessments, through the basic
phonics skills test, all kinds of early reading literacy to figure out where students are,
both as English learners and as English language arts learners, and differentiate a program for
them by which is going to be customized and tailored almost individually to each child.
The beauty of a multi-age classroom in that way is, as we all know, you can have first graders
who are really performing as third graders, and you can have third graders who are performing as
first graders, and that multi-age allows for that flexibility. This program would be, in a way,
you're having a, like I said, an individualized plan for each student that is able to address
their particular needs. The program is designed, and the school's intent is to progress monitor
these students every four to six weeks with the flexibility of moving them in and out of
either small group differentiated instruction in ELA or ELD as needed. Therefore, students are
able to progress at their pace in a way that they're not able to do, particularly in large schools,
because the system is so big and doesn't respond as quickly. Here, the response time to their
progress or lack of is going to be immediate. Every credentialed teacher, the plan is to hire
a credentialed teacher who has EL authorization. That teacher will be qualified into understanding
the essential ELA standards, the ELD standards, and how to offer, provide designated and integrated
ELD to students. The other questions, Cynthia? No. Okay. Eileen, it looks like your hand is up again.
No? Okay. Taking it down? All right. So I don't see any other questions from members of the board.
So the question now is, do we have a motion?
If I could just clarify a little bit on the budget piece that Matt was asking about.
So what the petitioner, I believe, was providing was a budget based on the May
revise because during the recommendation for the ACCS, there was a review by the department
of a budget using the May revise. But of course, now the May revise has changed.
And I'm wondering for the petitioners, did you have an updated budget based on the budget that
was passed? We have not updated the budget since the budget has passed due to the time constraints.
The original budget we submitted did include the $250,000 charter school revolving loan as other
income. When CDE did their review, they removed that, which generated the negative fund balances.
The revision we provided was based on the May revise, assuming a worst case scenario in our
funding. And that is as far as I have taken the budget at this point.
Was there at any point, did you all the petitioners talk to the district about
a district program that would meet your needs? I have asked the Twainheart School District
more than once. I asked prior to Rick Hennis being the superintendent. I asked this year after I
submitted this petition, if we could work together, even establishing trying to pass a tax measure,
if they were worried about the fiscal impacts to the district. I have a lot of respect for
Kathy Parker as the county superintendent and have also spoken to her on multiple occasions.
The Twainheart School District is a basic aid district. And I know you mentioned it early on
about the closure of the Pinecrest School. The Pinecrest School did operate until 2012,
was originally under the Columbia School District. It was given to the Twainheart School District
in the summer of 1995. And Twainheart ran it until they were changed to the basic aid funding
schedule. So they lost their necessary small school funds and the incentive to run a school
in the Pinecrest area. The Pinecrest School did operate for nearly a century in this community
with a small student enrollment. Peggy is an alumni of the Pinecrest School, as am I.
And those multi-grade classrooms did function. And I do understand that we're not little house
on the prairie and I'm not trying to make it seem like that. But I also understand that in the 21st
century that the community does still have substantial educational needs that are not
currently being met. And although the district does a fine job at their sole location, it does
not extend to this area of the community, which does provide them substantial support in their
basic aid funding statute with their excess tax. This is the high property value of that district
and we need to continue to support that so all parties involved can continue to survive and thrive.
Thank you. Are there any other questions from board members? Seeing none, is there a motion?
No, go ahead. Well, was that Matt who I heard? Yeah, go ahead, Ting. I'll go after you.
Yeah, so this has been a difficult one. I, again, do admire what the petitioners are trying to do
in serving the needs of their students and their specific community. I, it is very difficult to get
over the small numbers and to be able to provide the expanse of services. I do hope that the
district, the county, will try to work with the petitioners in helping them provide some choice
for this, but I will be, I'm going to go with the CDE recommendation to deny the charter.
Is there a second? I'll second. All right, is there any further discussion?
Seeing none, we'll now hold a roll call vote. Karen, please call the roll. Okay. Patricia?
Yes. Brennan? Yes. Jim? Yes. Ting? Yes. Eileen? Yes. Linda? Yes. Cynthia? Yes.
Matt? Yes. Hay Day? Yes. Kim? Yes. The vote's unanimous. All right, well, thank you very much,
Stephanie. I want to reinforce members' sons' plea that the district think about the choices for these
parents and community members, and we're now going to take a 10-minute break
before the next public hearing. So I want to ask you to please turn off your microphones and cameras,
board members, and be back here at about 3.52. Thank you. Thank you.
I know Member Rucker had to step away for a moment, but it looks like we have everyone else.
So Karen, would you like to reestablish a quorum by calling the roll? Yes. Okay,
Patricia stepped away for a moment, but she'll be right back. Brenna?
Here. Jim? Here. Ting?
Ting, are you there? Okay, we'll go there. Ting's there. Okay, good. Eileen? Yes. Linda?
Here. Cynthia? Yes. Matt? Here. Hay Day? Here. Kim?
Karen, would you like to? Here. Okay, everyone's here except for Patricia.
We know she'll be right back. Okay, so agenda item 17 is a public hearing regarding petition
for the establishment of a charter school under the oversight of the State Board of Education,
consideration of EGLE Collegiate Academy, which was denied by the Act in Agua Dolce Unified School
District on Los Angeles County Board of Education. The CDE recommends that the State
Board hold a public hearing to deny the request to establish EGLE Collegiate Academy,
TKK through grade three charter school. This item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of CDE.
Stephanie, please begin. Thank you. Before I start, I just want to clarify one thing based on the
overview I gave before the last item in terms of the SBE role. I just want to clarify that the law
does say that petitions shall be approved unless one of the findings that I had listed in that
slide are made. And so I want to be clear about that piece of ed code. So today we're going to
talk about EGLE Collegiate Academy. They are seeking authorization from the State Board of
Ed to establish a TK through grade eight charter school within the boundaries of the Act in Agua
Dulce Unified School District. The petitioners previously saw authorization. Oh, got to remember
to move this forward. Previously saw authorization through Act in Agua Dulce and the LA County Board
of Education. They were denied by the district on November 14th, 2019 and denied by the LA County
Board of Education on January 21st, 2020. They appealed to the State Board on January 27th,
2020. There may be some board members who see that this sounds familiar to them. They were,
EGLE Collegiate was in front of this board last year in May 2019 and obviously they were denied.
So they're back now. The California Department of Education recommends that the State Board hold a
public hearing to deny the request to establish EGLE Collegiate a TK through grade eight charter
school under the oversight of the SBE. The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools on June 9th
considered the EGLE Collegiate Academy petition and they moved the CDE recommendation to deny
the request to establish EGLE Collegiate petition by a vote of seven to one with one abstention.
The basis for recommendation for denial, the petition is not consistent with sound education
practice. The petitioner is demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the intended program
and the petition does not provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all required 15
charter elements. A little background on the school, their mission statement is to empower
pupils to become self-confident and authentic global citizens prepared for 21st century careers
and responsibilities. The enrollment projections are they intend to open, their intention was to
open in 2021 with 168 pupils in TK through grade three and grow to serve 438 pupils by 24-25.
And the program intends to adopt an international baccalaureate IB model.
On to our findings, unsound educational program, the petition provides an insufficient description
of the educational program, it does not reasonably comprehensive or does not, sorry, does not include
a reasonably descriptive plan for the implementation of the IB program or the professional development
plan for IB teacher training, does not sufficiently describe how English learners will receive
targeted English language development instruction, very little detail about the scope of the
program, very insufficient description of teaching methodologies and IB pedagogy
and scope and a lack of scope and sequence in each subject.
Inability to implement, this is, you'll see this slide in all of our charter appeals just to
remind everyone that, like you need reminding, that we're in the middle of a COVID-19 pandemic
and the budget is, the proposed June agreement includes 11 billion dollars of apportionment
deferrals for 2021. It's something that charters and especially charters that are looking to
establish will probably be a burden and problematic for them.
The inability to implement fiscal analysis, this is a fiscal analysis of the budget plan
that was submitted with their petition. If you can see here the first year, they are in the red
with no reserves and then they move up the second two years. I think it's important to note that
part of their budget is to borrow receivables. They'll be borrowing receivables, 515,000 on
startup year, 893,000 for the following year and 1,600,000, I'm horrible with these numbers,
1,636,000 for the following year. So that's a lot of borrowing and borrowing receivables for a
startup school who will also may have to deal with deferrals as well. It also is important to note
that the school must meet its enrollment ADA projections in order to be fiscally solvent.
There's no wiggle room there.
We do believe that they have aggressive enrollment assumptions and as I just mentioned,
their budget plan is completely reliant on their enrollment projections and growth to cover
expenditures. Their enrollment growth in the first five years, 168 in 2021 and 438 in 2425.
The district that they're located in, the Acton-Aguaduce district serves approximately
a thousand pupils. The district has one elementary school, one junior high and one high school.
The petition states that ECA will be an IB candidate school by its opening.
Again, opening times have been affected by COVID-19. So
that's something that the board can discuss. We have concerns regarding the ability of the
school to recruit staff, create a high quality instructional program, initiate the administrative
processes and facilities needed for all grade levels and meet the requirements for the IB
program. Additional concerns surrounding the level of professional development for IB teachers
is also one that CDE staff has found troubling.
In terms of their facility plan,
we do have concerns about the facility that they plan to lease within the boundaries of the
Acton-Aguaduce district and also the modular buildings that they are proposing to acquire
and put on the land. We felt in the original budget, we saw that they did not have the
budgeted amount for the proper budgeted amount for the types of modulars that they would be using
and they also, we felt that they were not, had not budgeted for the amount of work the facility
actually needs. The petition also has insufficient descriptions of the charter elements,
charter elements one, two, four and five. Educational program, I had spoken about that
a little bit ago, but also in addition to that, the petition does not include a comprehensive
description of the IB primary years program and middle years program, which is primarily
what they would be implementing. As you know, the full IB program is a high school, so they would be
implementing these two earlier programs. It does not conclude a comprehensive description of the
professional development needed for IB teachers and it does not sufficiently describe how ELs
will receive their instruction. The petition does not outline measurable pupil outcomes
that address increases in pupil academic achievement, both school-wide and for all
groups of pupils. We find this is common and really, in my estimation, a big gap in knowledge
when it comes to measurable pupil outcomes because this is how authorizers
oversee and measure growth in schools. The governance structure, the petition states
that ECA board members cannot simultaneously be members of the compensation committee and employees
of the school, but of course, this conflicts with their bylaws, which states that no director
serving at any time may be current employees of the corporation. So there's some language
in their bylaws and in their petition that conflict, which we had concerns with.
ECA school site council is in violation of Ed Code section 65000. The number of parents,
pupils and community members does not equal the number of school members selected.
Employee qualifications, the petition does not identify key positions nor does it specify
the additional qualifications of individuals in those positions. Given the IB program described
in the petition, if teachers teach only one discipline, ECA would possibly need 32 single
subject credential teachers. This is just some of the issues that we had in terms of confusing
language and not quite sure whether they understood how the credentialing works for schools and what
they would actually need to implement the very aggressive academic program that they outlined.
The petition does not outline measurable pupil outcomes that increases in pupil academic
achievement, both school-wide and for all groups of pupils, and that is pertaining to the eight
state priorities. So in conclusion, the CDE recommends that the state board deny the petition
to establish EGLE collegiate. The petition does not provide a sound educational program.
The petitioner is demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the intended program,
and the petition does not provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all required elements.
And there is the public comment page.
Okay. At this point, we will hear from the petitioner. Petitioners will have 12 minutes.
Then we'll hear from the district and county that are opposing the petition,
who will also have a total of 12 minutes. And after there are presentations from both sides,
we will have an opportunity for public comment from any individual who has not already presented
for one minute each. Linda, you need to officially open the public hearing.
I'm sorry, yes. I officially open the public hearing at 4.05 p.m.
and we'll open the phone line for public comment queue.
Can we hear from the petitioner?
Is the petitioner? Yes. Ready. Okay. Please begin.
Linda, you need to officially open the public hearing.
I'm sorry, yes. I officially open the public hearing at 4.05 p.m.
She did. She's opened it.
I did do that. And we'll open the phone line for public comment queue.
Good afternoon, honorable president. I'm sorry, somebody probably has their
live feed on, which means we're hearing what I said a minute ago now.
So if you have the live feed on, please turn your computer volume down.
Yes. Ready. Okay.
Linda, you need to officially open the public hearing.
Can you see this? Can you guys see the screen?
She did. She's opened it.
We're in some kind of a strange Groundhog Day loop.
Okay. I think the petitioner, you should be prepared to begin. Go ahead.
Okay. Good afternoon, honorable board president, Dr. Darlene Hammond,
and honorable state board members. I am happy to see that all of you are safe,
healthy, and still smiling after a long day.
My name is Ogokoye Johnson, founder and lead petitioner of Eagle Collegiate Academy.
On behalf of all our families anxiously waiting for our decision,
your decision this afternoon, thank you and the CDE staff for taking the time to review
our petition. Our board president, advocate, architect, fiscal consultant,
and charter school law consultants are here with me to answer your questions.
I would like to emphatically state that our families and team will be happy to accept
a fall 2021 charter term start as a condition for approval, recognizing the unknown impact
of COVID-19 as early as in March 2020. We sent a letter to CDE and SBE staff affirming
that we would agree to a delayed start to give you as much comfort as possible
about our readiness for a successful launch. It will also make up for the four months of delay
caused by the district and by CDE's removal of ECA from ACCS April agenda and refusal
of our request to be placed on SBE's May agenda.
Throughout the four years since a group of local parents, educators, and professionals embarked
on this journey to provide access to quality education for our children and our community,
ECA team has listened, compromised, sacrificed, persevered, and addressed the concerns from
potential authorizers even when upon resubmission new concerns are raised and areas that were
previously found comprehensive are reversed. You recommended in May 2019 that we open with
less number of grade levels and students that will fit within the build in the first year.
We listened intently to your remarks. Board member Ms. Rocker, you stated that our program
is innovative and that you would have liked to have been able to attend such a school.
Board members Dr. Son and Mr. Navo said that there is an apparent need and a demand for ECA
based on our parent interest which board vice president Dr. Strauss saw when she visited our
community but president Dr. Darlene Hammond you affirmed that I be the solid educational program.
Board member Ms. Patel Brownstein was pleased to see that we included pre-k students in our program.
There was no question that ECA program is consistent with sound practice.
Your words gave us hope and energized us to start over again so we met with the district,
county and CDE charter school staff. County staff recommended having an IB trained leader
although not required by IB. I paid for and completed the IB school leader training. To
give you comfort about our seriousness and readiness to open we started the site plan
ministerial review process by hiring architects, engineers and arborists who spent extensive hours
over several days conversing the interior and exterior of the property to develop the site plan
which Los Angeles county department of regional planning used to deem the site feasible having
met all zoning requirements. The county staff engineers said that they visited the site in
January on the morning of our scheduled board vote. The district staff stated during the ACCS
meeting that staff called public works seeking current permits for the site however you would
not be fiscally prudent for us to request permits to make changes to the property
without an approval of our petition. These tables show numerous inconsistencies in CDE
reports. The most recent is from June to July. CDE has had ECA petition since January 2020
and found ECA's petition to be consistent with sound educational practice in its April and
June reports. It is unclear what changed in the two weeks after the ACCS meeting because CDE did
not cite new reasons to reverse this finding in this July report. We have documented evidence
found throughout the petition that ECA is a sound education program that meets the needs of all our
student groups specifically on this petition pages. We have a letter of support from charter
schools development center who works with charter schools to make sure that they are on board with
what they are doing. ECA has also been accepted into the Eldorado Charter Selper after a very
rigorous application process. CDE found that ECA has aggressive enrollment but that's not the case.
The chart on the left shows that in 2019 we had 355 versus 168 students in 2020, a 53% reduction
which is pretty much doing what you asked us to do in May 2019. The chart on the left show that
and we had pre-k through eight and not pre-k through three which is what we have now,
five grade levels less. The table on the right shows the population of the 11 school districts
in our surrounding communities and the distance from their respective district offices to ECA's
proposed site. Five are in Santa Clarita Valley and five are in Antelope Valley. One is in Castaigne,
the nearest school district in Santa Clarita about eight miles and 15 minutes away to the site and
the nearest school is about five miles and six minutes away in Santa Clarita. The further school
district is 35 miles and 41 minutes away in Antelope Valley. These communities are within
short to very reasonable driving distances from each other. There are over 114,000 seat-based
students across these school districts. ECA's 168 students also include private school and
home school students. San Fernando Valley schools about 14 miles away where 16% of our interested
families reside are not included in this total 114,000 population. The chart on the left show
the communities where ECA families reside. 56% reside in Santa Clarita Valley, 22% in Antelope
Valley, 16% in San Fernando Valley, 4% in Castaigne and 1.5% in Actinago-Dolce. The chart on the right
show that we have 396 students interested in ECA with a breakdown of the number of applicants
per grade level. It's important to note that Aberdeen-Stein, which is a former Actinago-Dolce
school district charter, opened with 650 K-6 students with over 1200 during lottery in September
2013 and only 10 students were from Actinago-Dolce. CDE stated that our site is remote and not safe.
However, that's not the case as well. The left top and lower quarters show that the site is within
a residential neighborhood with Sierra Highway running through it. The right top quarter are
close-up photos that show both right and turn views from the entry to the site.
One can clearly see far ahead on the road each way. The lower right quarter is a contextual
analysis of the entry plan showing the lanes to turn into the site and student drop-off.
There is adequate space to accommodate the proposed modular classrooms that will be added
incrementally over the years. The photo on the top left shows the exterior of the building with
its beautiful bricks while the photo on the top right shows the sanctuary of the church.
The two lower photos are hung directly across from the site. The property owner submitted a
letter to SBE that is seen here taking responsibility for any repairs needed to ensure
that the site is visible. Therefore, ECA is not going to be incurring any funds to do that.
The site is central to families coming from all surrounding communities, especially those
who commute to work via Sierra Highway. On June 19, 2020, at CDE's request, we submitted a balance
revised budget using the May revised LCFF calculator that CDE stated it will include in
its presentation to SBE. As a result, we believe that the figures presented by CDE do not accurately
describe our fiscal status and is now defunct because the new state budget has changed that
whole scenario. Our current budget on the right meets net asset requirements over the three years.
We maintain the cuts in the reduction from the May revised in order to be ready for any
unanticipated COVID-19 impact. Some of the cuts we made were the CEO salary, classified FTE,
and other overhead costs, and we submitted this to the CDE. To ensure ECA has cash flow as a result
of the first, we increased receivables, AR sales, and interest expense. We have applied for and made
the eligibility for the public school grant several times, and we will apply again. We also
have had conversations with these other foundations who provide funding to charter schools.
We use CDE's COVID-19 operations written report template to plan for opening, and we will follow
all the guidelines required for opening. We are considering phase opening.
Why do we need ECA? Our community needs ECA because it will help to eliminate the
huge gaps between educationally disadvantaged and not educationally disadvantaged students
in ELA and math. 61 to 91 percent of EDS are not meeting ELA and math standards in our communities.
It will lower chronic absenteeism, especially for SED students, as can be seen in these two charts,
and it will be the first and only pre-K IB world school in the valley, provide rigorous access to
college prep classes for underrepresented groups. Here is research supporting our model, and these
are the support that we have from the city, the state, and national leaders. Honorable Congressman
Mike Garcia, Honorable Senator Scott Will, Vice Chair of California Senate Education Committee,
Mayor Pro Tem Bill Miranda, City of Santa Clarita, Mr. Reyes, owner of a Reyes winery
that is right there in Agudose. And here are the IV support that we have and other community
organizations. The most important people who are here are the people you will see in this one-minute
play. Honorable commissioners and board members, I am here for the Korean families
in Antelope Valley, Santa Clarita Valley, and San Fernando Valley who have been waiting for
Eagle College Academy to open. It is an excellent educational program, and the location is perfect
and ideal for our families. Please approve Eagle College Academy for our families. Thank you.
We are the Amakos, and we support the ECA. We are the Maduski, and we support Eagle College Academy.
We are the Michaels, and we support ECA.
Hi, my name is Edwin Resinos. I am the pastor of City on a Hill Church. I am here with Dr. Hugo,
and this is our congregation who are asking you to please approve Eagle College Academy.
Although we work very hard to open by September 30, 2020, because we have students, staff,
funds, families, and fathers due to the continued unknown impact of COVID-19,
and to give you comfort about our successful launch, we once more
employ you to approve Eagle College Academy. That's your time. Thank you. Thank you.
I think we are ready to hear from the district and the county.
Do we have district and county representatives here?
Yes. This is Niche Patterson. I am the director of charter services for the
Act in Aguadulce Unified School District. I'm here in support of the Act in Aguadulce Unified
School District and LACO's staff findings to deny the petition to establish a charter
by Eagle Collegian Academy within the Act in Aguadulce Unified School District boundaries.
I will be presenting with Jeffrey Hartman, who is the coordinator free of the charter school's
office. Our number one priority in Act in Aguadulce Unified School District is ensuring that our
students are provided with a safe and quality education. We are in a rural area, and whether
it be through our district services that we provide in our seat-based schools, which are
a elementary, middle, and high school, or through the authorization services we provide through our
charter partners, which we currently authorize 12 charter schools, all of which we work collaboratively
with. We hold their operating procedures to the highest standards, and the same matrix that we
use to evaluate current charters and renewals is the same matrix that we use to evaluate new
charter applications. The petitioners for Eagle Collegian Academy have submitted on at least three
separate occasions that, when independently reviewed by charter staff, demonstrated that
they were demonstrably unlikely to be able to implement the plans that are outlined in their
petition. So, essentially, the enrollment numbers that Eagle Collegiant has proposed,
although they've decreased in overall totals for the year one of operation than when they had
previously submitted, it's still inconsistent with the grade level numbers that continue to
trend in our district. Both district and both county boards determined that the petitioners
were unlikely to successfully implement educational programs. The petition does not contain required
signatures. The petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all
required elements. Their unrealistic enrollment plan is that the school intends to open in August,
we are talking about the current year, not a delayed opening, with 168 pre-K through
third grade students. Currently, we do have a seat-based school, which is Eilead Aguadulce,
and in November in 2019, Eilead had a total of 124 students in TK through three, and as of right
now, they have 137. Eilead is an established charter that actually has a school in the
Santa Clarita Valley area, and they've been established in this area for over three years
with a growth of only 13 students. And as these numbers were likely to result in a need
for distance learning due to COVID-19, Act in Aguadulce Unified School District in November of
2019, our preschool through third grade program had 265 students, and as of today, has 273.
We have not seen an increase in student enrollment. That would be significant enough that would imply
that the enrollment projections that Eagle Collegiate is proposing is reasonable. Those
numbers are excessive, and although they have decreased the grade levels, they have not decreased
the number of students in the grade levels that they propose to serve.
I will now turn this over to Mr. Hartman. Good afternoon, Board members. My name is Jeff
Hartman, and I work for the Los Angeles County Office of Education. Although LA County Board of
Education adopted the same three findings stated previously by the local district, I will elaborate
only on the issue that was found to be most concerning. The facility on which Eagle Collegiate
Academy proposes to locate is not currently fit for use as a school, especially for children ages
three to eight years old, which would occupy the site during year one. This is the same site ECA
proposed to use at the appeal before this board last year on May 9th, 2019. The site is located
on a 55 mile an hour stretch of Sierra Highway, a major commuting alternative to the State Route 14
known as the Antelope Valley Freeway. As you can see on this slide, there are no signal lights,
speed bumps, turning lanes, crosswalks that would accommodate the up to 168 families attempting to
safely drop off and pick up their children twice each day. In addition, there is not fencing
surrounding the entire site to keep these young children from accessing the adjacent highway,
an on-site drainage culvert, or the vast undeveloped expanse of hilly countryside that borders the site
to the south. We sent two representatives to the site on two occasions, and a report from our
engineer stated that there was visible damage to both the foundation and roof of the main building,
as well as evidence of copper wiring theft at this unoccupied facility. It was determined that not
only does the provided engineering quote of a hundred thousand dollars greatly underestimate
the costs that would be needed to make the site school ready, but that neither the petitioner nor
the engineer have budgeted for the necessary permits and studies that would be needed prior
to construction, making the proposed three-month timeline also unreasonable. Even with the additional
time, the costs and studies needed to be completed prior to the project are not sufficiently
addressed in a submitted budget. All of this is prior to the consideration of COVID-19. The
petitioner plans to divide the sanctuary of this former church into classrooms using partitions.
Much more expensive interior renovations would be needed to be done to make the building safe
for the number of students they plan to serve. These concerns regarding the choice of facilities
contribute to the finding by both the AAD-USD Board of Education and the LA County Board of
Education that the petitioners would be unlikely to successfully implement their educational program.
Next slide please.
In conclusion, the Los Angeles County Board of Education recommends denial of this petition
based on the three findings adopted by both the local district and county boards, that the
petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the proposed educational program,
that the petition does not contain the required number of signatures, and that the petition does
not contain a reasonably comprehensive description of all required elements.
Thank you for your time. Representatives from both the district and county are available for
questions. At this point, we'll open up the phone line for public comment
um and allow people to get into the public comment queue. I guess we want to post that
slide again in case people need to see it. Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this
item, there we go, may do so by calling 712-432-0075, entering the access code 651-905 pound, wait for the
operator prompt to press star six and then another prompt to press one to enter the queue.
Do we have anyone lined up for public comment yet? We have several callers that are in the queue.
All right, we encourage you to state your name and affiliation for the record and
remember to turn down the volume on your computers if you're following the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to one minute each and I want to ask the translator to provide
these instructions in Spanish for callers who need translation of their input.
All right, is there Linda we were hoping the translator would
jump in here and say it in Spanish. Is the translator listening?
No, okay, we're gonna keep going Linda, sorry, keep going.
Okay, the Spanish instructions are there to be read. So let's begin our public comment.
First caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
Hi, good afternoon everyone and thank you for your consideration. Can we please have two minutes
since it's myself Don Hakeem and my son Zane Hakeem would also like to speak?
Yes, we'll allow that.
Thank you. My name is Don and I am a parent with considerable charter school background and
experience and we have been involved with Eagle Collegiate Academy for the past two years.
I believe passionately that they absolutely will do a fantastic job with your IV program.
They have been in front of you. This is their second time. They've been to
Atena Cuedosa a few times and with every suggestion that has been made, every feedback,
they have soaked it up and made those changes. This is a team that is showing great flexibility
and they're willing to work with whoever authorizes them. They are backed by a group
of strong parents who want to help, who want to volunteer, who will be doing work at the
facility, who will be giving their services. I myself am a skilled human resources professional
and I will be helping. I was on the board for charter school so I have considerable
charter school experience. I think that we're comparing apples to oranges when we say that
Atena Cuedosa has low enrollment, that iLEAD has low enrollment because
iLEAD has schools operating very close to the Atena-
That's your time for your first speaker. Can you please go to your second speaker? Thank you.
Hi, so I do better. I'm Zain Hakim and I'm 12 years old and I do better in a smaller learning
environment because the teachers can help me focus on things that I didn't get,
I couldn't understand in class and it's a lot easier for me to work in a charter school type
environment and there's a lot of children and learners like me. I'm currently in a private school
and it is smaller and it has helped me a lot with individual attention and this year my
grades are significantly better than last year's and I've improved on my organization,
other skills that I needed to do better and Dr. Johnson has helped me immensely.
Thank you. She's been a great influence in my life. Thank you for your consideration.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record
and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon board members. This is Dr. Oscar Scott. I am calling in support of approval of
Eagle Collegiate Collegiate Academy. I have known Dr. Ogo Johnson for nearly 30 years
and I would like to speak to her character. So much in regards to making decisions are made in
regards to statistics but you have to have character and determination and drive and Dr.
Johnson is well respected in the educational community. I have never known her to take on a
project where she has never been successful with. So I really urge with the bottom of my heart
that you would not rely so much on cold statistics but you would rely on the burning desire of Dr.
Johnson and I respectfully request time of this consideration and approval. Thank you very much
for your consideration. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record
and begin speaking. Your time starts now. State board members, this is Sheila Whitley and I
represent the California Teachers Association. CTA recommends that the State Board of Education
vote to deny the petition of establishment for Eagle Collegiate Academy as recommended by the
California Department of Education. ECA is demonstrably unlikely to implement the program
set forth in the petition due to an unrealistic financial and operational plan including aggressive
enrollment assumptions and their petition is not consistent with sound educational practice.
The ECA petition does not contain a reasonably comprehensive description of all of the required
elements including elements one, two, four, and five. The state board should deny the Eagle Collegiate
petition and ask the Eagle Collegiate Academy to stop their continued attempts that are wasting
taxpayer funds and burdening the staff of the district, county, and CBE. Thank you.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Andrea Douglas. I'm an associate at Eagle Collegiate Academy. Very nervous. I just
want to say that LA USC currently has over 229 charter schools and Senate Corita does not have
any. I think that your approval will give us this additional educational opportunity
to meet the diverse educational needs and priorities of all students and families
in the Santa Clarita area. Thank you so much for your time.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
This is Katlyn O'Halloran with the Charter Schools Development Center.
CSCC has worked with ECA for several years. The lead petitioner, Ogo Johnson, contacted CSCC the
first time she brought her petition to Acton-Olga Dulce and CSCC has continued to work with her as
she moves her charter through the appeals process. Ms. Johnson and her team have been responsive and
reflective and has made the changes suggested to them by the CDE analysis and by ACCS. We've seen
her enrollment data, facilities plans, and her balance budget and remain confident that even in
these challenging times, ECA is a school that will attract a diverse student body and will offer
a strong educational program. As such, we urge you to grant ECA's charter. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts
now. My name is Paulina Johnson and as a member of the public I'm expressing my support for the
approval of Eagle Collegiate Academy. I believe the students who will be served by the school
deserve the opportunity to attend it. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now. Hello, my name is Chad Jackson and
as a member of the public representing public interest, I support ECA and I wish to see it
recommended for approval as I believe that this charter will have a positive impact and create
effective relationships with the people and the businesses of the Santa Clarita Agua Dulce community
that it will occupy. And as a member of that community, I would love to see this charter be
approved to serve this community well. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now. My name is Tyler Goldstein. As a member of the public,
I would like to express my support for Eagle Collegiate Academy. In these increasingly
uncertain times, parents and children benefit from an increase in the choices they have in pursuing
and achieving a quality education and I believe that Eagle Collegiate Academy will add an incredible
value to the options that are currently available. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and
affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now. Good afternoon. My name is
Isabella Jones and I'm a member of the public interest and support of the approval of Eagle
Collegiate Academy. Many families in our city and surrounding areas have their kids homeschooled,
some have higher private teachers, some drive all the way to San Fernando Valley and search
of choice schools. Some have opted for some blend of these different methods for years.
I've had friends wake up very early in the morning to travel to a school for a better education.
The application by ECA will bring these students on board to do the strong commitment by ECA for
robust parent involvement. While LAUSD has over total 229 charter schools, San Antonio does not
have a charter school. Please approve this great educational alternative and choice, especially for
our Black and Brown children and families to meet the diverse educational needs and priorities for
all students and families. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record and begin speaking. Your time starts now. Hello. My name is Kristen James and I am a supporter
of Eagle Collegiate Academy. This is a sound program and good for our community. Please listen to us
and approve Eagle Collegiate Academy. We know what our children need. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now. Debbie Rodriguez, supporter of school choice in Santa Clarita Valley.
I have had the honor of being the founding office manager for both charter schools in our valley.
That would be SCVI and Albert Einstein Academy. Two very different programs but needed
in our community. When Albert Einstein surrendered their charter, it was a huge loss for our community.
Students were forced back into their home schools or some families chose to home school or put them
in private school because there was no other choice. Eagle Collegiate provides that other choice
and is desperately needed for our families. And being the office manager at AEA, we had families
where one child attended our school, the other child attended their home school, or even the
other child attended SCVI. Different programs for different learners and how lucky were those? Time.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now. Good afternoon board members and a warm welcome to our new board members.
My name is Janelle Rooley. I'm an attorney with the losses of young mini and core here today in
strong support of Eagle Collegiate Academy and urging your yes vote for approval. Eagle Collegiate
represents a remarkable story of perseverance and commitment. These are the kinds of petitioners the
legislature imagined back in 1992 when it passed the charter schools act. Parents and educators
coming together to provide choice and unique opportunities for a very localized student
population. They're not backed by large organizations. This is truly a grassroots
group. And the charter petition meets legal requirements. As you've heard, the CDE has three
times determined the educational program to be sound. We cannot fathom why that assessment
changed just in the two weeks since ACCS. ECA has a facility and it's ready to break ground
on improvement. ECA can manage through apportionment deferrals. And for each charter element, the CDE
deemed not to be reasonably comprehensive. A condition was offered to mitigate that designation.
ECA agrees to these conditions. Eagle Collegiate has passed all of the tests. It's jumped through
all of the time. It's met those legal requirements. We ask the state board to follow the mandate and
approve this charter petition. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record and begin speaking. Your time starts now. Hello, state board members. I'm Elizabeth
Chivlett and I'll be teaching art as one of the highly qualified teachers at Eagle
Collegiate Academy. Our school will accommodate a diverse population of students. We will have
staff and resources necessary to provide appropriate special education for children
with additional needs. ECA will also offer the international baccalaureate program
that trains teachers and gives them ongoing support. Students benefit from the IB program
by gaining a deeper understanding of subject matter and learning the important skills they
will need for a successful future in the 21st century. For these reasons, I'd like to ask for
your approval of Eagle Collegiate Academy so that we can offer our community students and their
parents this unique and valuable educational opportunity. Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
My name is Jones Okeke. I support Eagle Collegiate Academy. I'm a teacher with Eagle Collegiate
Academy and I have a level two specialist education instruction credential. Eagle Collegiate
Academy will have a unique group of skilled and dedicated faculty members who are patient,
knowledgeable, caring, and have drive for self-improvement. At ECA, the faculty will
place greater emphasis on refined skills and digital teaching tools. Please grant approval
for ECA today. ECA staff are determined to integrate electronic learning, remote teaching,
and virtual education as components of its overall educational model. Teachers will be
set to use online classrooms and interactive platforms to deliver lessons and assignments.
The goal of ECA will be to adequately prepare our students for tomorrow's job
and to be well rounded. Time. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time
starts now. Good afternoon. My name is Ernest Carr speaking on the behalf of Eagle Collegiate
Academy. I'm a retired educator teacher, school administrator, and one of the pool of retired
educators who is volunteering to support the operations of the academy with my skills and
time. I believe the academy will provide access, rigorous college preparation for students,
especially underrepresented and socioeconomic disadvantaged children who need this access
the most. Every child deserves a quality education no matter the socioeconomic status of their
parents or guardians. Black and brown children especially must be given the opportunity
for the access into a rigorous college preparatory program, an education environment that is
positive as well as emotional psychologically nurturing. The academy will provide this access
through its international baccalaureate program that will start in primary schools. Please
allow the families of Santa Clarita. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
I don't know if that was somebody trying to speak but we couldn't hear them.
Hello? Yes. Oh, can you hear me? Yes. Oh, I'm sorry. Does my time begin yet?
I think it's about to begin. Thank you.
Thank you. Start now. Oh, I'm sorry. My name is Derek Hill. I'm sorry. I'm one of the
founding staff members of ECA and we've been struggling to go ahead and get this approval
and I believe we're going to go ahead and continue to work at getting better and getting this
approval. I just recommend that if the state could just work with us and approve us because
we're going to keep going and with Dr. Johnson's guidance, she's going to be diligent to get this
approval. Everything that we've been asked to do to make it happen and work, we've been doing it.
We've been following all the necessary steps and we're just excited to get started. Most of the
staff have kids. Our kids are going to be ready to go ahead and go to school there. I have two
school-aged kids and we're excited and I know we on Facebook, we've been petitioning and getting
kids and families involved to come to our school and we're ready to go. If you can
approve of us and look out for us, we will definitely make this school happen and we will
populate this school. All right. Thank you for your time and thank you for listening to us.
We will not go away. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Please state your name and affiliation and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Uje Okoye. I'm a parent of two. I'm a supporter of Yubu College Academy.
My kids can't wait for the school to open for them to attend to the school. I'm
waiting for you guys to approve Yubu College Academy. Thank you so much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Ujechi Amako. I'm a mother of two and I'm highly in support of ECA.
I've worked closely with Dr. Oko Johnson, who is the CEO and founder of ECA, and I tell you,
she's not going to fail. She's a very hardworking professional teacher and she has been in
academic for a long time. And I tell you, Rome is not built in a day. We are not to be limited
by looking at the structure, which I know Oko Johnson will do her best to have a quality,
approve structural, everything she needed to do, she will do and fix it up. She has done that
for this past, all this past while that you've complained about this and that she has worked
so hard tirelessly to put up structures in place. And I believe the board will be disappointed in
future because she's even coming from a pure African background. She started in Nigeria and
came over here and worked to, you know, the peak of her career. And I tell you, she's a single mother
of four and raised four kids that successfully finished college and are very responsible. And
she will do every to her utmost best to make sure every child, every, no matter the color,
black or brown or yellow, gets the best in life. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, Ken Higginboth and Eagle Collegiate Academy. And as president of the
board of directors, I am proud to extend my many years of executive leadership and
operational experience to the mission and success of the ECA. Being the proud grandparent of two
grandchildren that attend charter schools, one just graduated class of 2020, honors students,
the high quality of learning, individual growth, academic achievement and enrichment make ECA the
pinnacle of a top tier educational institution, greatly benefiting the children and their
families. The foundation for success is evident and strong. Approval of this petition is paramount
in providing educational options in this cultural and ethnic diversified community
where black and brown children's education strongly matters. In conclusion, there is
no other public school option in Santa Clarita. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Okay, that caller hung up. We do have additional callers now that are in the
participant queue, so I will ask them if they would like to make a comment.
Hello, did you wish to make a comment for item 17?
Good afternoon board members. This is Brian Kite, managing principal of SRK Architects. I'm the
architect that has been retained to assist Euclid Academy. We have investigated the site. We believe
the site is completely feasible for use as a school. The issues that have been raised
relative to the county were done very early. Oh dear, we just lost you.
Am I back now? Yes. Thank you. We're still going through our public comments at this time.
I'm sorry. Are you calling as a public commenter? I must have misunderstood that this was that I
saw a notice notification of 17, so I just spoke, but I can speak. We're still doing public comments,
so Shauna, go ahead and continue with public comment. We'll come back to you for questions.
Thank you. We'll come back to you for questions.
Caller, did you wish to provide public comment for item 17?
Yes, I do. Please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time
starts now. My name is Ayodeji Ido. I am a resident of Santa Clarita Valley, a parent,
and supporter of Eagle College Academy. I'm also a friend of a parent of two children
who can hardly wait to send their children to ECA as soon as it opens its door. I attended a
presentation about the school and I love the international baccalaureate program. I also like
the fact that the children will be at the school from pre-K to A grade with the teachers and staff
that already know them and watch them grow. I am one of the families that filed a petition about
the school and I was determined to keep fighting until we get the school approved. Please listen
to us as parents and educators because we know what our children need. Children also learn in
different ways and we need to realize one side does not fit. So please hear our voice and approve
Eagle College Academy for our children. Thank you.
Hello caller, did you wish to make a comment, a public comment on item 17?
Caller, did you wish to make a comment on item 17?
Yes, hello. Yes, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin
speaking. Your time starts now. Hello. I can hear you.
Yes, we can hear you. Please begin speaking and we'll start your time.
Okay, thank you. Yes, my name is Eliana Howe. I hold a teaching credential and I have known
Dr. Over Johnson for over 10 years and I know that she's doing everything possible to have
the school provide all the necessary things for this community such as great education,
emotional support for the students and a safe and an amazing place to learn.
So I'm just calling to give my support and I pray and hope that you also support the school. Thank you.
Caller, did you wish to make a public comment for item 17?
Hello. Hello caller, would you like to make a public comment for item 17?
At this time we have no additional callers in the participant queue.
Okay, I guess we lost that last one. Thank you very much to everyone who presented and
took the time to make public comment. At this point I want to ask, I'm going to close the public
hearing at 4 57 p.m. and commence with board discussion and action. I want to ask Ting's son
as our state board liaison if she has initial comments then we'll move into discussion.
So well first of all I really appreciate the petitioners for their persistence and
perseverance and enthusiasm in their presentations and I have seen the petitioners and their
efforts to address concerns that the state board had expressed in their petition a year ago.
I'm also extremely impressed by the overwhelming support of the community members who had called in
for this school and clearly this is an area that needs school choice.
So I'll just leave it for that as an intro for now and then have my fellow board members ask
any questions that they have. Okay, I'm going to take the prerogative of the chair and
say a couple of things and ask a few questions and then we'll get the ball rolling with
others. I also remember when Eagle Collegiate came to the board just a year ago
and there clearly is there was enthusiasm from members of the community then and there's clearly
still enthusiasm from members of the community now. I am not concerned about the enrollment
projections because I think there was a pretty persuasive case made that this really serves
multiple districts. It is a community that has an alarming number of non-classroom based
charters and homeschooled students so there is sort of a felt need for many places for this kind
of a school. I'm not concerned about the quality of the IB program because I know that program
well and it's a very high quality program with embedded assessments and I know IB has pledged
to work with this school and I see the determination that the school has. I would like to ask
about several issues however that have been raised and we need to hear more about them.
So I'd like to ask the petitioner to be available and also the architect who was
calling in a few minutes ago. One of my questions has to do with the
facility and the plans to make it safe and adequate for students. A second question I have
has to do with the training for staff around the international baccalaureate program
and then I'll have some other questions about timing. So is the architect with us?
I am. Can you continue the thoughts you are going to share with us? Sure thank you so much.
So we were retained about three months ago in order to begin work on the ministerial site plan
review for the county and so I do believe that there was an overlap of information. We did our
due diligence about about three months ago as I said. We believe that the site is accessible
from the perspective that the buildings themselves are set back. They were originally
buildings designed originally for high occupancy and so a school is a very reasonable and normal
from our practice experience change of use from the existing use to the proposed use as a school.
We've done layouts both the site plan layouts as well as traffic studies. We retained a civil
traffic engineer to assist in striping that would be required to allow for adequate access
to the site. We've just completed a queuing study for the for the property to determine
based upon the one hour eight o'clock worst case scenario of 168 parents arriving by automobile
and queuing up and there is plenty of space. The site itself has two acres of essentially flat land
and because of the layout we believe and we've done studies to determine that not only is it
adequate for the initial pre-k through three there is space flat space available for additional
modulars for the future. So we believe that the site has all the components that a good school
should have and we wholeheartedly support it and we put our name behind the fact that we believe we
can adequately get permits for the process for the school as the time would allow.
And I assume that in the course of your analysis you've evaluated the ability to have adequate
fencing and so on between the site and the yes because yes thank you board member since the
the site is not currently occupied the temporary fence has been put up but there is along sierra
highway there's about 300 or so feet that would have new fencing place. The owner of the property
separate from the school itself has also stepped up to the plate with commitments to do all of the
what we call shell and core work separate from the tenant improvement work to convert the interior.
So the we believe that a budget for both is will be required and the landowner with your approval
of school there in this in the site will initiate a significant amount of improvement to the property
that would be normal. It was referenced about the theft of the copper wiring in our experience in
any site that is not in use the copper wiring will be stripped out and that is very normal.
They've already committed to replacing that so that puts back the there's plenty of power to the
site more than 400 amps to the site so we feel that the basic infrastructure is there but it
does need to be completed in order to to make it permissible. We do lots of school work and we
think that this is a perfectly great structure and site for this use. Can I ask you how long
you think it would take to do that work? Sure permits are not the easiest thing we'd love to
have we'd love to have six months to do that but it's the permit cost or time that it that it that
is required more so I think that the the notion of doing it in a month is probably difficult but
that's in part because of the elapsed time that's gone by you know since earlier earlier this year.
Yeah I have another question for the plaintiff I mean without the plaintiff
it does feel a little like a court of law doesn't it for the petitioner and let's see if we can
find you on our zoom screen here so I wonder if you can talk to the question of training
I'm not sure that credentialing is a problem because you're planning to be TK through grade
eight and there's most of those grades hold a common credential but IB is you know a fairly
serious change from much of the curriculum experience that many people have had so can
you talk to us about what the plans are for training staff for the IB curriculum? Yes ma'am
thank you honorable madam president yes we plan to train our teachers and it's a requirement
by IB anyway before the school starts one of the things that we plan to do or we had hoped to be
able to do was to have a two-day in-person training whereby IB will send their specialist
to the school and train the teachers and that's the required training that a two and a half days
teachers are supposed to have so they're going to do a training on how to create the lesson plans
how to assess the resources that IB has already for them and then how to be able to receive help
as they go along the way so the IB requires about two and a half days to get the clock hours
needed for teachers to get started there are three categories of IB training the very first
one which is a category one is for those who have never been in an IB at all and that's
understandable because IB is not you know here and there where there are teachers who have done it
before so IB recognizes that and as a result they plan to train you and they don't require that so
category one is for teachers who've never been in IB and they teach you and train you and help you
to get your resources your training materials by the time that training is over you would have
your lesson plans and resources ready to guide you at least for a long time into the into the
year and then there's category two which you participate in after you've already talked
for a little bit and then there's category three for those who are flying you know that will do
that along the way so we are working with a specialist have been working with us for almost
four years and they are willing and ready to come to the school and train but because of COVID
there is also online training that teachers can participate in and you go through and receive the
same quality materials and instruction during that online training for teachers to to have
in order to prepare them and that's one of the things that excites parents about this program
the fact that they know that IB requires training and that they're not just going to have teachers
who are not trained to teach as they provide curricular materials i know but two days of
training is very modest so what is the plan beyond the two days absolutely and we have that in the
in the petition as well so we're going one of the things that we built into our schedule is a
wednesday training and so we have a mini monday a half day on every wednesday just devoted to
training professional development is one of the things that we take to heart because we know that
we can't hold teachers accountable if we're not giving them the tools and the skills they need
so every wednesday teachers have the two hours every every week to just focus on pd and also
collaborating with each other so it's an ongoing weekly training throughout the year you know that
and does IB also provide coaching along the way and is there a plan for tier two and three training
yes IB does provide coaching and they will come and visit the school and that's one of the things
they have to do once you apply for candidates because i have taken this IB school leader
training we are really able to now become candidates once we're approved and then they
will come because we are assigned an IB specialist that will tell you what training you need to take
when you need to take it sequentially throughout the year so there is a plan for that coaching
and support throughout the year okay thank you very much those are my two pressing questions i
want to see if other members of the board have comments or questions looking for hands i see
um Cynthia Glover Woods
thank you um really just a couple of comments um a very strong program and again a lot of kudos for
the support in the community for the program i of course this is my first board meeting so i
didn't have the pleasure of listening to the petition when it came forward the last time but
it seems evident from my fellow board member comments and from staff that there has been a
lot of work done i do have a concern as was expressed by president Darlingham and regarding
the facility and the preparation of the facility and the thought of a august 2020 opening seems
like an extremely heavy lift considering we're in the month of july so i'm just a point of
consideration as far as if there might be benefit of moving forward with the school but doing so in
the next year so that there's sufficient time for facilities to be prepared for adequate training
in the ib program and other aspects and also to clean up some of the other areas that has been
brought forward in the board item related to the school site council membership and other pieces of
that sort so i'm just just a thought on how we might be able to possibly move forward and do
some cleanup yeah that could i piggyback on that and sort of ask the question um you know given
that you already have some people who are prepared to teach we heard from some of them who've been
part of this conversation but also that you have facility needs that could take some you know some
happy year to manage what would be the ideal time of starting would it be 2021 would it be
january of 2021 september of 2021 or how do you think about the assets and difficulties
that you have in relation to the timeline thank you very much and we appreciate that opportunity
and that's one of the reasons why my very first statement after introducing myself and thanking
you and cde staff is that we are open and we are willing and we sent a letter as early as in march
2020 recognizing the impact of covet 19 not knowing what would happen even before all the
budget changes and and the delays that we had both at the district level as well as at cde level
while we understand the delays also impacted our ability to move forward with their plan and and
with the facility and everything else so we do implore you that if you if you so wish we are
willing to move our start to the following school year because we're on a traditional calendar so
it's really best to to work that way and so we're willing to have that done even though our parents
whose children may not will be aged out again but they will be so happy they'll be three they'll be
dancing you don't even know they'll be calling you and just saying thank you that you gave
their other children an opportunity to participate in this program i will be dancing too
um member navo i think i saw your hand go up yes it did thank you um dr johnson i i am uh
really impressed with your persistence and your uh enthusiasm on this issue and i'm quickly
becoming a fan of yours i think that you're doing some um obviously this is not a trial on
your character much more about the the substance of the petition and i just want you to know that i
greatly respect the work that you're doing and how persistent you can um that being said i do have
i did watch the uh your um the accs i did watch last year's uh board meeting again
to get a feel as to where you were and i remember there were um and two several issues came up at
the accs that concerned me one is the budget um and the reality that what cd shows and the
inability to implement a fisc uh implement the program is also complicated by the reality that
we're facing a potential 11 billion dollars in deferrals because of covet um the other issue is
the facilities and i think it's the the the conflict between what the county has found
and their foundation and also what your eca architect the gentleman who spoke and what he
says is viable there's there's there's clarity issues there and i remember i watched in the last
year's um miss board member ruckers pressed you quite a bit on the facility and the e-permit and
the cap doesn't have a cafeteria doesn't have a library doesn't have a playground those things
and i don't necessarily know that those were resolved um between now and then i think there
those are probably still issues so my question to you is um with regards to the petition and
the staffing and the educational program tell me a little bit about i think the two issues
are going to be the budget and the facility so tell me a little bit about the the difference
that you see in relationship to your budget as opposed to what cde has presented on slide 12
thank you very much for that question and i will start it and then i'm going to hand it over
to our fiscal consultant because we submitted in a petition budget that was submitted
was very viable and met net assets for the five years however because of the way that cde
calculated the money about the hundred hundred thousand dollars that was supposed to be used to
do the 10 improvement it made it look like our first year wasn't viable but it is and i will let
our fiscal consultant miss lee taylor go into more details for you so that she will explain
everything and we also um did a may revise and submitted it at the cde's request on june 19
which they said that they will present to you but and that may revise was also budgeted
and it made all the net assets starting from year two and so i like i said i'll just let miss
taylor tell you a little bit more in details miss taylor thank you yeah and if you if
if you answer that i'd like to give cd an opportunity to respond to so
just absolutely absolutely thank you so much miss taylor hello board members can you hear me
yes are you okay my name is lee taylor and i would like to say thank you for the time
and thank you for the question um i've been working in charter finance uh for
over eight years and i've worked with several different charter schools
as a back office provider who've been authorized by the cde and i know your staff um at least
via email and our various correspondents and i have to say i'm shocked and concerned about
the inconsistencies and inaccuracies of the financial information and analyses that you've
been presented with over and over again we have repeatedly attempted to correct their erroneous
errors and the skewed presentation of the financial situation i will tell you that i am also
prior to a dramatic industry change i spent 20 years in financial accounting coming from a big
five cpa and um and so i'm very shocked and it took so the first thing i want to point out is
that there is an error in what you were presented we never gave them anything that said that year
one ended in negative sixty thousand dollars of net in in income what has happened is that
and and this honestly i want to acknowledge your the financial staff at the csd because
this is not consistent with what i've learned over my years of working with them
there is a misunderstanding of the difference between governmental and not-for-profit accounting
so they added expenses that do not belong and negatively skewed the numbers it took multiple
requests and multiple months to get a schedule to find out where they came up with all of these
negative adjustments we gave them a response detailing that out of all of the negative all
of the adjustments that only fifteen thousand dollars of um after the may revise revenue
reductions of a hundred and sixty five thousand dollars in revenue or in net income adjustments
were actually valid and we incorporated those into the budget but interestingly when they
were making all of these negative adjustments to the bottom line they failed to include anything
that would show a positive on the side of the school including the reduction in stirs costs
so the fifteen thousand dollars that we said yeah you know what you're right that is a valid item
and we should pick that up but oh it's more than offset by the fact that you didn't include a
credit for the reduction in employer stirs contributions that are also in the may revise budget
after and i will i understand everybody in finance and education with covid has been
scrambling to understand but every time there was a proposal or a suggestion or a conversation at
the state senate or legislature or the governor we were asked to do another revision over well what
if this happened and these are very complicated issues i'd be up at night because there was no
other discussion i'd be up at night reading the the actual laws trying to interpret them as opposed
to having other people because i had to implement them into a forecast of what might happen in two
weeks so we've done multiple re-forecasts multiple corrections and then it turns out that the revenues
are fine now so there's that issue i would like to state that very clearly
as far as deferrals and cash flows are concerned you are also being given some very significant
misleading information that i'd like to explain when it comes to accounts receivable sales this
is an incredibly complicated financing tool simply because of the way state funding flows
and the way that the borrowing has to be done it's not like going and getting a mortgage on your home
where you borrow half a million dollars and you pay it back over a term this is more like using
your credit card every month and when the bill comes you pay it off and then you you get to use
your credit card up to your available credit and then the bill comes and you pay it off so when the
cde and it this is a consistent issue that i have they tell you that the school will be borrowing
1.4 or 1.5 million dollars that's not exactly true they're borrowing the same money over and over
again so i have an apportionment that's been deferred three months so i will go to the
receivable sales and i'll say i need the cash now to make payroll to pay my rent because i can't
send vendors and iou that's not an option for not-for-profit entities do you mind if i do you
mind if i interrupt because i appreciate your um your explanation but i think i don't necessarily
know that i'm getting the gist of it yeah yeah so can i let me shift yeah narrow me down and i will
well let me shift it to cde i just if cd can stephanie is i don't know who's going to answer
this question but i'm just curious about the financials if cd can answer this is stephanie
i'm here so a couple of things um number one yes we could not um predict or what the state
legislature was going to do in terms of the budget so we did ask all the schools on appeal to us
to submit a budget based on the may revise which we now know is not what ended up in the final
budget numbers that's the only time we've asked the school to submit a new budget which we ended
up not using as as you know because the may revise didn't look like the final budget
um that the governor signed so that number one that's that's what that is and and and and it
is complicated and i have um secondly uh what was on slide 12 is the cde's analysis of the budget
that the petitioner sends in so we don't just take their budget and put it on the slide and say this
is it we do our own analysis i have um uh we do have a budget analysis person in the charter
schools division that is uh very strong and has done these analyses for several years
and i trust her work on it and so the budget analysis that we have there is is what we
analyze based on the original budget they turned in with their petition
um in february i think so that was their analysis based on the original budget any new budgets that
they have submitted since uh the accs meeting which i think they did possibly last week to
the state board as a whole we have not had the opportunity to review that yet i do think also
that i need to add in um because i i haven't had a chance to um speak um is that all this new
information that's coming out in terms of uh plans that the architect has um for instance or
the details of the ib program that's all new to us and so all of that is nothing that was heard
at the local level the district didn't get to hear the plans that the architect had
they didn't get to hear all the details about the ib program neither did the accs quite frankly
because this isn't something that was um was brought up then so there is a lot of new information
that is coming out today that we have not had the opportunity to analyze or verify or evaluate for
quality um including the budget support um since like i said we have not had the opportunity to
review the newest budget that they turned in but i do want to uh just in uh reiterate that
we had only asked them for one budget and that was me revise and that was taken out of this final
state board item because of the new budget that was signed i appreciate that stephanie and i
watched the accs and some of this information i'm aware of visiting so i appreciate your
answer so um board president i'll open i'll leave it for other board members to ask questions i have
more about facilities but i think like yeah this is why we do a de novo hearing right because
information changes uh new um new pieces of information come up over this course of time
so uh one of the things i'm curious about now is how do we get a chance to take a look at or
hear succinctly about the most recent budget of the school because we're dealing with old information
and old analyses at this point that are not relevant now and i don't know if there's a way that
the petitioner can succinctly state what that is or whether there's a way that we can
see that um i don't you know there's a lot of documents here so i did not see
it in any of the documents but i might have missed something
thank you again president our slide does have our current budget that's the only one we placed in
and then uh appendice e also in the packet that we submitted is our current budget and i will try to
be succinct because i don't have all the information that um lee has but if i could share my screen for
slide number nine then you'll be able to see hopefully succinctly what our current budget
looks like if that's okay yeah go ahead thank you
you
and now if you could make it bigger yes i'm gonna do that
is that big enough yeah can you see okay awesome thank you so much
so when you take a look at this budget here i know he's on on the other side you would see that
fiscal year 1920 is always a negative because it's a start year and that's where we borrow the money
because we don't have the money yet but when you go to oh my god sorry about that
okay i'll stop touching this
okay so when you go to year one fiscal year one um miss delah tells me that i like to see my
percentages and i do because it gives me not having all the finance background you know the
snippet of what is going on in my budget and so when you take a look at the ending net assets
for fiscal year 21 you would see that we have 120 to 91 thousand dollars as net assets which is
about 7.68 percent which is higher than the five percent that cde requires and when you go to
fiscal year 21 22 and you take a look at everything else and it goes all the way down to net assets
again you would see that it's 23.59 percent again showing that we have reserves that we can use in
uncertainties and then when you go to the last year which is the third year that cde actually
looks at you will find that we have 33 net assets and so that's like a short description of that
but how did we get there so what we did was we used the since there is no current lcff calculator
currently right now so what we did was use the may one to use the current budget that has been
approved by the governor to come up with these figures with zero color and cuts and we also
maintain to make sure that we take care of any unanticipated covet 19 impact that will show up
we don't know we decided to maintain the cuts that we created in the may revised budget and those
cuts were the ceo salary classified fte and overhead cuts so that we would make sure that
none of our programs are impacted by anything and if nothing happens then we may restore those things
and then in terms of cash flow like we also talked about for deferrals we are going to increase
receivables a ourselves and interest expense and so that's how we were able to create those balanced
budget using the current budget and the may lcff calculator so you used a conservative estimate of
state funding absolutely yes all right i want to get this to other board members member angeline
thank you i i just want to echo some of the concerns of board member nabo about the facilities i
would like to learn a little bit more just because i believe it's one thing to say
the facility is fit but i'm not quite understanding the changes that were made
just also not being here a year ago what were the issues before and how are they being addressed now
i don't think that was clearly stated so i just appreciate if someone could explain that
okay um i'm getting back on the zoom um at this point in time i would yield to our
architects if he could share the created site plan on his screen so that you can see visually
what we're trying to say to you so mr kite are you able to pull up that site plan please
mr kite you're muted you need to unmute please
i'm sorry thank you if you can allow me to share the screen i'll do my best
um stop the other sharing screens uh may i do that yes you may okay
um so one of the key uh elements of this building it's it's actually in two pieces
uh both of them were built in the in the 50s back in the 50s uh buildings were built uh very well
to our knowledge there are no foundation problems other than at that at we did determine that uh
somewhere along the line i believe that the building was built in the 50s and the building
at that at we did determine that uh somewhere along the line i believe when it was the church
there were some unpermitted structures built that are the by the definition of the code if
they're not permitted they're not actually there so um we have recommended that they be removed
because to our knowledge the way they're constructed they're they're not permitted so
they're they're small little adjunct buildings to to address that point um we went through a very
uh comprehensive analysis of the the buildings and the site according to the construction
specification institute there are 16 categories of different types of of construction we've done
a complete analysis of that and provided that to dr johnson for disposition between what would be
shell and core improvements and what would be school tenant improvements essentially on the
inside of the building and so there's a very strong line of demarcation between those two costs
but um in our professional opinion um there the the um infrastructure related costs to the shell
and core of the building such as the replacement of the windows so the building will have to be
brought up to title 24 which is the california energy standard so that standard will require
replacement of the windows uh that's an item that is accounted for to the landlord because
the landlord will own the windows for for the life of the building and that's just a basic part of
the and i think that was noted in the initial um county assessment that the windows are not to code
and that and that's certainly true so there's no element of the building that we think is
insurmountable with respect to foundations or the nature of the the framing of the building it's very
very stout building and as well as the fact that it was originally uh built as a restaurant so
there's a there's a lot of electrical mechanical infrastructure there is roof repair uh there has
been some evidence of leakage but it's it's in the repair uh it's not a it's not a comprehensive uh
take the building apart and put it back together again it's really uh very normal we've um
executed many projects very similar to this uh and didn't find anything that if we had found
anything that we thought was insurmountable we wouldn't even take the assignment
okay i want to um recognize a member mcquillin who's got his hand up unless
brenta you had any further questions on this
brenta are you on mute
and not right now okay member mcquillin we can take the slide down thank you
thank you and thank you all for the presentation very good uh mine my question is more on facilities
also and we heard from the county perspective that those cars are whizzing by there at 55 miles an
hour and then i heard the the architects say that there's room for striping is there other plans to
have a turning lane or is there a verified space for turning or safe access for all those cars to
get in and out of there is my my concern thank you
happy to answer that go ahead the uh as it exists today there are two points of entry
and our initial recommendation based upon our our traffic study uh through our our civil engineer
recommended a single point of entry that point of entry uh is actually in a portion that's
widened already so that will allow for deceleration for eastbound traffic
and and and plenty of stacking space of course the leftbound traffic is the is the one that is
the the worst case and would require the most amount of um uh if anything needs to occur
that the main thing about uh this site and this at a single point of access is that there are
complete sight lines for roughly a half a mile in either direction of aguadulce and that
is a subject that would be debated but but um we believe that normal traffic mitigation to allow
for a a left turn onto sierra highway can be accomplished it's as a school zone there would
be there would be certain striping that would occur as a result of just the fact that it would
become a school so all those things are in our uh initial investigation that we've done thus far
quite mitigatable and that's a subject that we would concern ourselves with a great deal of
course as well as our civil engineer
uh i am looking to see if there are any other board members who want to be recognized uh
and i don't see any other raised hands do we have a motion
ting do you want to make the motion yeah i would like to um you know to address some of the
concerns from the the board members and uh you know it's very difficult for a school to start
this year moving into a very uncertain 2021 school year and uh you know i do believe that
the petitioners have the background the enthusiasm and the support to successfully implement the
educational program and we do have a couple of just the facilities and some of those and just
going into next year so i would like to offer and the petitioners have um stated that they would be
willing to open and enroll in the following school year so uh i i would like to make a
recommendation that we approve this charter uh but with some conditions and i i can share those
conditions or i can i can talk through them uh if you have the floor why don't you do that now
okay so i uh i have something written would you rather see it and then
or should i maybe talk about share your screen yeah i can i'm able to do that let's see
and if not you can talk us through it okay i can share screen okay
all right i think it's easier to see it are you guys able to see that
yes you did you did it well okay great can you make it larger i hate to ask that question
i could just take my glasses off
is that okay yeah thank you all right so so what i would like to um
so i'd like to recommend that we approve the eagle collegiate academy charter it would have
to be a term for five years so it'd be from july 1st 2020 to june 30th 2025 but the school will
begin instruction between july 1st 2021 and september 30th 2021 so that would give them a
fall opening in 2021 and this would be with the caveat that you have four years
actually three years before renewal so that's going to be a quick uh quick uh turnaround for
the school the school will produce evidence of may 28th of a prospective enrollment of 168 students
because there was some worry there and i want to make sure that they are able to maintain the
numbers of students for their opening the school will submit a plan to the department of education
by october 1st that describes how eagle collegiate will implement the ib program
and then provide an update annually that describes the prior implementation outcome so that we are
ensuring that there is that consistency and the implementation moving forward that all the
facilities improvements including improvements to roadway access and occupate occupancy permits
that have been expressed the concerns have been expressed that are that those are required beginning
to begin the school operations in 2021 and it needs to be completed and ready and submitted to
cde by may 21st 2021 and the school will submit to the department of education a revised budget
with real numbers knowing where we're going to be going next year
and any changes to the charge portion that into the petition that addresses the deficiencies
including language that's outlined by the cde staff analysis
is
those are a lot of conditions i'm just trying to process them yes i understand that
it seems to me that on the second one
um they may or may not have precisely 168 students they might have you know 160 170 175
but the real goal of that should be to produce evidence that there is perspective enrollment of
a sufficient number of students to support the financial viability of the school i don't know
that it needs to be precisely 168 no more and no fewer would you take that as a friendly amendment
that would be with me it is i want to make sure because they the petitioners did propose 168
students to start with and i don't know staff wants to chime in on that but i i believe that
when we have a certain number there is a there's some flexibility in i mean usually it's you know
some minimum number that you need to make the budget viable but i don't know that we would say
you can't have more or if you have two fewer you know if you have 166 but your budget works
most charters you are are ballparking in that regard
so should we say at least 168 students yes this is judy sias generally we allow um in the mou
i'll have to double check i don't have a copy of it in front of me but in the past we've allowed
up or down by 20 to 25 percent um in order to to not be considered a material revision so that's
sort of what we've looked at in the past okay so should you think that needs to judy do you
think that needs to be in the conditions stated or do you think that we can rely on the
legislative precedent um sure we can add something as 168 students you know plus or
minus 25 if that's your preference yeah whatever the whatever the convention is that would make
sense okay um all right are there any of so we need a second on this motion then
is there a second second i'll second who was that
glover woods thank you so many so many boxes up on my screen okay we have a second
is there further discussion linda matt has his hand up okay uh member navo yeah i hate to be a
bearer of bad news here i'm i'm a little uncomfortable with it um but i have a question
to staff or board member ting on how you see this is my understand am i understanding this correctly
that if we approve this if one of any of those five is not completed then they will not open
the petitioner's budget is that how is that how we're because what what what concerns me most is
that although i appreciate the petitioner's budget having not had the cd staff have an
opportunity to review that really makes me uncomfortable about saying okay we're going
to take their budget and their information and we're going to grant them an approval so what i'm
concerned about is number five if cd doesn't come in uh doesn't agree with the petitioner's budgeting
we're going to be in this in this dilemma and cd needs to make a call and so i'm wondering if
we get to number five and they don't agree with the budget the petitioner's budget templates
or the budget plan then i'm assuming it doesn't open um this is judy size again i i think
conditional approval is always legally challenging and the reality is by the time the school opens
next may there will be another budget right because we will have another state budget at the time
so if it gets to that point we will um possibly have to come back to you all um if it gets to
where things do not look viable for the school um and we are unable to reach agreement with the
school um the budget situation is obviously very unclear right now for all school districts and
charter schools okay well that that helps so judy if i understand you because they had a seven one
vote uh for not opening on accs so by us approving this on conditions if one of those five doesn't
come to fruition they'll come back to us you're asking the question matt whether it will come
back to us correct one of these five is a question of any kind right i i think what
i have to meet all five conditions they have to meet this this is judy that they'd have to meet
those five conditions and if there's a disagreement with the school whether or not those five conditions
have been satisfied and then it's a choice of whether or not they will open or not then they
will have to come back to you okay the issue with the budget which i don't believe is the is the
fault of petitioner is they submitted an original budget there was some disagreement with cde on how
that budget was uh and analyzed it sounds like there was not the communication or agreement but
before then then cde did an analysis based on the may revise of their budget using the may revise
they responded to that which caused more confusion and now we no longer have the may revise we have
another set of numbers to go with so there has been quite a bit of back and forth and i don't
feel that that is um the the fault of the the petitioner so i and they're not necessarily
real numbers they don't have real numbers really to work with until we know better what the budget
conditions are so this is this is judy again i i would add that um cde treats all budgets the same
the way they analyze the budgets and the numbers they back out and how they analyze budgets
they treat them all the same so i would disagree strongly with how um the budget analysis presented
by some of the petitioner statements um that being said the it's true the budget situation
is uncertain right now i i think that's an understatement and that's true for all districts
and charter schools and you who knows if the state is going to have to reopen their budget
in a few months we just don't know with covid the uncertainty is is clear
so if there is a question mark or disagreement about the adequacy of the budget it will come back
to us right is that what is that the main question i think what i would say is again if there is a
question about whether or not these conditions have been satisfied and there's a back and forth
with the school and it's unclear whether the conditions have been satisfied as such that they
can open that then it will come back to you if that question is outstanding okay thank you
um all right we have a motion we have a second are there any other board members with questions
or discussion
seeing none uh we will need a roll call vote karen can you um hold the roll call yes kim
yes
i day yes matt
yes cynthia yes linda yes eileen yeah
you eileen i couldn't hear you yes ting yes jim yes breanna
yes and patricia record but i don't think she's rejoined us patricia are you there
no okay so um of everyone voting it was unanimous one that we it passed all right thank you very
much to all the presenters and to the staff uh for all of this work uh and uh we are now ready to
take general public comment which is the last thing between us and dinner i just want you to
know hold on we're almost there uh we'll put the public comment slide up general public comment
is invited on any matter that was not included in the printed agenda and we will open the
phone line and we need the general public comment slide chad can you put up the general public
comment thank you
we're getting there but we're not there yet
might be the last slide here we go uh so members of the public wishing to provide
comment on this item they do so by calling 712-432-0075 and following the instructions
on the slide and with that said i know there's a little lag so we'll be patient
while we ask if there are any public comments we do have two commenters in the skew all right
speaker please state your name and your affiliation for the record and your time starts now
now
hello yes speaker please go ahead and and start oh uh this is mrs areas and my son
is with me so we request a two minute comment please he's gonna start
uh yes go ahead
hello my name is samuel areas i am a 10 year old student in fourth grade i need help in math
and in reading fontana unified school district has failed due process and gets me not to provide
services please assure selpa
please assure selpa's youth funds to provide services not to litigate against students
please help children like me and me thank you for your support thank you second speaker
yes good afternoon the state board of education my name is maria areas i am the parent of three
children with special needs my local support department within the fontana unified school
district has wrongfully used taxpayer funds to litigate against special needs children
my family included this is all while requesting additional funds for special education alone
the legal vendor has also request payment protection program ppt loans while filing
against special education children i have completed public record act request
and for the past three years fusd has spent 469,953 dollars in legal fees
fusd is using funds to that should be going to students not towards litigation if you wish to
find more information about all this information that i provided you today please support my local
movement the youtube movement every student successful more education less litigation thank
you for the opportunity to make a comment time have a great day
next speaker
please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
can you hear me okay yes please uh state your name and affiliation for the record and your
time will start now thank you my name is rita louf i am a parent and a member of the samarandino
county board of education our family has been victimized by some of the law firms that districts
contract with i was involved in a litigation in the west end selpa which lasted seven years selpa
litigated all the way to the nine circuit court of appeals to deny my child special education services
they lost but the lawyers billed the district for every single minute throughout the seven years
now amid the coronavirus outbreak another vendor the law firm of fagan friedman and full frost
is suing children with disabilities on march 18th while our state was under stay home orders fff
sued our family for 12 000 dollars arguing they are due the money they needlessly spent on hiring
private investigators to conduct surveillance on our family's attorney and private tutor
they spent over 120 000 dollars in an eight month period to speaker your time has
ended thank you thank you please look into it thank you
next speaker your uh please introduce yourself to the record for the record
and your affiliation your time starts now
hi good afternoon can you hear me okay yes thank you okay thank you my name is marianne grozner
i am the mother of two children with special needs my youngest son is very impacted by autism and is
non-verbal he was in a public school system but we had to pull him out because our school district
was getting ready to sue us for a third time and we honestly could not afford to keep paying
attorneys to keep my son in the public school system something is seriously amiss with the
public school system if you disagree with what the iep team offers you get sued and this is what
happened to us the second time around the school district didn't have a placement for my son for
the first three weeks after the school year started so we exercised our right to file due
process but yet the school district sued us back saying our lawsuit was frivolous it doesn't seem
right that the school district can use their own budget our taxpayer dollars to pay for-profit
litigators to deny services to children with disabilities and i want you to know that parents
don't have these kinds of resources and denying services impacts these vulnerable children the
speaker your time is up
thank you there are no more public speakers thank you
thank you very much i will now adjourn today's meeting at 5 57 p.m.
we will reconvene at 8 30 a.m. tomorrow morning